TODAY'S BUDGET HEARING THIS
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE-
NUMBER TWO ON EDUCATION
FINANCE. THIS IS THE MAY REVISE
HEARING WE'RE NOT TAKING ANY
ACTIONS TODAY- BUT OF COURSE WE
HAVE PLAYED THIS QUESTION ON.
THE PROPOSAL IS ABOUT THE- MAY
REVISE THIS IS OF COURSE STILL
THAT SOCIALLY DISTANCE HEARING
WILL A PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE HEARING ON ALL THREE
ISSUES OTHERS A TELEPHONE LINE
ON THE AGENDA- YOU CAN GO TO
OUR WEBSITE OR- TAKE NOTE HERE
IT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN- THIS IS- WE HAVEN'T BEEN
HERE FOR NEARLY A COUPLE MONTHS
IT SEEMS- BECAUSE OF THE-
TRUNCATED SCHEDULE THIS YEAR
BUT WE'RE BACK HERE WITH THE
MAY REVISE- WE HAVE. AS WE SAID
EARLIER THIS YEAR A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO. REINVEST IN OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM AND NOW
FRANKLY A HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET ON
TOP OF THE PRESIDENT BY AN
AMERICAN FAMILY PLANNING-
CERTAINLY ALWAYS OUR FOCUS IS
K. TWELVE EDUCATION WE HAVE A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
TRANSFORM OUR EARLY EDUCATION
SYSTEM. FROM CHILD CARE ACTS
LAST ACCESS TO TRADITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS WHICH WILL BE A BIG
PART OF OUR AGENDA TODAY- I
KNOW WE HAVE SOME FINER DETAILS
WE NEED TO SORT OUT AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH ALL.
PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
BUDGET OUR PLAN WE'RE DOING
THIS YEAR IS A WIN WIN WIN- WE
DON'T WANT TO PICK WINNERS AND
LOSERS WE WANT TO. HELP
EVERYBODY- SUCCEED MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR FAMILIES AND
KIDS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. SO
WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE WHICH IS THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSALS
RELATED TO EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ALEJO. A CD E. AND
SOCIAL SERVICES SEVERAS. STARK
IN THAT ORDER THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
AND IT UP TO MY COLLEAGUES AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. TO GET A START. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER TOOK. A DEPUTY AT THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES NOT
JUST GIVE A QUICK OVERVIEW SOME
OF THE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS.
SINCE THAT WERE IN YOUR AT. AND
AS AS THE CHAIR JUST INDICATED
THE CORPORATE NINETEEN. HAS HAD.
IMPACTS ON THE CHILD CARE
SECTOR AND I'M PARENTS AND
CHILDREN WHO RELY ON CHILD CARE
TO SUPPORT EARLY LEARNING AND
ECONOMIC STABILITY. THE MAIN
CHEN BUILT ON PRIOR INVESTMENTS
TO ADDRESS THIS DISRUPTION. ON
THE CHILDREN FAMILIES AND WORK
WITH THIS INCLUDES INVESTMENTS
IN RELIEF FOR THE WORKS FOR.
ACCESS AND INVEST TO STRENGTHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MAKE SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS. FEDERAL FUNDING
WILL CONTINUE TO BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN PROVIDING FOR
THE RECOVERY AND SUPPORTING
STABILITY OF FAMILIES AND THE
WORK FORCE AND THE PROGRAM
SERVING. THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL ALSO CONTINUE TO BUILD
OCCUPATIONS FROM THE MASTER
PLAN AND- AIR TO TRANSFORM THE
STATE'S CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
WE'RE FULLY COMMITTED AS WELL
TO A SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION OF.
PROGRAMS FROM CD ET CDSS
AFFECTED JULY FIRST AS WE
DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY IN THIS
COMMITTEE. SO WITH RESPECT TO
SOME OF THE DETAILS IN THE MAY
REVISION THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS OF FEDERAL RELIEF
FUNDING THESE INCLUDE ONE TIME
STIPENDS TO ALL LICENSED FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOME PROVIDERS AND
IT ISN'T JUST TEARED STIPENDS
FOR LEISTON CENTERS. FROM.
THREE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED TO
SIX THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. ONE TIME PROVIDER
STIPENDS OF SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER CHILD WHO RECEIVES A
SUBSIDY. WE ARE A FAMILY FEES
FOR ALL FAMILIES THROUGH THE
END OF JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
A ONE TIME INVESTMENT IN THE
CHILD CARE AND IS A PROJECT TO
BUILD CAPACITY. AND LICENSE
PROVIDERS IN CHILD CARE DESERTS.
A ONE TIME INVESTMENT TO EXPAND
THE CALIFORNIA INCLUSION OF
BEHAVIOR CONSULTATION SERVICES
SO THAT WE CAN SUPPORT THE
CHILD CARE WORKFORCE AND THE
NEEDS OF CHILDREN. SIXTEEN
ADDITIONAL PAID NON OPERATIONAL
DAYS FOR COVERT NINETEEN
RELATED CLOSURES AND A
CONTINUATION OF THE HOLD
HARMLESS POLICY THAT HE'S
CONTRACTED PROVIDERS BASED ON
THE MAXIMUM LEVEL OF. THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE IN ADDITION TO
INVESTMENTS ALREADY MADE
THROUGH CARE SPENDING AND
THROUGH A PANDEMIC RELIEF
PACKAGE ENACT. EARLIER THIS
YEAR AND THEY REFLECT AN
AGREEMENT THAT WAS REACHED
THROUGH A WORKGROUP PROCESS
MINISTRATION AND THE CHILD.
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED YEAH.
CRITICALLY THE MAY REVISION
ALSO PROPOSES TO ADD MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILD CARE
SLOTS. SIXTY THREE THOUSAND OF
THESE SLOTS ARE ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM CAPTURES. THAT
CAN HELP TO PROVIDE PARENTAL
CHOICE AND ENSURE THAT FAMILIES
WITH VARIABLE IN NONTRADITIONAL
WORK SCHEDULES CAN ONLY ACCESS
CHILDCARE DEVELOPMENT SERVICES.
INVESTMENT IN FORTY TWO
THOUSAND GENERAL CHILD CARE
SLOTS WILL ALSO HELP TO
INCREASE ACCESS AND ALLOW
PERCENT FOCUS AS WELL AND
SERVING INFANTS AND TOP. THERE
ARE AN ADDITIONAL. ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED TWELVE. IN MY
CURRENT ALTERNATIVE PROGRAM AND
FIVE HUNDRED SLOTS FOR THE
EMERGENCY BRIDGE PROGRAM FOR
FOSTER. IN RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTION IN YOUR AGENDA
REGARDING THE INTERACTION OF
RATES AND SLAPS WE WANT TO
EXPRESS THAT WE ARE NOT
CONCERNED WITH THE UPTAKE OF
THESE ADDITIONAL SLOTS. THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT WAIT LISTS AND
A GREAT DEAL OF UNMET NEED AND
HISTORICALLY ADDITIONAL ABOUT
YOUR SPOTS HAVE BEEN QUICKLY
REALIZED. ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS BUT I'D LIKE TO
FIGHT IN THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN INVESTMENTS
IN INFRASTRUCTURE. TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS TO
INVEST IN LOCAL RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL AGENCIES. SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF DIRECT DEPOSIT PAYMENTS FOR
PROVIDERS. OR CONTRACTORS- FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. TO SUPPORT THE
INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE
DESIGN OF A CHILD CARE DATA
SYSTEM TO MEET THE FAMILIES AND
WORK FORCE. TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO CREATE AN
INTERAGENCY LOAN FUNDS SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE BUT- CONTRACTOR
FLEXIBLE PLEASE TO TRANSFER
FUNDS BETWEEN GENERAL CHILD
CARE AND STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS. AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR A MULTI YEAR EFFORT
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO EXAMINE ITS ACT
EXISTING CHILD CARE QUALITY.
SUPPORT AND SYSTEMS. YOUR
AGENDA ASKS THE QUESTION ABOUT
THE DATE OF BIRTH WHICH I
DEFERRED MY CAR THAT CHOW WHEN
SHE- WITH YOU. ANOTHER QUESTION
IN YOUR AGENDA IS ABOUT THE
INVESTMENT OF FEDERAL FUNDS
TOWARD CHANGES IN THE-
QUALITIES THAT. HOW INCLUDED
TWENTY DOLLAR FOR A YEAR TO
STRIKE QUALITY. MISTER A SYSTEM.
IS THE CDF PROJECT FUNDED BY
FEDERAL CARE COM WILL TRANSFER
TO THE DEATH WITHOUT A IN ME
CHANGES. THIS FUND OF ABOUT
SUPPORTING FOOTBALL RANGE AND
CHANGES INCLUDING AT TEN AS AND
A- THE QUALITY INVESTMENT TO
INFER POLICY SETTING AN
PROGRAMS. THE CRITICAL CAN.
FROM STATE WERE QUESTIONS OF
HOW DEFINE QUALITY. AND HOW TO
PAY YOUR INVEST IN THE GREEN
PARTY. WITH A FOCUS IN PART ON
A DRY AND- THIS FUNDING BE USED
FOR. COUNCIL AND TO SUPPORT THE
ENGAGEMENT I HAVE CLIENTS AND
THE WORK FOR. IN THE PROCESS OF.
AND BIG TO END. AND BETTER
RESPONSIVE TO THIS IN. YOUR
CHEN ALSO I THAT REGARDING AND
IN PARTICULAR THE NEIGHBOR TO
THE NOT UP REGIONAL RIGHT IN
MINISTRATION IT. THAT AND OF
RATE TO THE CARE. AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT THE RATE
FOR WHICH IS ALSO BEEN REYES IT
LOOKS CONCERN BY NOW STATE AND
THREW THEM PLAN PROCESS. GREAT
SETTING IS WITH THE STATUTORY
OF. BETWEEN THE ADMIN. AND THE
NEW REFORM CHAO CARE FROM AND
IN. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE- TO
WHICH READY RELATED ISSUES. AND
MAIN TO NOT IS THAT PROPOSAL AT
THIS TIME. FINALLY I WANT TO
EMPLOY THAT CLASS AND SEE
CONTINUE TO WORK. GATES
MISSISSIPPI WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND OF COURSE WITH ALL YOU WHO
CARE. DEEPLY ABOUT OUR CHILD
CARE. I THINK ABOUT IT OVER I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU TO GO NAY TO
OKAY I THINK WE HAD SOME. HERE
SO WE THE PERMANENT. TO PRESENT
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PAPA.
THEN L. A. AND THEN ADDS- OP
FOR DEPARTMENTS SO YOU DON'T
ALL HAVE TO SPEAK WE HAVE A BIG
AGENDA AND MEMBERS WANT TO
ENGAGE TO SELL SOME OF THAT-
DEPARTMENTS ARE HERE JUST IF WE
HAVE QUESTIONS SO. LET'S GO
BACK TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THEN ELIA. THROUGH ARE DO
YOU JUST WANT TO GIVE ANOTHER
OVERVIEW. PLEASE REPEAT
QUESTION. D. HE- I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT ALL SERVE. KIND OF
DID YOUR RAW SO IF YOU THEY
THINK THEY MESSED. YOU DON'T
HAVE DO THAT NO NOT THREE
EVERYTHING THEY. NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS MOMENT
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU L. A.
L. MORE FAIR COURTS WITH THE
LETTER ANALYST'S OFFICE HAVE A
FEW LEVEL COMING BASED ON
UNDERSTANDING OF CHILD CARE
GIVERS PACKET. WE WOULD NOT
THAT ARE OF THE PACKAGING HAVE
ALL AS BUDGET CONTINUE TO BE A
BIT. SO FIRST COMMENT. IT'S
ABOUT THE FUNDED SLOTS- OF THE
SIX. SIXTY THOUSAND SLOTS OF
THE HUNDRED FIVE FUND WITH WIDE
PURPLE. WE ASKED BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF SLOTS THAT AREN'T
WITH. WITH AND TWO TWENTY TWO
TO THREE. SO BIG BECAUSE OF
THIS WE DO RIGHT. ALL A- OUR
WITH. ONE WE ESTIMATE THE
ACTION WOULD COST TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY FOUR MILLION. WITH
THE REMAINDER OF THE FUNDS THE
STATE COULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
VOUCHERS PLUS UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
WE RECOMMEND ABOUT GEORGE LOTS
INSTEAD OF GENERAL CHILD CARE
SPOTS BECAUSE OF THE TEMPORARY
NATURE OF THE FUNDS SOURCED
THAT'S NOT YOUR FAULT YOU'RE
ABLE TO BEGIN. USING SLOTS- BUT
SHE QUICKER THAN GENERAL
CHILDCARE- DONALD TRUMP
WRITERS. WITH THIS PLAN IS TO
MAKE THE STATE WOULD BE ABLE TO
FUND THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
CHARACTERS LEFT FROM OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
WORK- COACH. FIRST OF ALL IT'S
DISABLING FAMILIES FROM CHILD
CARE BOTH IN JUNE TWENTY TWO IN
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY THREE- ONE
TEMPORARY STOCKS ARE SET TO
EXPIRE HE PUSHES THE DATE BACK
OF THE SYSTEM MOMENT UNTIL JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY. WORK ON THE
STATE COULD CONTINUE BECAUSE
LIKE BY DEFINING ONGOING
FUNDING STORES. UNDER THIS
APPROACH THE STATE WITH NEED TO
IDENTIFY UNDER THE UNDER OF THE
LA OVERCOME BIGELOW STREET
ACROSS THE STATE WOULD BE TO
IDENTIFY FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE MILLION. OF ONGOING
RESOURCE IN THE BUDGET BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROACH THE STATE
WOULD NEED TO IDENTIFY TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY FOUR MILLION
AND ONGOING RESTRICTIONS BY
JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND THEN
ANOTHER EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO MILLION UP ON
FOREIGN. RESOURCES BY JULY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE- ARE.
CRIMINAL THE FLOOR IS WITH
REGARD TO MIX EXPERIENCE- OF
THE FIX. FIVE GOING TO PROGRAM.
NO I JUST THINK GAME DEFINITELY
OF THE DOING BANKS. THE BILL
PACKAGED. WHAT 6% THE STOCK. IS
GOING VOUCH PRO. IN THE RING.
FOR PER. THANK GOING TO TREND
PRO. THE LEGISLATURE MIDDLE
COULD DIFFERENT MAKES TO PAY ON
ITS- FOR EXAMPLE IF THE ALREADY
WHAT'S YOUR MEDIA. ACCESS TO
CHILD- PUBLIC WITH ONE OF. MORE
LAST UNDER THE TYPICAL TAKES
NINE MONTHS TO UP GENERAL
CHANNEL CARE SPOTS DUE TO THIS
CONTRA. CROSS AND ONLY A FEW
MONTHS WRAP UP THE DOCTORS. THE
LATEST MABEL TO. GENERAL CHILD
SLOTS IF WANTS TO A BETTER
SPECIFIC IF GROUPS SUCH INTENSE.
BOTH OUTRAGE I DON'T CARE
PROGRAM I'M SORRY. THINGS BUT
THE STATE HAS MORE ABILITY TO
PRIORITIZE. BY AGE OF THEM BY
AGE GROUP AND- TRY CARE BECAUSE
OF THE CONTRACTING. PROCESS
THANK YOU YOUR CALL MAY IN
THERE ABOUT THE- PACKAGE TO HOW
THE STATE IS LEADING FOR HEALTH
HOW GOVERNOR PROPOSED. TO
EXPAND THE FEDERAL RELIEF. SO
THE FIRST IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS
FAILED INCLUDE FOR TO FULLY TO
POINT THREE BILLION OF CARE.
ARE FUNDS- WHAT THIS CHILD
STABLE THE FUNDING FOR PARKS
THE IS TO PROVIDE GRANTS CHILD
CARE PROVIDER TO PAY FOR COSTA
AS- RENT CLEANINGS THE-
STABILIZATION- TRAVESTY WITH
THE FUNDS TO WILL TO PUT THREE.
THEY MUST BE FULLY BY.
THIRTIETH TWO TWO THREE HOWEVER
THE FEDERAL STRONGLY STATES TO
EXPAND THESE. BUTTONS BY
DECEMBER ELEVENTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE CONGRESSIONAL TO
HEAR WAS THAT THESE
RESTRICTIONS BE USED TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE FISCAL RELIEF PITCHER
THE CHILD CARE SECTOR. AND I
THINK WITH PROVIDERS THAT ARE
NOT PARTICIPATING IN THE
SUBSIDIZED PROGRAM THE STATE'S
THE DEVELOPMENT APPLICATION
WARNS THAT BRITAIN. SHOULD
CHILD CARE. PROVIDERS BASED ON
OPERATING EXPENSES. SACRAMENTO
IS WITH REGARD TO THE CHOI AND
FIFTY MILLION. AND PARKER.
UNFUNDED PROPOSED IN FRESH
GRANTS WE WOULD JUST YOU KNOW
THAT ARE BUT SHALL CARE. CANNOT
BE EITHER FOR WHICH- OF A
THREE. PLAN IT IS IMPORTANT
INCLUDE MINUTE MINOR INTERFACE.
SUCH AS INSTALLING NEW AGE
FACTORS DETECTED IS THAT A
LOCAL USE OF THE R. PROVIDE. SO
GIVEN THESE RESTRICTIONS IF THE
SCOPE OF THE PROPOSAL WILL NEED
TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFIED TO
EXCLUDE. ACQUISITION
CONSTRUCTION AND THE
DEVELOPMENT. ORDER THE PROPOSAL
WOULD BE TO BE FUNDED WITH.
GENERAL FUND. THIS CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS BUT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT. THE APPROPRIATE
TIME OKAY THANK YOU. WE HEARD
FROM THE SOCIAL. TO DEPARTMENT
OF A- HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD. WE
DEAR GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SERENATA MARC AND
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY. WE ARE VERY
HAPPY TO SEE SO MUCH IN THIS
PROPOSED MAY REVISED RELATED TO
EARLY EDUCATION WITH A HISTORIC
AND UNPRECEDENTED PROPOSED
INVESTMENT FOR T. K. EXPANSION
IN THE EARLY LEARNING CARE
SYSTEM A COUPLE. WE'LL BE
SAVING A REMARKS REGARDING THE
T. K. PROPOSAL FOR THE NEXT
PANEL. BUT WANTED TO BEGIN WITH
SHARING WHAT WE KNOW FROM
DECADES WORTH OF RESEARCH AS WE
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THESE
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS LEVERAGE
THE PROMISE OF EARLY EDUCATION.
HIGH QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
EXPERIENCES CAN HAVE IMPACTS ON
THOSE SHORT TERM OUTCOMES LIKE
TEST SCORES. AS WELL AS LONG
TERM OUT KINDS INCLUDING GRADE
RETENTION REDUCTION IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION PLACEMENT HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION AND LATER INCOME AND
BECOMING A HOMEOWNER. THESE
HIGH QUALITY LEARNING
EXPERIENCES IN THE PRESCHOOL
YEARS ARE POSSIBLE INTO SCHOOL
BASED AND COMMUNITY BASED
SETTINGS. RECENT RESEARCH OUT
OF BOSTON AND THAT THEIR LOCAL
EDUCATION. BASED PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM BOOSTING COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE SAT TEST TAKING AND
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES
AND ALSO DECREASED JUVENILE IN
PERSON INSPIRATION. HOWEVER
HIGH QUALITY PRESCHOOL LEARNING
EXPERIENCES REQUIRE INTENTIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN A WELL QUALIFIED
EDUCATORS DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE ENVIRONMENTS
THOUGHTFUL CURRICULUM
MEANINGFUL FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
AND SUPPORT FOR MULTI LINGUAL
AND STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
DESPITE THAT MAYBE PRICES MAJOR
INVESTMENT IN TEEKAY WE KNOW
THAT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE
TO BE A BIG PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S PRESCHOOL SYSTEM.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AS THEY
DEVELOPED A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE AT CSGP IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE MASTER PLAN
RECOMMENDATIONS. A BIG PART OF
STABILIZING THE FUTURE AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF THIS THE FTP
PROGRAM WILL BE ADDRESSING
COMPENSATION. RATES AND THE
COST OF PROVIDING QUALITY CARE.
SAID THERE'S A LITTLE BACK
STATEMENTS WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO
SEE THE ME REVISED INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR ONE TIME STATEMENT.
WHICH WILL HELP WITH THE ONE
TIME HIGHER COSTS DUE TO COOK
AT NINETEEN. THE SUPER COLA.
WELL WE APPRECIATE RECEIVING A
CALL OF OUR PROGRAMS YOU ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR PRESCHOOL.
PROGRAMS DID NOT RECEIVE A CALL
ALLOW ASK YEAR IN LIGHT OF THE
GAP PROPOSED. HE TOLD AS WELL
AS HOW MUCH OF HER ARE
STRUGGLING WE WOULD ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALSO ALLOCATE
THE SAME COLLECTED THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM FOR C. S. B. T.
ADVOCATE TWELFTH. RCS PP RATES
ONE CRITICAL PIECE THAT WE WILL
NEED TO ADDRESS AT THE STATE.
IS ABLE TO KEEP CURRENCIES P.
FROM GOING OUT OF BUSINESS AND
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THE MASTER
PLAN. IS ADDRESSING THE C. S.
P. P. RATE WHICH IS FAR BEHIND
THE T. K. RATE AS WELL AS THE
AVERAGE. ARMAR A REGIONAL
MARKET RATE FOR VOUCHER BASED
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS. EVEN WITH
THE PROPOSED COLETTE THAT MAYBE
IF I SEE S. P. P. S. OUR RATE
IS ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND LESS
PER CHILD THAN THE AVERAGE RMR
FOR THE SAME EACH CHILD. IN A
CENTER SETTING THAT IS NOT
REQUIRED TO MEET THE HE THE
LEVEL OF QUALITY STANDARDS. IT
IS ALSO LESS THAN THE AVERAGE
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME RIGHT
WHERE THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT
FOR ANY EDUCATION OR ANYTHING
BEYOND BASIC HEALTH AND SAFETY.
THE T. K. PROGRAMS ALSO
RECEIVED SIGNIFICANTLY MORE PER
CHILD PER DAY AND THE CSP KEEP
PROGRAMS. ABOUT 76% MORE
FRIENDS PER CHILD PER DAY THEN
THE PART DAY. AND 9% MORE AND A
FULL DAY. ADDITIONALLY THERE
ARE TWO OTHER AREAS WHERE
INVESTMENTS ARE NEEDED PER CDC
S. P. P. PROGRAMS. DIRECT
DEPOSIT. THEY MADE A REVISION
PROVIDES THE CDS THAT'S WITH
SIX MILLION TO SUPPORT DIRECTOR
PROCESS. FOR THE CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS UNDER THEIR PURVIEW.
AS THIS DOESN'T ADDRESS YES PP
THIS CD WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SIMILAR RESOURCES APPROPRIATED
TO ALLOW DIRECT DEPOSIT FOR
CSGP CONTRACTORS. ALTERNATIVELY
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALLOCATE
THE RESOURCES CURRENTLY PLANNED
FOR THIS TO THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. SAID THAT
A STATEWIDE SOLUTION THAT WOULD
APPLY TO BOTH DEPARTMENTS AND
ALL PROGRAMS AND EARLY LEARNING
CARE CAN BE DEVELOPED WHILE
MAINTAINING THAT. TRANSPARENCY
OF STATE ACCOUNTING DATA
THROUGH THE FISCAL ASSISTANT
INSTEAD OF MOVING OUTSIDE OF
IT. AND THEN TAKE. THE CD WILL
HAVE DATA NEEDS FOR C. S. B. P.
AND RIGHT OF CONNECTIONS TO
CRADLE TO CAREER. ON THE MASTER
PLAN GOALS AROUND P. THREE
ALIGNMENT. OVER THE NEXT YEAR
WE WILL BE DIVING INTO WHAT IS
NEEDED TO ESTABLISH UNIQUE
IDENTIFIERS AT THE CHILD
PROVIDER AND FAMILY LEVEL. TO
ENSURE THAT STATE PRESCHOOL
DATA CAN CONNECT WITH THE
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM.
WE BELIEVE THE NEXT STEPS FOR
CD IN THE SPACE IS TO BRING ON
PROJECT MANAGEMENT. TO NAVIGATE
THROUGH THE STATE'S PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE HOW PROCESS.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY. THANK. YOU SO
MUCH THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS.
OKAY THANK YOU. I'LL TAKE ROLE
ROQUE. WE COULD. MCCARTY HERE
GALLAGHER PLEASE BEAR MEDINA.
O'DONNELL BRASS. BY A DARK YEAH.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM AT AGAIN
WE WILL BE TAKING VOTES TODAY
AB DISS INFORMATIONAL FOR TODAY
SO WE CAN NOW BEGIN WITH A
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RELATED TO THE ISSUE
NUMBER ONE THE GOVERNOR'S EARLY
EDUCATION PACKAGE- NOT RELATED
TO K. THAT'S ISSUE NUMBER TWO
KATO EXISTENCE IS THE C. D. AND
E. S. S. PROGRAMS ALL I'LL HAVE
A FEW QUESTIONS BUT I CAN.
START WITH OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANYBODY SOMEONE MEMBER
VITAS. THANK YOU- SO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF WHAT. THIS IS
BEEN A DEVASTATING YEAR- FOR
CHILD CARE FOR FAMILIES- I KNOW
IN MY DISTRICT WE'VE LOST OLD
NEARLY- THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS- I'M
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND REBUILDING-
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- ARE YOU DO YOU FEEL
LIKE YOUR DEPARTMENT IS
PREPARED DO YOU NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES- ARE THERE ENOUGH
RESOURCES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- FOR YOU TO START TO.
ADD YOU HAVE ENOUGH ANALYSTS IN
YOUR COMMUNITY CHILD CARE
LICENSING- TO START TOO
APPROVAL LICENCES RAPIDLY- I DO
FEEL SUPPORTED. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OUR COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
DIVISION DOES INDEED STAND
READY TO CONTINUE TO. ENSURE
THAT LICENSING IS THAT IS THE
SMOOTH AND EFFICIENT PROCESS WE
ALSO DO HAVE SOME INVESTMENTS
IN- BUT I MENTIONED IN THE
OVERVIEW WITH RESPECT TO BOTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IN TERMS OF THE
BUILDINGS THEMSELVES. BUT ALSO
WITH RESPECT TO CAPACITY
BUILDING IN THE FIELD AND WE
FEEL THAT THESE ARE CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS EXACTLY
BE CRISIS THAT YOU ARE
DESCRIBING. AND WHAT DO YOU
ANTICIPATE HOW LONG WOULD THE
PROCESS BE FOR A NEW PROVIDER-
WANTING TO. SECURE A LICENSE TO
PROVIDE CHILD CARE SLOTS AND IS
THERE DO YOU HOW MANY APPS DO
HAVE APPLICATIONS FOR- EXPECT
FOR FROM PROVIDERS TO EXPAND
THEIR SLOTS. WE DO HAVE
APPLICATIONS FROM PROVIDERS TO
EXPAND THEIR SPOTS WE DO
RECEIVE THOSE WE ALSO HAVE
RECEIVED DURING THE PANDEMIC OF
COURSE QUITE A FEW NOTICES THE
CLOSURE FROM. PROVIDERS SO ARE
KEY TO CONVINCING DIVISION
PROVIDES TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
ON A REGULAR BASIS APPLICANTS-
WHO ARE APPLYING FOR LICENSURE
OR WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
EXPANDING THEIR LIGHTS INJURE.
THANK YOU WE DO ALSO TRACKED
CLOSELY HAVE SHARED WITH YOU
BEFORE THE CLOSURE DATA YEAH IF
WE COULD JUST IF YOU COULD HAVE
MY MAYBE WE CAN GET ON THAT A
CALL OFF LINE I JUST I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND IF WE'RE ACTUALLY
SEEING GROWTH- IF I'M JUST
TRYING TO STAND UNDERSTAND
WHERE WE'RE AT. I'M SO MAYBE WE
CAN DO THAT I ADDED A LITTLE
LATER DATE- SO. IN CHILD CARE
ADVOCATES HAVE BEEN EXPRESSING
SOME CONCERNS WITH MANY OF THE
COMBAT COMPONENTS- PROPOSED
CHILD CARE EXPANSION
PARTICULARLY WITH THE LACK OF
RATE INCREASE THE DATA SHOWS
THAT THE AVERAGE ANNUAL PAY FOR
CHILD. CARE PROVIDER IS ABOUT
TO TWENTY TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO DOLLARS
SO HOW DO THEY PROPOSE STIPENDS
IMPACT PROVIDERS COMPARED TO
RATE INCREASES- THIS MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. WE'RE CONTINUING TO
LOOK INTO THIS TOPIC OUR- RATE
REIMBURSEMENT AND WE LOOK. WE
LOOK TO FURTHER TO FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS TOPIC AS OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE ARE AT THE
SEVENTY FIFTH PERCENT NOW OF
THE- R. TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN SURVEY HOWEVER
AS MENTIONED WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
DISCUSSION. SO DO YOU KNOW
WHO'S GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS STIPEND IS IT PROVIDERS
CURRENTLY OPEN- AND PROVIDING
CARE PROVIDERS THAT WERE OPEN
AT SOME POINT BUT NOW BE CLOSE
BUT MAY NOW BE CLOSED OR- NEW
PROVIDERS CLOSE PROVIDERS WHO'S
GONNA BE ELIGIBLE. COOPER TO MY
COLLEAGUE THAT THEIR DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. SECONDS
WILL BE PROVIDED TO ALL
LICENSED PROVIDERS. CURRENTLY
OPENED OR IF THERE. IF THEY'RE
CLOSE AND THINKING ABOUT RE
OPENING I MEAN. THE PROVIDERS
WERE OPEN AS OF JUNE. AS OF
JUNE THANK YOU. NO FOR THE OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER. YES
SIR I MEAN I THINK A LOT OF MY
FOCUS IS GOING TO BE ON IN
THESE BUDGET DISCUSSIONS IS WE
HEAR A LOT ABOUT THESE KIND OF
BIG NEW BUDGET PROPOSALS- YOU
KNOW TAKING CENTER STAGE BUT
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
EXISTING PROGRAMMING I MEAN
THAT'S BECAUSE WE'VE HAD SOME
ISSUES WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT- YOU KNOW. FOR AS LONG AS
I'VE BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE
ABOUT HOW DO WE IMPROVE WHAT WE
HAVE ALREADY- AND I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE A BIG BIG FOCUS HERE-
IN ADDITION PANDEMIC POLICIES
MAY ACTUALLY BE CONTRIBUTING TO
LIMITED ACCESS IN CHILD CARE
THIS IS THE SHORTAGE OF CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WHICH PRECEDED
COVERT NINETEEN. HAS HAS ONLY
BECOME WORSE. ADD IN THIS LAST
YEAR AND LIKE EDUCATION
RESTAURANTS IN OTHER SECTORS
WHEN GOVERNMENT CONTINUES TO
PAY WITHOUT REQUIRING WORK. OR
SUBSIDIZES REDUCED WORKING
LEVELS GUESS WHAT WE HAVE. A
LABOR SHORTAGE. THE SO CALLED
HARD HOLD HARMLESS POLICIES MAY
ACTUALLY BE DOING MORE HARM.
CREATING DISINCENTIVES FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS TO OFFER
AND RECIPIENTS TO ACCESS. AND
FULLY UTILIZE CHILD CARE. THE
LIMITED NUMBER OF AVAILABLE
SLOTS ARE DEEMED FULL EVEN IF
NOT BEING USED. LEAVING THOSE
WHO ACTUALLY NEED AND WOULD USE
CHILD CARE ON ON WAITING LISTS
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW ANY OF THESE
PROPOSALS IN THE MAY REVISE
WILL ACTUALLY REVERSE THIS
TREND AND ATTRACT THE THOUSANDS
OF QUALIFIED NEW PROVIDERS
NEEDED. I THINK THAT IS LIKE
FRONT ROW CENTER WHAT WE NEED
TO BE FOCUSED ON- WITH THIS. IN
PARTICULAR RIGHT HERE WITH THIS
MAY REVISED PROPOSAL SAUCEDA
THE ADMINISTRATION GIVEN THE
DECLINE IN THE NUMBER OF CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS DURING THE
PANDEMIC INCLUDING THE CLOSURE.
OF AN ESTIMATED FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED CHILD CARE HOMES IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO HUNDRED
CHILD CARE CENTERS. HOW DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION ANTICIPATE
IMPLEMENTING A HUNDRED THOUSAND
NEW SLOTS. IN THE NEW YEAR A
HUNDRED AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SUBSIDIZED HEALTH CARE
SLOTS. IT WILL BE- AT IT'S AN
EXPANSION OF GENERAL CHILDCARE
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAMS AND
IT'S BEING PHASED IN IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. IT'S- IT'S AND WE-
FULLY WERE FULLY COMMITTED TO
THE HUNDRED CASE THOUGHT THAT
THE HISTORICAL INVESTMENT AND
AGAIN THEY WILL BE. A THERE
THERE NOT ALL BEGINNING JULY
FIRST THERE PHASED IN GRADUALLY.
FINE I UNDERSTAND HOW YOU GONNA
FILEM RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE SLOTS
THAT ARE ALREADY AVAILABLE THAT
WE CAN'T FILL- SO HOW YOU GONNA
FILL THESE HUNDRED THOUSAND
WHAT THE PHASE A MEN OR-
WHATEVER. YOU NEED THE WORKERS
WHERE YOU GONNA GET ON. I JUST
WANT TO ADD TO IT SO I
COLLEAGUES IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SHARED SKEWED TO
INDICATE THAT THIS IS A PART OF
WHAT WE ARE INVESTING IN WITH
RESPECT TO THE RELIEF PAYMENTS.
BAD WE DISCUSSED BOTH THE STATE
PLANS TO PROVIDERS TO ASSIST IN
STABILIZING THE FIELD AS WELL
AS THE- CHILD CARE. INITIATIVE
PROJECT TO BUILD CAPACITY- AND
WE DO ALSO HAVE QUITE A FEW WE
INVEST AND UNMET NEEDS ACROSS
THE STATE THAT WE THINK AND
THERE ARE PROVIDERS TO MEET
QUITE A FEW. OF OUR FAMILIES
ALL SUPPLY AND FAMILY FRIENDS
AND NEIGHBORS- FOR CARE
PARTICULARLY IF THEY NEED CARE
DURING WORK HOURS AND SO WE DO
EXPECT. IT WILL BE PROVIDED IN
THOSE SETTINGS AS WELL- BUT I
MEAN JUST IS STILL DOESN'T GET
TO MY QUESTION WHICH IS RIGHT
NOW YOU CAN'T FILL THESE BUT
SOME PEOPLE ARE WEIGHTLESS AND
WE'VE LOST WE HAD. A BUNCH OF
THESE CHILD CARE CENTERS CLOSE
DOWN- YOU'RE DOING A HOLD
HARMLESS POLICY WHICH PAYS THEM
WHAT REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY'RE OPEN OR NOT. REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THEY'RE HAVING THE
SAME HOURS OR NOT SO. I'M I'M
SORRY I'M JUST VERY CONFUSED
ABOUT HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
ACTUALLY INCREASE LOTS IN THIS
CURRENT LABOR SHORTAGE THAT
ARGUABLY YOU HELP CREATE. SO MR
GALLAGHER I CAN LET ME JUST
INTERJECT RIGHT HERE SO I THINK
THAT YOU'RE RAISING A POINT BUT
WE HERE HAVE TO YOU KNOW WALK
AND CHEW GUM AT THE SAME TIME.
SO THE PANDEMIC IS COMING TO AN
END WE'RE SEEING THIS ISSUE NOT
JUST IN CHILD CARE CENTERS
BUTTON. IN A PIZZA
ESTABLISHMENTS AND RETAIL AND
JOBS ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHERE
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IS THAT THEIR- UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS KEEPING THEM AT HOME
IS IT A COMBINATION THAT
FRANKLY THEY CAN'T GET CHILD
CARE TO. THAT'S BY THE PROBABLY
BIGGER ISSUE THEY CAN'T SEND
THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL SO IT'S
LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT. I'M IS
GONNA STAY HOME AND RIDE IT OUT
AND SO. YOU KNOW I THINK THINGS
ARE HAPPENING WITH THE RECOVERY
OF COVER NINETEEN VACCINATIONS
AND EVERYTHING AND WE'RE WE'RE
CHANGING SO. THIS BUDGET OF
COURSE. WE'RE ADOPTING A BUDGET
THAT WOULD START JULY FIRST GO
FOR THE NEXT TWELVE MONTHS.
BERASAL SETTING THE STAGE FOR
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS SO. WE'RE
TRYING TO THINK LONG TERM NOW
SO YOU'RE RIGHT. IF THE
CURRENT. TREND CONTINUED LIKE
WE ARE FOR COVER NINETEEN. IT
WOULDN'T WORK OUT WE'RE TRYING
TO FOCUS ON THE LONG TERM BUT-
I THINK THAT WE'RE TO WHERE WE
ARE TRYING TO LAY OUT- A
REALITY THAT. YOU KNOW FOR
CHILD CARE. PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA
FOR YOU KNOW YEARS EVEN DECADES
ABOUT A MASSIVE WAITING LIST.
WHICH WERE TRYING TO ADDRESS.
NOW THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES A
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW SLOTS I
WILL NOTE THAT. THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET BLUEPRINT WHICH WE
UNVEILED TWO WEEKS AGO.
PROPOSES THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SLOTS WITH THE PLAN TO GET TO
MILLION IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
THE SENATE. HAS A PLAN FOR TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND SO. WE THINK
THAT THE HUNDRED THOUSAND. IS
NOT AMBITIOUS ENOUGH SO WE
pTHAT WE ADOPT OUR BUDGET. I'M
NEXT WEEK BUT- I WILL NT
LASTLY. THAT I WILL SAY THAT
BOTH THE S. AND T. K. WHICH
COMES NEXT THEY'RE NOT NEW
PROGRAMS WE'RE NOT CREATING
SOMETHING NEW AND YOU YOU
MENTIONED THAT WE SHOULD FOCUS
ON. DOING WELL WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. BOTH GENERAL CHILD
CARE. AND THE AND- THE-
EXPANSION HERE. THE ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PROGRAM AT EIGHT P.
WHICH ARE. THE MAJORITY 99% OF
THE SLOTS. OUR EXISTING PRODUCT
WHICH HAVE MASSIVELY LISTS SO-
SO I'VE I APPRECIATE THE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I AND I AGREE WITH
YOU WE HAVE A FIVE YEAR PLAN
RIGHT AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE LONG ERM. BUT WHAT I WANT
TO I WANT TO HEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION RESPOND TO THIS
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
SAME WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS IN
A YEAR. THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
ARE SAYING IN THIS MAY REVISE
IN A YEAR WE'RE GOING TO
IMPLEMENT A HUNDRED SLOTS
PHASED IN. AND I WANT TO KNOW
HOW THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
CONSIDERING THE POLICIES THAT
THEY PUT IN PLACE. RIGHT NOW IN
THE CURRENT LABOR SHORTAGE I
WANT I WANT TO HEAR FROM THEM
YEAH. LIKE I THINK WE HAVE A
PLAN I THINK THEY JUST LIKE TO
ANNOUNCE THINGS WHAT I DID NOT
SAY HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
YEAH I THINK IT'S HARD TO ME
JUST INTERJECT AGAIN BECAUSE- I
THINK YOU YOU'RE- HAVING
CONCERNS WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
DOING ON THE- SHUT DOWN OF THE
ECONOMY AND OUR STATE AND- YOU
KNOW. THAT'S NOT THEIR DECISION
THEY RUN OUR CHILD CARE AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND- YOU
KNOW THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE A
DECISION. JUNE FIFTEENTH THINGS
ARE GOING TO BE VERY VASTLY
DIFFERENT IN THEIR WORK YOU
KNOW SIX WEEKS AGO AND SIX
MONTHS AGO SO. I THINK THINGS
ARE CHANGING ANYWAY BUT I DON'T
KNOW. I THINK YOUR ISSUE. OKAY
BUT I THINK YOUR QUESTIONS TO
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. NO IS IT TO THEM.
THAT YOU CARE FOR ORDER YEAH
JUST. KEEP WE HAVE A QUESTIONS.
PERTAINING TO THE TOPIC. AT
HAND. NOT NECESSARILY THE
OVERALL. PANDEMIC IN THE
GOVERNMENTAL RESPONSE TO IT.
NOT I MEAN NO QUESTION. BECAUSE
TO THIS WE HAVE A HOLD HARMLESS
POLICIES YEAH. THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO THIS BUDGET ITEM.
IN CHILD CARE RIGHT AND WHAT
THAT MEANS IS WE'RE PAYING
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THEY'RE OPEN AND REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER NOT THEY'RE HAVING
THE SAME HOURS AND- WHICH IS
LEADING TO A LABOR SHORTAGE SO
I'M ST NOW WE'RE GONNA SAY
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MORE SLOTS. THAT
SOUNDS GREAT I WANT TO HAVE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE CHILD
CARE SLOTS BUT HOW ARE YOU
GONNA DO IT CONSIDERING. THAT
THE CLOSURES THAT WE'VE HAD AND
THE LABOR SHORTAGE THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW. SIX WE
HAD CITY YEARS- FINANCER SOCIAL
SERVICES TALK ABOUT THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISIONS WE HAD IN
THE LAST FEW COVERED PLANS AND
WHEN THOSE EXPIRE AND HOW
THOSE. HOW THOSE- CANNOT RELATE
AND- TIE INTO OUR EXPANSION
HERE. YEAH I THINK IT MAY IT
MAY BE HELPFUL JUST TO PROVIDE.
A QUICK CLARIFICATION THE HOLD
HARMLESS POLICY IS NOT ABOUT
PAYING PROVIDERS WHEN THEY ARE
CLOSE THE HOLD HARMLESS POLICY
IS ABOUT WHEN THE PROVIDER
REMAINS OPEN. AND THE CHILD
DOES NOT ATTEND DUE TO PANDEMIC
RELATED- IT TO THE ENTIRE
FAMILY SO THAT'S WHAT THE HOLD
HARMLESS POLICY IS HOWEVER
THERE ARE ALSO KEEP NOT
OPERATIONAL DAYS. THANK I'M A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DESCRIBING
THAT SAID THE CAPE NON
OPERATIONAL DAYS ARE LIMITED TO
SIXTEEN DAYS. SO THAT IS
SPECIFIC TO CRISES THAT MIGHT
BE HAPPENING RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC AND IT IS A- LIMITED
NUMBER. OF DAYS SO- I JUST
WANTED TO PROVIDE THAT
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE THEY DO
ALSO THINK IT HELPS WITH THE
DISCUSSION. OKAY ALL I WANT IS
AN ANSWER LIKE HOW YOU'RE GOING
TO IMPLEMENT WHAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING THAT'S IT. I DON'T
THINK I'M ASKING SOMETHING
CRAZY HERE. I UNDERSTAND THOSE
POLICIES AND AGAIN AS I SAID
THEY'RE CONTRIBUTING TO THAT
FACT IF YOU'RE HOLDING IT OPEN
FOR A KID WHO'S NOT ATTENDING
THAT MEANS SOME OTHER KID AND
ANOTHER RECIPIENT WHO WANTS TO
BE ABLE TO USE IT UTILIZE THE
PROGRAM. CAN'T DO IT THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE ON THE WAITING LIST.
BUT AGAIN ADMINISTRATION YOU'RE
THE ONE SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
DO A HUNDRED THOUSAND YOU'RE
PROMISING BIG THINGS. AND NOW
ARE YOU GOING TO DO IT THAT'S
MY THAT'S THE QUESTION. WHAT
ARE YOU GONNA SOLVE THIS LABOR
SHORTAGE PROBLEM. WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS CAPACITY IN THE
FIELD FORGET TAKE UP THE SLACK
AND THAT THERE IS SUFFICIENT
NUMBER OF FAMILIES WHO NEED FOR
SLOTS AND THAT THOSE MATCHES
WILL BE MADE AND THESE ARE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WHO WILL
RECEIVE THE ADDITIONAL. I THINK
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE IS LOOKING
FOR IS CLARITY ON- AND- OFF ON
THE GROUND SO. WILL THE
DEPARTMENT BE CALLING FORMER
PROVIDERS TO SAY HEY YOU KNOW
THESE MONIES ARE AVAILABLE-
WOULD YOU WANT TO CONSIDER YOU
KNOW REOPENING- YOUR CENTER-
WHAT ARE. IS WHAT IS THE PLAN
TO RECRUIT FIT THE WORK FORCE
HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN ISSUE WITH
IN CHILD CARE- FINDING-
QUALIFIED TEACHERS- AND CARE
GIVERS- IS NOT EASY. SO WHAT IS
THE PLAN TO RECRUIT THEM TO
EVEN IF YOU ARE A PROVIDER THAT
WANTS TO OPEN. AND YOU'RE
APPROVED FOR FORTY EIGHT SLOTS-
CAN YOU HIRE THE TEACHERS TO
MEET RATIOS- THESE ARE SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE IS LOOKING TO SEE. IF
WE WANT TO GET TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND WHAT'S THAT WHAT'S THE
ACTUAL PLAN- FOR ACTUALLY
OPENING DOORS AT CENTERS. AND
PAIRING FAMILIES ABOUT WITH
PROVIDERS. WITH RESPECT TO
LICENSE CAPACITY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE
AT THIS POINT ARE ALMOST ABOUT
A NET ZERO. AND IN TERMS OF THE
LAST AND THE GAINES SO WE HAVE
WE HAVE LOST SIGNIFICANT
CAPACITY AS YOUR KILEY DID AND
WE HAVE BEEN DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT. THAT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE HAVE POP UP CENTERS
THAT HAVE. BEGUN AND WE ARE
TRANSITIONING THEM FLEXING AND
WE'VE HAD NEW PROVIDER. ARE
COMING AND THAT THOSE ARE A
VERY MINOR CHANGE IN THE
OVERALL FEEL. HAVING SAID THAT
WE HAVE BOB I WANTED TO
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
QUALITY CHILD CARE AND THERE
ARE INVESTMENTS IN THE BUDGET
BUT ALSO DO FOCUS. ON HOW. THE
CHILD CARE INITIATIVE PROJECT
IN PARTICULAR THAT FUNDING IS
INTENDED IT DOES INCLUDE. BOTH
OUTREACH AND ASSISTANCE TO FOR
PROVIDERS TO ASSIST THEM WITH
BECOMING LICENSE. AND THEN WE
ALSO HAVE THE NON LICENSE OR
LICENSE EXEMPT. CARE THAT IS
PROVIDED SO I HOPE THOSE ARE
HELPFUL CLARIFICATIONS TO-
PRESIDENTIAL CONTACTS BUT- EVEN
THOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN.
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES WE DO
ALSO HAVE GROWTH THAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE- OKAY LAST
LAST QUESTION HERE. IS. YEAH WE
PROPOSED FOR TKA OF WHICH-
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF WE'VE DONE
A FOUR POINT 005% COAL INCREASE
AND HERE WE'RE DOING A ONE
POINT 7% CALL INCREASE SO WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU'RE- DURING A VERY
MINIMAL CALL INCREASE AND NO
RATE INCREASE. RIGHT. IS THAT
PROBLEMATIC TO. ENSURING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE KIND OF
PROVIDERS THAT WE NEED. EVEN
JUST AN EXISTING PROGRAM. THE
MAN. IS THAT A PART IN A
FINANCE. OR WHOEVER WOULD LIKE
TO ANSWER FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT BE GREAT
LET'S HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ANSWER THAT AND THEN
LET'S STAY ON THIS TOPIC FOR A
BIT. YEAH WOULD THE REGIONAL
MARK RATE- AGAIN. WORD CAN. TO
INTO THE TOPIC. WE WORK- TO.
FUTURE DISK. ABOUT THE- AS FOR
THE- I DO NOT HAVE THAT IN.
WITH ME AT THIS MOMENT. BUT I
CAN BACK TEARS. OKAY THAT'S NOT
HOME THE DEPARTMENT OF RAINY
AND MOST HAPPY ADD ON AND- TO
MISTER DEALERS RESPONSE. WHAT
DID YOU LEARN FIRST JUST RIGHT
NOW WITH THE COLA QUESTION WHY
THE DIFFERENTIAL THERE. YEAH
SO- D. AS I BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE
SPEAKING TO IS THE HEALTHIEST
OF COLA WHICH WERE PROPOSING-
AT FIVE POINT 007% AND IN THE
BUDGET. AND THAT IS JUST
DISTRICT CONTACTS THAT IS THE-
COMPOUNDING OF THE TWO POINT
21% COLLECTING TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. ONE POINT 7% COLLECTING
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND ONE
PERCENT- ADDITIONAL OUT ON THAT
WE ARE PROPOSING- WITHIN THAT
THE MAY REVISION- SO THE 1%
OBVIOUSLY THE POLICY DECISION
WHICH WE'RE HAPPY TO DISCUSS
AND THE IN THE K. TWELVE- FIVE
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO IS
THAT COMPOUNDED COLA BETWEEN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- UNDERSTANDING THAT-
THAT THE COLA DOES IMPACT THE
APPLICATION OF COLA. TO THE
TITLE FIGHT PROGRAMS DOES NOT
INCREASE THE RATES FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS- UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO HAVE A
CONTINUING CONVERSATION AS MY
COLLEAGUES- DISCUSSED EARLIER
REGARDING THE OVERALL RATE
SYSTEM AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF DIFFERENT PROPOSALS
OUT THERE. I'M SPECIFIC TO YOU
KNOW BRING IN THE RACE TOGETHER
AND HOW DOES THAT HOW DOES THE
ARE MARKED CONNECT TO THE S. R.
R. AND WE ARE KEEPING BACK CALL
LACK OF STATUTORY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE ABOUT THE OVERALL RATE
STRUCTURE. GIVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION. MORE THAN JUST THE. I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT IT'S DEAD
THE PROBLEMATIC THINGS WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT RATES. YOU
KNOW FOR AT LEAST THREE YEARS
HERE AND SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION WE GOT
A MONTH BEFORE WE GOT TO
FINALIZE A BUDGET SO. ONE OF
THOSE DISCUSSIONS I GUESS GOING
TO HAPPEN THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN
HAPPENING I KNOW ON OUR END-
AND WE'VE SEEN THE NEED FOR IT
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO ATTRACT.
MORE PEOPLE AND MORE PROVIDERS
YEAH LET'S LET ME JUST ADD ON
TO WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MR
GALLAGHER AND 100% IN AGREEMENT
THERE AND THAT'S ONE OF THE TOP
PRIORITIES OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
OUR BUDGET IS ADDRESSING THE
RATES BECAUSE IF YOU WANT TO
WELL EVEN IF YOU JUST WANT TO
HAVE EXISTING CHILD CARE WHERE
WE HAVE NOW THE NUMBER OF SLOTS
RATES AS A PROBLEM. YOU KNOW WE
CAN'T KEEP UP WITH YOU KNOW THE
ECONOMIC FACTORS OF PAYING OUR
EMPLOYEES DECENT WAGES YOU KNOW
WE LOSE OUR WORK FORCE TO
BETTER JOBS THAT COSCO IN AND
OUT BURGER NOTHING AGAINST
COSCO NOW BURGER BUT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE MAKE FINANCIAL CHOICES
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND IF. YOU
KNOW THE MOST IMPORTANT JOBS
SIZE TAKE CARE OF OUR KIDS WE
DON'T PAY THAT THAT WORKFORCE-
YOU KNOW LIVING WAGE YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT ROCKET SCIENCE TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS THERE SO AND THEN
WE WERE LOOKING ABOUT EXPANDING
BY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
POTENTIALLY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND SLOTS- AND- YOU KNOW
HOW. IS THIS GOING TO WORK OUT
IN LESS WE ADJUST. OUR RATE
STRUCTURE SIMPLIFY IT WHICH
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN THESE.
BILLS WE'VE- BEEN CAUGHT LAST
COUPLE YEARS- I KNOW DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND OTHERS TALK
ABOUT YOUR NEGOTIATING. WITH
YOU KNOW THE UNION CONTRACTORS%
PROVIDERS OUT THERE BUT REMIND
YOU THAT A LOT OF THE- CHILD
CARE FIELD OUT THERE IS NOT
UNION WHETHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE- CBO'S IN COMMUNITIES YOU
KNOW. WE WANT TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR OF OUR UNIONIZED WORKFORCE
AND NOW THAT'S THE LOG WITH THE
LIMóN THE FROM TWO YEARS AGO
AND RIGHTFULLY SO I'M GOING TO
DO THAT BUT- THERE'S A BIG
PIECE OF THE CHILD CARE FIELD
THAT NEED THAT TOO. SO IF WE
DON'T ADDRESS RATES. ALL THESE
WORDS HERE ON THESE ON THE PLAN
AND- THAT AND WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE IF THAT WON'T
WORK SO HOW DO YOU. ADDRESS.
THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO
I'LL DEFINITELY DEFERRED TO MY-
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
COLLEAGUES TO DISCUSS THE
IMPACT ON THE OVERALL CHILD
CARE- SYSTEM- UNDERSTANDING OF
COURSE IN THE PRESCHOOL SIDE
WHICH IS WHICH I CAN SPEAK TO-
THAT THERE ARE SOME TOTAL BY
PROVIDERS WHO ARE FAMILY CHILD
CARE. PROVIDERS SO IT'S OKAY-
THE CONVERSATION IS NOT QUITE
SO CUT AND DRY AS- YOU KNOW
THOSE WHO ARE REPRESENTED- AT
THROUGH THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS AND THOSE.
WHO AREN'T THERE ACTUALLY ARE
SOME REALLY TOUGH CAR
PROVIDERS THAT PARTICIPATE NOT
HEALTHCARE PROGRAMS. BUT BUT
RECOGNIZING THAT. THESE
CONVERSATIONS COUNTY HAD
SEPARATELY FROM EACH OTHER THEY
HAVE TO HAPPEN ALTOGETHER
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE YOU KNOW AS
AS WE AS WE HAVE TALKED. ABOUT
FOR YEARS NOW AND- WITH YOU AND
IF MCCARTY- YOU KNOW THERE
THERE ARE IMPACTS THE WEEK
REACHING THREE TO ONE AREA- AND
DON'T CHANGE IN ANOTHER AREA
SO. AGAIN WE ARE WE ARE LOOKING
AT THIS CONVERSATION
HOLISTICALLY- AND THAT. ARE YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION- YOU KNOW YOUR
PRIORITIES AS WELL AS THE
PARTIES OF THE SENATE. ON A
MOVING FORWARD AND I WOULD JUST
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE SEPARATE
HEALTH COMPONENT SERVICES FOR
ANY KIND OF THING THEY HAVE. ON
THE IMPACT OF CHILD CARE THE
OVERALL CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
BEFORE THAT THEY DO WE GET PAST
THE EAGLES BEEN DELIVERING
THESE CONTRACTS FOR YEARS THE
THIRD LEVEL MORE GAMES. DO. YOU
THINK THAT WE COULD EXPAND. SLY
BY- THE HUNDRED DOLLAR OR MORE.
WITH THE EXISTING GREAT
STRUCTURE DO WE NEED TO
INCREASE RIGHT. THEIR NUMBER
MARKING CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO EXPAND ITS THOUGHTS VSAT IT
JUST DEPENDS ON WHICH PART OF
THE SYSTEM YOU'RE LOOKING NOT I
DO THINK I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THAT RATES CONTINUE TO BE AN
ISSUE. AND AS WE LOOK FOR ME
THE REPORT I REALLY WANT TO
KEEP MY COMMENTS ON THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND NOT
ADDRESS THE CHILD CARE SITE
THAT REALLY GETS DSS AS PER
VIEW AT THIS POINT. SO FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM JUST TO MAINTAIN WHAT
WE HAVE WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THE RATES ARE INCREASED WE KNOW
THAT THEY STRUGGLE WITH KEEPING
TEACHERS WITH HIRING TEACHERS
WITH GETTING TEACHERS THAT ARE
QUALIFIED. FOR THOSE THE TITLE
FIVE STRUCTURE SO HARD OUT OF
WHAT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT AS
HOW WE ENSURE THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS SUPPORTED AT A RATE
AND A FUNDING AMOUNT AND I
THINK EARLIER MY TALKING POINTS
I SPOKE TO THAT. IN NOT EVEN A
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME PROVIDER
IS MAKING MORE FOR THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLD THAT OUR STATE
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND INTERSTATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS HAVE TO. DO
MUCH HIGHER STANDARDS AND TO
PROVIDE SPECIFIC SERVICES TO
THE PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
ACTUALLY ARE DELIVERING A
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WITH SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS. AND STANDARDS
AROUND SOME. OKAY I THANK I
FORGOT TO PRESS THE ON BUTTON
SO WE HEARD US HERE BUT PEOPLE
AT HOME I WAS ASKING ABOUT- HOW
COULD WE INCREASE LOTS WITHOUT
CORRESPONDINGLY INCREASE RATES
AND WE CAN WE CAN GO ON THIS I
JUST WANT TO MAKE THE POINT
CRYSTAL CLEAR THIS IS AN
ABSOLUTE. IN THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET- WE WON'T PUSH FOR AND
GO FOR WITH THE BUDGET LAST
WEEK. THAT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS-
THE RATE STRUCTURE FOR EASY
PROGRAMS. FURTHER QUESTIONS ON
THESE ISSUES MR O'DONNELL. JUST
A QUICK QUESTION I MAY HAVE
HEARD IT RIGHT I MAY HAVE HEARD
IT INCORRECTLY. HI THIS
QUESTION IS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THERE WERE SOME LA-
COMMENTS IF I INTERPRET THEM
CORRECTLY THAT. STEVE THE
FEDERAL FUNDS- PROPOSED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE CANNOT BE USED
FOR CONSTRUCTION OR LAND
PURCHASE IS THAT ACCURATE. SO
DIFFIDENT POINT READY
INFRASTRUCTURE WERE MADE BEFORE
AFTER OKAY GUIDANCE WITH
AVAILABLE AND WE'RE CONTINUING
TO LOOK FURTHER INTO THIS AS
NEW FEDERAL GUIDANCE IS
AVAILABLE. OKAY THANK YOU OKAY.
AND THEN JUST LASTLY I WANT TO
KNOW THAT LMAO MENTIONED- THE-
FEDERAL MONEY AND POTENTIALLY
DECREASING NUMBER OF SLOTS AND
I THINK WE AND OUR BUDGET-
RECOGNIZE OUT YEAR REVENUES AND
PEGGED THESE TOWARDS MAKING
SURE THIS IS A PRIORITY. TO
INCREASE LOT SLIDE THIS YEAR IN
THE OUT YEARS AS WELL. SO THESE
ISSUES ISSUES WE WILL HOLD OPEN
CERTAINLY OF TOP PRIORITY OF
THE ASSEMBLY BUT WE WON'T TAKE
ACTION TODAY. ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE UP
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE INCLUDING. THE T. K.
THROUGH TWELVE BUDGET- IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AND SO FORTH.
PRESS START WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ELIA IN NCD. BERMAN
FINANCE. THE MORNING. MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIGHT
COMING THROUGH LOUD AND CLEAR
YEP YOU'RE GOOD THANK YOU.
CORRECT AB APARTMENT OF FINANCE
DEVIDED THIS MORNING WITH AS
BRIEF AS POSSIBLE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE PACKAGE AT
THE MAY REVISION FROM THE
MINISTRATION OF START WITH-
TALK ABOUT CALCULATIONS HOW WE
ARRIVED AT THE- DIFFERENT
TOTALS FOR EACH YEAR AND THEN
I'LL DO A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
SEVERAL OF OUR- MAIN. SPENDING
PROPOSAL. WITH STRONG REVENUE
INCREASES OVER THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND IS UP BY A
TOTAL OF MORE THAN FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD COMPARED TO WHAT
WAS ASSUMED AT THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT TOP WITH
ALMOST SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
OF NEW RESOURCES OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD COMPARED TO.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. I WOULD
PROBABLY STILL IN A TEST ONE IN
EACH OF THOSE THREE YEAR IT
WILL TAKE ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT
CENTS ON EVERY NEW GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS- PROPERTY TAXES
MAINTAIN. MODEST GROWTH OVER
THE PERIOD OF WITH MOST.
DOWNWARD CHANGE ARE PROTECTED
THE MAYOR VISION BEING
ASSOCIATED WITH RECENT GUIDANCE
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AFTER
THE GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET-
REGARDING ACCESS HE WRAPPED
DISTRIBUTION. BURKE GUARANTEED
TOTALED IN THE PRIOR YEAR
GUARANTEE ABOUT SEVENTY NINE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
PER YEAR IS THAT NINETY TWO
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS WE
HAVE TO MAKE THE BUDGET YEAR AT
NINETY THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT THAT NINETY THREE
POINT SEVEN. IS NOW WITH OUR
INCLUDING- THE WHAT WAS
PROPOSED THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS EQUAL TO ONE AND A
HALF PERCENT OF TOTAL GENERAL
FUND REVENUES. WHICH OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE HAD
PROPOSED TO CONTINUE TO INCLUDE
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
NOW THE BIGGER VISION THIS
PROPOSING TO REMOVE BOTH THE
NOT HERE AS WELL AS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR WHICH WOULD HAVE
BEEN EQUAL TO ABOUT TWO POINT
SIX. BILLION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO ON TOP OF THAT.
NINETY THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION. AMOUNT WHAT. THE ONE
AMOUNTS OF FAR EXCEEDING THE
CALCULATED TECH TO. IN BOTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AM CAP GAINS
REVENUES EXCEEDING GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROJECTION. THEY GAVE
RESERVE DEPOSITS ARE INCREASE
FROM GOVERNOR'S BUDGET UP TO
ABOUT ONE POINT ALMOST TWO
BILLION. IN THE CURRENT YEAR
AND TWO POINT SIX BILLION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. SIMILAR TO OUR
ASSUMPTION THAT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THIS AMOUNT OF A RESERVE
BALANCE WOULD TRIGGER THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE CAPS PER
STATUTE BEGINNING IN. TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. I
THOUGHT WE ARE ESTIMATING THE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
CONTINUED TO DECLINE THOUGH NOT
MUCH OF A PRACTICAL IMPACT ON
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING AMOUNT SPENT INFLATION
AND ENROLLMENT CHANGES ARE ONLY
FACTORED INTO THE TEST TO. TEST
THREE CALCULATION. WHAT
OPPOSITION I DID IT I'M
PRESIDENTE LEVELS OF HER PEOPLE
FUNDING ALMOST FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. PER K. TWELVE
STUDENT THE MAYOR VERSION CLOSE
TO SEVERAL KEY ADVANCEMENT ON
BOTH AN ONGOING BUT A ONE TIME
BASIS HELP PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS FALLS PRIOR
TIGHTENING. THE MAXIMUM
POSSIBLE FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES
NOT JUST REALLY IMPACTED BY THE
COMPANY IN FACT ENDEMIC.
BECAUSE THE APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY FOUR IN ONE TIME K.
TWELVE POINT FOR- AND SIX
BILLION IF ONGOING CASE OPENED
AFTER- WHERE ALL OF THE
AVAILABLE SPENDING AND
COMPETING PRIORITIES AND WE ARE
STILL TO MAINTAIN BUT YOUR
DEFERRAL UP ON THE K. TWELVE.
OF ABOUT TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS ROUGHLY EQUAL TO THE
PROPERTY GET RESERVE DEPOSIT
REQUIRED IN THE BUDGET YEAR-
LASTLY AT OF YOU LIKELY HAVE
HEARD DUE TO A COMBINED
OPERATION OF THE LIMIT
OVERREACH IN BOTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OF TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
APRIL SCHOOL THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WILL RECEIVE A TOTAL
OF EIGHT POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITION TO THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE AMOUNT AS
REQUIRED PRO CONSTITUTION WHICH
IS CURRENTLY BEING PROPOSED IN
THEIR VISION FOR ALLOCATION IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ONE
FINAL ACCEPT STYLE. AMOUNT IS
NOW. NOW ALSO BRIEFLY. TO SOME
OF THE MAIN FOCAL- THAT I
REFERENCED- EARLIER. ON THE
HELP YOU OUT THE MAYOR VISION.
THAT COMPOUNDED. A FIVE POINT
007% WHICH MY COLLEAGUE.
JESSICA HOLMES EXPLAINED. IN
DETAIL EARLIER ON BUT HAPPY
AFTER QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT IF
THEY ARISE- WE COMBINED WITH.
EIGHTY EIGHT FROM NOW THE ABOUT-
THIS IS TO THREE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS A TOTAL INCREASE FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOL OKAY ABOUT FUNDING FROM
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FOR AN ESTIMATED
TOTAL IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
OF SIXTY FIVE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTERS. ARE COMING OUT OF
EDUCATION ARE ALSO ESTIMATED TO
RECEIVE AN INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
LEVEL. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND UP AT THOSE A FEW WEEKS
THAT ARE FUNDED BASED ON THE
HELP YOU HAVE TARGET WILL
PROCEED TO FIVE POINT. 07% COLA
AS WELL. IN ADDITION TO THE
FIVE POINT ZERO SEVEN COLA.
VISION ALSO COOPER. APPROXIMATE
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASING THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT PERCENTAGE.
WILL DELAY THE RECEIVER- AND
MORE DETAILS ON THAT PROPOSAL
WILL BE DISCUSSED IN THE NEXT
PANEL. SPECIAL EDUCATION MAYOR
BEING PROPOSES THAT ADDITIONAL
GROWTH AND COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. EQUAL OR KIDNEY
ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. ON
THE EIGHTY SIX OH TWO FORMULA
OF ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
REFLECTING A COMPOUNDED COLA OF
FOUR POINT 005% BUT THAT IS.
ACTIVELY APPLYING THE CURRENT
YOUR COLD WOULD NOT BUY IT
MULTIPLIED BY THE MAY REVISION
STATUTORY COAL OF ONE POINT 7%
WITHOUT THAT ADDITIONAL
DISCRETIONARY 1% GOAL OF THAT
WE'RE ALSO FINE. DELPHY ABOUT.
ADDITIONALLY MAY VISION OF.
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
IDEATE FUNDS FOR SPECIALIST
SPECIAL EDUCATION. OUR OUR
UNIVERSAL PK PROPOSAL COVER
BRIEFLY- THE MAY REVISION NOW
INCLUDES SEVERAL PROPOSAL TO
HELP AT LEAST A RAMP UP TO FULL
YEAR EARLY TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. ROLLOUT PROPOSED
BEGAN AT TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE ASSEMBLY ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIAL. W. TROUBLED WILL
SLIGHTLY REDUCE FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AMOUNT BY
JUST TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
VARIOUS ADJUSTMENTS THE LABOR
MADE INITIAL. SEATED TRAILER
BILL. OUR TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN.
DOLLARS FOR TO BECOME BUDGET TO
INSTEAD OF BALA EARLY HE K.
EXPANSION IN THE BUDGET YEAR-
REMAINS BUT THAT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT INTO OF THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION PROPOSED
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
GROWING TO SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION. YEARS AIMED AT
REDUCING CHILD TO ADULT RATIOS
AND- TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
AND KINDERGARTEN IS NOT IT IN
ADDITION TO THE PROPOSED
ESTIMATED CALL. BEGINNING AT
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TWO ALL
THE WRAP UP TO FOUR YEAR-
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN UP
FOR THAT YOUR CALL ABOUT TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION THOSE
COMPLEMENT YOUR ERROR IN
ADDITION TO THAT. COST ABOUT
THE ABOUT- THE MAIN AND ALSO
BY. TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. SIX HUNDRED AND THREE
MILLION OF WHICH IS PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND. TARGETED
INTERVENTION GRANT THE PROBLEM
AT THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION
ALREADY PROVIDED THROUGH THE
EARLY ACTION EIGHTY SIX.
PACKAGE THAT WOULD PROVIDE FOR
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITY.
ARE RECOGNIZING THAT THE
CHALLENGES AND THE IMPACT ON
LEARNING I'VE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC THE
PROPOSAL INTENDS TO DRAFT THE
NEED FOR A MULTI YEAR PERIOD BY
PROVIDING FUNDING OVER THREE
YEARS POSTING ON RESEARCH.
TESTED INTERVENTION BUDGET HIGH
DOSE DURING. AN INTENSIVE RAIN
GAUGE REFER STUDENTS.
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. ON SCHOOL REAL.
THE VISION ALSO BUILT ON THE
INVESTMENT. ONE OF THE OTHER
INVEST IN A. EIGHTY-
INCENTIVIZE ADEQUATE LEN TO
TAKE THE REAL QUICK BREAK
PERSONAL. BY PROVIDING A- TO
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME COMPETITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
THURSDAY INCREASE AND THE MAYOR
VISION FOR THE FOSTER YOUTH
SERVICES COORDINATING PROGRAM A
ONE TIME AUGMENTATION OF THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AT THE
EXISTING PROSTITUTES CORDING
PROGRAM IS FUNDS ARE MEANT TO
SUPPORT THE EXISTING PROGRAM ON
A ONE TIME BASIS AND TO PROVIDE
COUNTY OFF THE MEDICATION
PERFECTIBILITY TO PROVIDE
DIRECT EDUCATIONAL SERVICES TO
FOSTER YOU. BY REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT TO SUBMIT A WAIVER
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES AND BY
ALLOWING COUNTY ALL THE
ORIGINATION TO USE A PORTION OF
BONTA CONTRACT WITH MISSION
ALIGNED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. MAY REVISION DOES
MAKE SEVERAL SMALLER
INVESTMENTS FOR RETIREMENT
TRAINING RESOURCES AS WELL
PROFIT IF THE STATE AS WELL AS
SEVERAL SMALLER- BOWLS THAT I
WON'T GET INTO HERE BUT HAPPY.
TO FIELD QUESTIONS. LAST THE
MAYBE PROVIDE EIGHTY FOUR NO
DOLLARS NONPROFIT SHE NINETY
GENERAL AND FIFTY FIVE POINT
TWO POSITIONS THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHICH INCLUDES
FUNDING TO SUPPORT CORE
FUNCTIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT ACTIVITIES
WITH BOTH IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND THE MAY REVISED AS
WELL AS VARIOUS VERY OVER AND
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS. ARE I
WILL LEAVE A COMMENT AT THAT
BUT I HAVE OF MYSELF AND
SEVERAL COLLEAGUES FROM OTHER
DEPARTMENTS ANSWER QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE ANY. AFTER THE REST OF
THE PANEL OF GETTING. OKY
THANK YOU L. A. L. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN GET ON
WITH THE LEGEND WITH OFFICE
I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM A
SHORTHAND OUT THAT OUR OFFICE
PUBLISHED ON OUR WEBSITE THIS
MORNING- BACK IN JANUARY YOU
HEARD US SAY THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN THE
BIGGEST NEED YOUR INCREASE IN
CASE FOURTEEN FUNDING IN THE
HISTORY OF PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT. AND THIS MAYOR VISION
CONTINUED RIGHT IN THAT SAME
VEIN BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF THE
CAR YOU ALSO REPRESENT. THE%
BIGGEST INCREASE IN FUNDING
BETWEEN JANUARY AND MAY- THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE HISTORY OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. OTHER
PROMINENT FINANCE MENTIONED THE
SEVENTEEN POINT SEVEN BILLION
INCREASE THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE THAT'S OVER THE
NINETEEN TWENTY TO TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. YEAH AND AGAIN
THAT'S REFLECTING ABOUT 40% OF
THE INCREASE IN GENERAL FUND
REVENUES- AS REQUIRED BY- THAT
TEST ONE FORMULA THAT SET THE
SIDE. UP 40% THE STATE REVENUE.
AFTER SCHOOLS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S REVENUE ESTIMATES
ARE REASONABLE- SOLID STARTING
POINT FOR BUILDING THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET- WE ALSO THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS AS REASONABLE AS WELL-
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE THIS YEAR IS ABOUT AS
FAR ABOVE THE CREEK AND
DEMOCRATS HOLD. NOW AS WE
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE BELOW THE
CREEK ENDEMIC LEVEL BACK AND
YOU AND- AND SO THE RECOVERY
THAT THOSE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS WERE INTENDED TO
ACCOMPLISH HAS BEEN ACHIEVED.
ALSO THE TOTAL INCREASE IN
FUNDING- IN THIS MAY REVISION
IS FIFTEEN POINT FOUR BILLION
THAT'S THE SEVENTEEN POINT
SEVEN BILLION INCREASING THE
GUARANTEE. LESS THE TWO POINT
THREE BILLION US UP ON A
PAYMENT. THAT WAS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET. I
ENTER OF THE- STRUCTURE OF THIS
BUT FIGURE STUFF. I WOULD NOT I
THINK ON PAGE STUFF OF HEARING.
AGAIN TO GIVE YOU GOOD OVER. I
SAW THE BACK. THE HIGHER PROP
NINE EIGHT GUARANTEE. I MAKES
THE HIGHER REQUIRED RESERVE
DEPOSIT AND THEN ALLOCATE 789%
OF THE REMAINING FUNDS TO
SQUIRRELS AND THE WEAPON
PERCENT TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES-
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATE'S. HEALTH PRACTICE. FOR
ALLOCATING INCREASES IN THE
GUARANTEED. I DON'T CARE A LOT
ABOUT THE COMING COLLEGE. I'LL
TOMORROW SO OFTEN JUST ON THE
NEED TO KEEP CHANGES. ARE YOU
PROBABLY REMEMBER THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAD LITTLE
OVER SEVENTEEN POINT THREE
BILLION YEN HECALLED
PROPOSALS- THIS MAY REVISION
ADDS ANOTHER TWELVE POINT SIX
BILLION IT NEW PROPOSALS ON TOP
OF THAT AMOUNT. SO THE TOTAL
PACKAGE BEFORE YOU AT ABOUT
THIRTY BILLION IN. TOTAL K.
TWELVE- PROPOSALS- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING TO
ALLOCATE NEARLY TWENTY FOUR
BILLION OF THAT FOR A ONE TIME
ACTIVITIES. AND SIX BILLION FOR
ONGOING AUGMENTATIONS. I THINK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GIVE
YOU A GOOD OVERVIEW OF SOME OF
THE MAKING MVING PIECES- FOR
THE ONGOING FUNDS ALMOST ALL OF
THAT IS RELATED TO. THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA IF THE
FIVE POINT 007% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT INCLUDING A 1%
ADDITIONAL BASE INCREASE FOR
ALL DISTRICTS. AS WELL AS THE
AUGMENTATIONS I TO THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT AND THEN A
NEW FUNDING STREAM- FOR
EXPANDED LEARNING- THAT WOULD
INCLUDE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY SUMMER ENRICHMENT-
CURRENT. CURRENTLY STRUCTURED
TO BE SEPARATE FROM THE LCF
DEATH BUT IT COULD BE FOLDED.
INTO THE FORMULA OVER TIME. TO
WHAT THERE ARE BIG ON. ARE
COMPARED WITH JANUARY THAT'LL
HAVE THESE ARE BOTH ONE. I WON
AS THE COMMUNITIES. WE PROGRAM.
I THINK THAT THIS MAY REVISION
PROVIDES A TOTAL OF THREE
BILLION FOR THAT PROGRAM. STEP
TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION
COMPARED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. SETS ASIDE ABOUT 70% OF
THAT AMOUNT. TO CREATE YOU
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND 30% FOR
EXPANDING- AND CONTINUING
EXISTING COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
ANOTHER MAJOR AUGMENTATION AND
FOCUSES ON THE EDUCATION
WORKFORCE- THIS MANAGING HAS
ABOUT TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION
FOR PREPARATION TRAINING AND
RETENTION ACTIVITIES THAT'S AN
INCREASE OF TWO POINT THREE
BILLION COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- ONE OF THE-
BIGGEST COMPONENT OF THAT PIECE
OF ONE POINT FIVE BILLION FOR
THE EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS
BLOCK GRANT- THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT DISTRICTS COULD USE. A TO
FIND A RANGE OF TRAINING-
COACHING AND MENTORING AND
OTHER ACTIVITIES. FOR TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AS WELL AS
CLASSIFIED STAFF- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MATCHING
THE SCORE WE OPENING PROPOSED
SO THIS IS ANOTHER TWO BILLION
FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY
ACTIVITIES- THESE FUNDS
DISTRICTS COULD USE THESE FUNDS
FOR RANGE OF ACTIVITIES- THAT
WOULD INCLUDE TESTING FOR- I
THINK THE BETTER RESPECTS
INITIATIVES- CLEANING-
RECONFIGURING FACILITY IS.
INCLUDE MEDITATION- PERSPECTIVE
EQUIPMENT- REALLY ARRANGED
ACTIVITIES FOR THE OPENING
SCHOOLS. AGAIN SEPARATE FROM
THAT REALLY ACTION TWO BILLION
THAT. YOU PUT APPROVED BACK IN
MARCH. THERE'S ALSO EIGHT POINT
FOUR BILLION FOR PAYING DOWN
THE PEARLS THAT IS AN INCREASE
OF ABOUT ONE POINT ONE BILLION-
COMPARED WITH. THE GOVERNOR
GENERAL BUDGET BUT WHAT THE TWO
POINT SIX BILLION IN THE FOR
ALSO MEANING AT THE END OF
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. THE BIG
MULTI YOUR PROPOSAL IS THE ONE
I RELATED TO TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN- SO THE GOVERNOR
WOULD MAKE ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT PROGRAM OVER
A THREE YEAR PERIOD FROM TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE- CONCLUDING IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. A
FOCUS JUST ON THE FISCAL SIDE
OF THAT- THE FUNDING THE
ONGOING FUNDING FOR DISTRICTS
BUT THIS PROGRAM WOULD COME
THROUGH MAKING THE STUDENTS
ELIGIBLE TO GENERATE ATTENDANCE
TO THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA. ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES STATUS NO COSTS- THAT
BY. TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
WOULD TOTAL ABOUT TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION. AND THE GOVERNOR
ALSO PROPOSES TO INCREASE OR
WHAT WE CALL REVENGE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE TO COVER THOSE COSTS.
SO RATHER THAN PAYING FOR. IT
IF NOT I'LL SEE AT THE OFFICE
YOUR EXISTING GROWTH IN THE
GUARANTEE. OF THE STATE WOULD
PAY FOR IT BY. INCREASING THE
GUARANTEE AND ESSENTIALLY
TRYING DOWN NONPROFIT ASIAN AND
YET FUNDING TO PAY FOR THAT. A
SEPARATE FROM THOSE BASE COST
THE GOVERNOR ALSO HAS A
PROPOSAL TO REDUCE ADULT THE
CHILD RATIOS- THIS WOULD
PROVIDE THIS PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE WANTED ADDITIONAL US
CERTIFICATE A CLASSIFIED STAFF
FOR EXTENDING EACH TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOM. THE
FINANCE ESTIMATES DIVISIONAL
COSTS WOULD TOTAL SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FORTY MILLION BY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AND UNLIKE
THE BASE COST THE STATE WOULD
PAY FOR THOSE COSTS WITHIN
EXISTING GROWTH OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE. I'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT RETENTION- THIS BILL
DECISION I THINK REALLY COMES
DOWN TO- THE TRADEOFF- AND YOUR
PRIORITIES WITHIN THE BROADER
STATE BUDGET CONTEXT- I
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
PREVENTION IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE
IS ALLOWABLE B THE
CONSTITUTION. WE DON'T THINK
IT'S- THAT REQUIRED IT WOULDN'T
HAVE TO DO IT. WHAT IT REALLY
MEANS IS THAT OVER TIME THE
STATE WOULD BE ABLE TO SPEND
MORE ON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT PROGRAMS. AND LESS ON NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PROGRAMS AND SO- THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING PRETTY TO THINK ABOUT
IN. DEVELOPING. A MULTI YEAR
STRUCTURE OF THIS BUDGET. HI
THERE TWO POINT SIX- FOR. THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET- THIS IS FINDING
THAT WOULD DRAW FROM A COUPLE
DIFFERENT POTS OF FEDERAL
FUNDING AND SIX HUNDRED MILLION
WHAT TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING- FOR THIS TARGETED
INTERVENTION GRANT DISTRICTS
COULD USE THE FUNDS TO PAY FOR
A- WIDE VARIETY OF SERVICES.
INTENSIVE TUTORING ADDITIONAL
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME- OTHER TEXAS
SUPPORTS BY THE FEDERAL OF THIS.
COULD BE USED TO REMEMBER SIX-
BACK TO THE STATE OF THE PANDA.
OR EXPENSE- THE STATE. COULD BE
USED FOR X. JUST INCUR AFTER.
JULY FIRST OF. TWO TWENTY ONE.
I TURNED INTO A ASSESSMENT WE
THINK THIS IS HAS SOMEONE FOR.
SO IT DOES INCLUDE SOMETHING
AUGMENTATION FOR AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN. A LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES A NUMBER OF YEARS I
THE BEST THING OF THE ARE
INCREASE RIGHT HI THE INCREASES.
FOR ACTORS AND LEARNING TIME.
AND THEN ADDITIONAL. I THIS
SUPPORT. I STRUCTURALLY THIS
BUT ALSO. A LARGE ONE TIME
BECAUSE- OF THE KICKOFF. THE
CPAS. US. TO TWENTY ONE FOR
TWO. I'M MORE THAN FOUR TWO
BILLION IN FOUR ONE TEN
ACTIVITY. AND COMBINING THAT
AMOUNT WITH THE PROPER NINETY
EIGHT WITH DEPART. AND SOMEONE
TEN COMMITTEE CALL SPEND. THIS
BUDGET AT THE TONE ONE TIME. A
NEARLY SAID BILLION. AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS.
BECAUSE IF THEY HEARING WORK
DROP NOT YEAR. THAT ONE TIME
PRESSURE. BUT THE STATE OF
WAITING MAKE CUTS TO ON BLANCA.
OR I MEAN. TURNING BACK TO
DEFER. IF THE GUARANTEE DOESN'T
DROP IT. THAT'S FUNNY FREE TO
NEXT YEAR YOU CAN ADD USE THAT
ADDRESS. A NEW ISSUE IS A QUITE.
AND IT INCLUDES A ONE TIME
INCENTIVE FUNDING BUT IT WASN'T
CLEAR- WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
THE GOVERNOR WANTED TO GO WITH
THAT PROPOSAL. AND WE WEREN'T
SURE WHAT THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN WAS- THIS MAY REVISION HAS
A FAIRLY AS A CLEAR END GOAL
AND- A CLEAR IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN- THERE'S BOTH ONE TIME AND
ONGOING FUNDING THAT LINES UP
WITH- THE COST DISTRICTS ONE
CREATED INCREASE THESE PROGRAMS.
AND SO IT'S MUCH- I THINK IT'S
A MUCH MORE DEVELOPED A
PROPOSAL- THERE ARE SOME
DETAILS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
STILL TO THINK ABOUT LIKE. WHAT
WE WOULD LIKE THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO LOOK LIKE
THAT PROGRAM CURRENTLY SERVES
MANY FOUR YEAR OLDS. I
PERSONALLY WILL SERVE MUCH
FEWER OF THEM. I ONCE THAT I
WILL OUT OF TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN BEGINS. BUT
OVERALL- THIS IS STRONGER
PROPOSAL I THINK WE ALSO THINK
THERE'S BEEN SOME IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
PROPOSAL AND ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUE I TOOK A LOOK. ON MY
COLLEAGUES TALK ABOUT MORE
ABOUT THAT. IN ONE OF THE NEXT
PANELS. BUT TO OUR CONCERN.
GOING TO FLY. AFTER PROPOSAL
FOR YOU ONE IS THE TWO POINT
SIX BILLION. FOR TARGETED
INTERVENTION AND THE SECOND TO
GET THE TWO BILLION FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY ACTIVITIES.
DISTRICTS HAVE ALREADY RECEIVED
MORE THAN THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR. ADJUSTING LEARNING
LOSS AND- HEALTH AND SAFETY
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR
BILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS MORE
THAN SIX BILLION STATE FUNDS.
AND THOUGH THAT EIGHT PREVIOUS.
CAN BE USED TO SUPPORT ALL OF
THE SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE OUTLINED IN THESE TWO MOST
RECENT PROPOSALS. INCLUDING
TARGETED INVENTION INTERVENTION
IS LIKE KIND OF TUTORING AND
ACTIVITIES- TO OPEN SCHOOLS.
AND WE ARE CONCERNED IS THAT
THESE TWO PROPOSALS PROVIDE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
FUNDING. I WITHOUT IT THEIR
JUSTIFICATION FOR IT. A LEADING
UP TO THE MAY REVISION WHAT WE
HEARD FROM DISTRICTS THAT THAT
DISTRICTS HAVE NOT SPENT ALL OF
THE ONE TIME FUNDED THEY'VE
ALREADY RECEIVED CITIES
ACTIVITIES. AND ALTHOUGH THEY
FACE A LOT OF CHALLENGES WITH
THE OPENING SCHOOLS MAKING UP
PREVENTING LOSS. THOSE DON'T
SEEM TO STEM FROM A LACK OF ONE
TIME FUNDING. IN FACT THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE I THINK FOR
MANY DISTRICTS IS FINDING
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO USE THE
FUNDING WE'VE ALREADY RECEIVED.
SO WE THINK YOU COULD REJECT
BOTH OF THOSE PROPOSALS. AND
USE THOSE. FREED UP FUNDS FOR
HIGHER PRIORITIES. LASTLY WE
THERE IS A MISTER. IN THIS
MAYOR TO MAKE MORE PROGRESS ON
BUILDING SCHOOL DISTRICT-
BUDGET RESILIENCY- SPECIFICALLY
LEAVING TWO POINT SIX BILLION
AND APPROACH THE MEANING- THAT
SECOND STEP THE CONCERN TO US-
IT'S A CONTRAST TO WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SIDE. ALL OF
THOSE DEFERRALS ARE PAID DOWN
WE THINK THAT'S MORE PROMISING
APPROACH AND WE RECOMMEND
ADOPTING. THAT SAME APPROACH
FOR. K. TWELVE EDUCATION- THE
BUDGET ALSO HAVE- ANY PROPOSALS
RELATED TO LONG TERM INCREASES
AND PENSION COSTS. AND IN
PREVIOUS YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME PROPOSALS AND WE'VE SEEN-
BASED ON THAT ARE MAKING OUT OF
LARGE ONE TIME PAYMENT IN ONE
YEAR CAN PROVIDE SAVINGS OVER A
NUMBER OF DECADES AND REALLY
HELP ADDRESS AND STABILIZE
DISTRICT BUDGETS OVER A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME. AND I THINK. I
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT ONE
REASON WE BRING UP THIS THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT BUDGET-
RESILIENCY CONCERN ISN'T JUST
ABOUT- IS BEING A GOOD FISCAL
PRACTICE ALTHOUGH WE THINK THAT
CLEARLY IS A CONCERN AND I
COULD. JUST CONSIDERATION. BUT
ALSO WE THINK THAT THE BENEFITS
STUDENTS BY INCREASING THE
LIKELIHOOD. THAT THE PROGRAMS
DISTRICTS CREATE OVER THE
COMING YEAR WITH ALL OF THIS
ONE TIME FUNDING THE RECEIVING.
THAT THOSE PROGRAMS CAN BE
SUSTAINED. OVER TIME OVER A
LONGER PERIOD AND THROUGHOUT AN
ECONOMIC CYCLE. BOB SO CAN DOWN
THE PEARLS ACTUALLY SOMETHING
PENSIONS WOULD BOTH THAT WOULD
LEAVE PREPARE BOTH THE STATE
AND DISTRICTS- THE BETTER DEAL
WITH. SOME OF THE ECONOMIC.
UNCERTAINTY ON THE ECONOMIC UPS
AND DOWNS. FIRST OF ALL STOP
THEIR MICHAEL IS A GROUP SOME
ADDITIONAL COMPANY PANEL BUT WE
HAVE THE ANSWER QUESTIONS. OKAY
YOU THAT NEXT DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ELLIE GARNER
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TEMPERAMENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
WE ARE THANKFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR CONTINUES TO MAKE
EDUCATION A TOP PRIORITY IN HIS
BUDGET. MANY OF THE PROPOSALS
IN THE NEIGHBORING VISION
ALIGNED WITH THE SHARED GOALS
OF THE SSD I. ENSURING
EQUITABLE EDUCATION FOR ALL
STUDENTS AND CREATING A FOCUS
ON STUDENTS HIT HARDEST DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. OUR STUDENTS OF
COLOR STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. USE THAT THE
NAY REVISED INCLUDES THE
HIGHEST EVER HELLO FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION AND THE LARGEST K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION PER
PUPIL EXPENDITURE IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY. THE COMPANY
NINETEEN CABINET HAS BRIGHTENED
THE OPPORTUNITY GAP SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A CLOSE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE WEEKS AHEAD TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE THE TO
CLOSE OPPORTUNITY GAPS TO MAKE
SURE THAT STUDENTS RETURNED
SAFELY TO SCHOOL FOR IN PERSON
LEARNING AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS HAVE
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
EXCEL. WE WOULD JUST REQUEST AS
WAS ELECTED LEADER TO AN INCH
AND THAT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERED
THE SAME COLOR FOR CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS AS FOR THE LCS MATH
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION. BUT
SECURELY TO THE EXTENT
ADDITIONAL REVENUES IDENTIFIED
WOULD REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZE
INCREASING THE CALL OF FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE ONLY RECEIVE A ONE
POINT 7% COLLAPSE AS OPPOSED TO
THE FOUR POINT OH SEVEN.
SPECIAL EDUCATION OR THE FIVE
POINT OH SEVEN FOR LCS. THERE
WERE MANY GREAT PROPOSALS AND
ANY REVISION THERE'S ONE IN
PARTICULAR THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT WHICH IS THE
UNIVERSAL TRANSITION. A
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROPOSAL STAR NOVEL MORGAN
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL GRANT TO
YOU HEARD FROM ALREADY. IS HERE
TO PRESENT ON THE UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROPOSAL. SEMI TO AT LEAST
THEIR NOVEL MARC AND-
REPRESENTING THAT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. AS
WE MENTIONED ON THE LAST PANEL
THAT MAY REVISED PROPOSAL TO
HAVE UNIVERSAL TO TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN IMPLEMENTED ACROSS
THE STATE. BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE IS BOTH
HISTORIC AND EXCITING. THIS
PROPOSAL ALSO PRESENTS
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PRE K. THROUGH THIRD GRADE
ALIGNMENT ACROSS THE STATE.
WHICH HAS BEEN FOUND TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT INVESTMENTS IN
PRESCHOOL AND I TRUST THINGS
LIKE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT. WE
HOPE THAT THIS IS A STARK
INVESTMENT WILL THAT
CALIFORNIA'S SERVE MANY MORE.
AT THE NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLD CHILDREN. WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR STATE SUBSIDIZED EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS BUT NOT
SERVED ITEM. THERE ARE CRITICAL
CONSIDERATIONS THAT MUSTBE
ADDRESSED TO MAKE SURE THAT
UNIVERSAL TKA WORKS FOR
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES SPECIFICALLY.
EXPANSION OF T. K. AS WELL AS
STABILIZATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
CREATES AN URGENT NEED FOR AN
ESTIMATED THOUSANDS OF NEW
TEACHERS. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
ADEQUATE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED
AND INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS ARE PUT
INTO PLACE TO SUPPORT THE
EXISTING PRESCHOOL WORK FORCE
AND OTHERS. TO FILL THESE JOBS
SINCE IT IS INDIVIDUALS HAVE
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE ARE
THE FIRST. AND DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE IN THEIR
FIELDS. AND THAT THAT EQUITABLE
COMPENSATION AS WELL AS
BENEFITS. THE TICKET EXPERIENCE
MUST BE DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE. WITH PROPER
SUPPORT TICKET CLASSROOMS CAN
SUPPORT INTENTIONAL LEARNING
THROUGH PLAY. WHICH GO HAND IN
HAND WHEN EDUCATORS ARE QUICK
BUT THOUGHTFUL SEQUENCED
CURRICULA AND HAVE THE SKILLS
AND KNOWLEDGE TO SUPPORT CHILD
DEVELOPMENT. AFRICOM TAXED. HE
CAME MOST ALL SUPPORT FAMILIES
NEEDS AND PRINT CHOICE. THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
AROUND. UNIVERSAL AFTER SCHOOL
FOR TEEKAY FAMILIES IN MANY
SCHOOLS WILL GO A LONG WAY TO
SUPPORT S. AND WE APPRECIATE
EXPANDED EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES. NEED TO HAVE
LOWER ADULT CHILD RATIOS AND BE
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE.
EXCELLENT OPTION THAT MANY
PARENTS WILL CHOOSE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN SO LONG AS THAT IS
DESIGNED TO MEET THEIR NEEDS
AND GEOGRAPHICALLY ACCESSIBLE.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE BEGIN TO
RECOGNIZE THE MATH OF PARENTAL
CHOICE IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM
FOR WHAT IT IS. CURRENTLY MANY
PARENTS ARE FORCED TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN PROGRAMS THAT MIGHT
PROVIDE BETTER EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE
GEOGRAPHICALLY ACCESSIBLE.
HOURS THAT THERE NEEDS. FOR THE
COST FACTORS ENSURING THAT T.
K. LEADS TO AN OVERALL
EXPANSION ACCESS TO THE EARLY
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES INSTEAD
OF A LOSS OF CAPACITY. THIS
WILL REQUIRE SIMULTANEOUSLY AND
THOUGHTFUL PLANNING AND
INVESTMENTS IN NEEDS SIXTEEN
COMMUNITY BASED INFRASTRUCTURE
PRIVATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT
CURRENTLY HAVE SPACE AS WELL AS
STAFF AND EXPERTISE SERVING AT
THESE COMMUNITIES. WE
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION THAT
FACILITIES AND PLANNING SUPPORT
ALONG WITH SUPPORT FOR THE PRE
SCHOOL LEARNING FOUNDATIONS AND
ADDRESSING CURRICULUM. WILL
NEED TO BE OPERATIONALIZED FOR
THIS AND- WE HAVE SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS TO YOU ON THESE
PROPOSALS TO HELP STRENGTHEN
THEM AND ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AS WE WORK
TOWARDS FINALISING. PACKAGES
FINALLY WE WANT TO FLAG THE MAY
WEEK THAT THEY MAY REVISED
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT NEW
WORKLOAD AROUND UTK THE
PRESCHOOLER RENDITIONS AND THE
EARLY MATH INITIATIVE. WITHOUT
CORRESPONDING NEW STATE
OPERATIONAL FUNDING WE'VE
REACHED OUT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE WEBSPHERE THAT
WE WILL NEED TO INVOLVE THE
LEGISLATURE I NEEDED RESOURCES.
TO ADDRESS THE. ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD INCLUDED. THIS
CONCLUDE OUR REMARKS FROM THANK
HAVE DEPARTMENT OF ITS- THANK
YOU FOR. OKAY THANK. THANK YOU-
THAT WRAPS IT UP FOR IN THE
PRESENTERS NOW WILL GO TO-
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM
MANY MEMBERS ALL START WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RANTS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR FIRST I
WANT TO APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR.
IN THIS MAY REVISE FOR THE
MONUMENTAL INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION SYSTEM
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT TO
THEIR NUMBER OF THINGS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN HERE LIKE THE
EXTENDED AND EXPANDED LEARNING.
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND THE
FUNDING FOR EDUCATOR
EFFECTIVENESS. I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS- ROLE IN
PROVIDING FOR AND PUSHING FOR
T. K. THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS I HAVE
HEARD FROM MANY OF OUR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND WOULD LIKE
TO ADVOCATE FOR THE MIXED
DELIVERY THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
IN THE BARDEN PROPOSAL WE HEAR
SO MUCH ABOUT AND I APPRECIATE.
AGAIN THE CHAIRS WORKING WITH
THE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE LOOK AT ALL
OF THESE POSSIBILITIES WHEN WE
LOOK AT CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WHAT WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
OUR PROVIDERS. WE'RE THE ONES
THAT WERE THE FRONT LINE
WORKERS THEY WERE THE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ARE THE ONES THAT KEPT
EVERYTHING GOING PUT THEIR LIFE
ON THE LINE. AND THEY DESERVE
TO BE RECOGNIZED AND
COMPENSATED IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE ESSENTIAL SERVICES THAT
THEY'VE PROVIDED. ANOTHER AREA
IS OUR SPECIAL NEEDS CHILDREN
I'VE HEARD FROM MANY IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND I KNOW THAT ISN'T
NECESSARILY WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE BUT I DO WANT TO
BRING THIS UP NOW- ARE SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILDREN. NEED ADDITIONAL
SERVICES AND I KNOW THAT THERE
IS- THE INCREASE IN THE BUDGET
TO DEAL WITH THIS- AND I WANT
TO BE SURE THAT. THEIR VOICES
AND THEIR NEEDS ARE HEARD AND
THAT WE HEED THEIR PLEAS
BECAUSE IT ISN'T JUST A REQUEST
THEY ARE PLEADING WITH US TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILDREN. IT WITH REGARD TO THE
CHILD CARE- VERY SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDING THE RATE INCREASES.
FOR THE PROVIDERS ACCESS ACROSS
ALL CARE SETTINGS. AND TO
ELIMINATE THE FAMILY FEES. BUT
MOST IMPORTANT I THINK THAT
IT'S  WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
SO THAT OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM
IS PROTECTED. WELL WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH RTK. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK REQUIRES
LEADERSHIP. AND THAT IS WHY
PERSONALLY I APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF OUR CHAIR. OF
FROM FROM THE SUB COMMITTEE IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD IN A WAY THAT IS
EQUITABLE AND I WANT TO THANK
HIM FOR THAT. THANK YOU SOMEONE
NEVER KNOW YOU HAVE MAJORITY
LEADER DUTIES TODAY SO YOU'RE
IN AND OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
BUT- WHAT I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAD OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
FROM YOU ON THIS ISSUE THAT
YOU'RE- OFFENDED TO. I FELL OF
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION AS WELL
AND- I'LL HAVE A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS WILL BE START WITH A
COMMITMENT MISTER DONALD HE
HAD- YES THANK YOU- A LONG
PRESENTATION BECAUSE IT'S A
LONG LIST- BUT AGAIN I THINK
WE'RE HEADING CERTAINLY IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION WE WOULD ALL
AGREE. PHAM ALL JUST HAVE A FEW
A FEW QUESTIONS HERE- THIS ONE
IS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WITH REGARD TO THE SUB
MODEL PLANET OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT. IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE WAS
AGREEMENT AMONG STAKEHOLDERS
THAT. WE WILL CONTINUE ON WITH
THE SUPPLEMENTAL A PAYMENT IN
ORDER TO RAISE THE FLOOR PROP
NINETY EIGHT WHY ARE WE
ABANDONING THIS SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS AT THIS TIME. YOU'RE
SEEKING TO MOTIONS AND-
PROPOSING TO. COURSE AREA ARE
OF FINANCE ALL TAKE A ANSWER
THAT QUESTION SO IF YOU RECALL
GO ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE HAD. AT
THE BUDGET ACT OF LAST YEAR I
BATES ARE CALCULATED THAT THE
CRIME THE ASSUMPTION WAS THAT
THE TEST ONE CALCULATED AMOUNT
ATTACHED TO CALCULATING AMOUNT
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THE TESTS TO
CALCULATE MY WAS GOING TO BE
OVER TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
HIGHER THAN THE PAST ONE
CALCULATED AMOUNT CUMULATIVELY-
WITH NO MECHANISM- UNDER
CURRENT LAW FOR SCHOOLS TO
REGAIN NOT FUNDING ON AN
ONGOING BASIS- IN THE GUARANTEE
OF A JETS. ATTACHED TO WOULD
HAVE BEEN THAT MUCH HIGHER WE
WOULD FUND IT AT ONE- AND THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN THAT LOST
RELATIVES TO AMOUNTS OF THE WAS
THE MAIN MAJOR IMPETUS BETWEEN
RESTORING ORIGINAL MODEL
PAYMENTS ARE MEANT TO RESTORE
THAT TWELVE POINT FOUR BILLION
OVER A PERIOD OF SEVERAL YEARS.
NOW AS- MY COLLEAGUE CAN THAT
THE L. A. L. MENTIONED. IN PART
WITH. BOX INCLUDED DIFFERENT IS
NO LONGER A NAY TOLD POINT FOUR
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY A CALL. NINE
THREE THREE. AND SO AT THE-
BACK WAS THE MAIN- THINKING
ABOUT BEHIND. US REMOVING A
COUPLE NAY PAYMENTS ALTOGETHER
THANK ARE NOW BACK ON A
TRAJECTORY MUCH MORE SO. TO IT
NOT BY THAN. WHAT WE HAD US- I
THINK BUDGET. OF TWENTY TWO
ONE. THE COMPANY PANDEMIC AND
ALL THE ASSOCIATED. ASSUMPTIONS
THAT WERE MADE AFTER THAT
ADDITIONALLY. I MENTIONED AS
WELL THERE IS EIGHT POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN. EXTRA
BATTLE THAT'S GOING TO BE GOOD-
GOING BACK TO. K. FOURTEEN
SCHOOLS AND PROBABLY 8485% OF
THAT WILL GO DIRECTLY TO K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS I JUST ON THE
BASIS THAT THE MOMENT- AND NOT.
LARA DISCRETIONARY FUND FOR
THEM THEY ARE SO BUT WAS THAT
ALL OF EVERYTHING I MENTIONED
AND THEN WITH THE FACT THAT
DOLLARS THE BEFORE ONE BILLION-
AND ALL THE COMPUTER PARTY
WITHIN THE BY. AT LARGE- THAT.
WHAT MADE THE MOST FOR US THE
MAYOR VISION HEARING WHICH ALSO.
ALLOWED DO DIRECT- TRULY
UNPRECEDENTED OF RESOURCES FOR
K. TWELVE SCHOOLS AS THEY
NAVIGATE BOTH FIVE RESPONDED
PANDEMIC AND ALSO OF COURSE
JUST. RISING FIXED COSTS THAT
ARE A PART BECAUSE THE DOING
BUSINESS THAT THEY HAVE ON. ON
WHAT BASIS. THANK YOU BUT BUT
THE AGAIN THERE'S NO. THAT THE
SET THAT THE THAT THE
TRAJECTORY WE ARE ON WILL
EXCEED THE SUPPLEMENT PAYMENTS
THAT OCCUR. WELL I BELIEVE WE
ARE ALREADY BACK. WELL YEAH
THAT'S CORRECT IF WE IF THE
REGULAR ON. MAY OR MAY NOT NEED
IF WE WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE
APPLIED THE PROBLEM ON A
PAYMENT IN EACH YEAR ON TOP WO
POINT SIX BILLION GROWING TO
WHATEVER IT WOULD WORK OUT TO
BE NOT YEAH BUT- THAT FACTOR.
THANK YOU. BOB WITH REGARD TO
THE COLD IT'S GOOD I'VE I'D
LIKE A LITTLE BIT HIGHER MAYBE.
TWO APPLIED OF TO MORE PROGRAMS
TO TOOK TO THE OTHER CREDIT TO
OTHER CATEGORICAL- I MEAN FOR A
LONG LIST YOU'RE SO EXCUSE ME
FROM. TAKING TO FIND MY
THOUGHTS HERE- WITH REGARD TO
REOPEN SCHOOLS MORE MONEY FOR
RE OPENING SCHOOLS TO SCHOOLS
NEED REALLY NEED MORE MONEY TO
RE OPEN. WE GAVE THEM A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT ALREADY TO
REOPEN. AND IF THEY DIDN'T TAKE
IT THEY DIDN'T REOPEN SO THEY
WOULD NEED THE MONEY SO WHAT
WOULD THEY NEED MORE MONEY FOR
NOW. PROBABLY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. HIS DESK
HOMES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE VISION INCLUDES THE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY GRANTS ON TO AUGMENT
WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN PROVIDED
SO AB EIGHTY SIX INCLUDED- TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THOSE
ELEAZAR THAT OPENED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR- CAN AND IS
AVAILABLE INTO THE INTO THE
BUDGET YEAR BUT WAS REALLY MADE
AVAILABLE TO COVER THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THINGS THAT
COULD BE TESTING IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. SO THESE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
WHICH ARE AVAILABLE TO ALL AND
LIAISE ON THE BASIS THAT THE
PROPORTION OF LCF BATH- ARE
AVAILABLE ACROSS THE STATE AND
ALI IT'S FOR WORK IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN THE IN THE
BUDGET YEAR STILL A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WAS AB
EIGHTY SIX. AND REST TO THE-
THE SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS THE ELEAZAR- ARE
RECEIVING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THOSE ARE GOING
OUT ON THE BASIS OF TITLE ONCE
OR NOT- CONSISTENTLY AVAILABLE
TO ALL AREAS ACROSS THE STATE.
I THINK THAT THAT POLICY
CONCERN HERE IS THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE IN ENCOURAGING
FAMILIES TO RETURN TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION- THAT THEY FEEL
LIKE THEIR SCHOOLS ARE.
PROPERLY RESOURCE TO PROVIDE
THAT INSTRUCTION AND HOW
HEALTHY AND SAFE MANNER. OKAY-
COMMONWEALTH I HOPE WE'RE
TRACKING HE EXPENDITURES OF
THOSE DOLLARS ARE WE ALREADY
DOLED OUT OF BEEN EXPENDED. SO
WE'RE NOT JUST ADDING ON MORE
MONEY WHAT IT MIGHT. AND I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THIS
MIGHT NOT IN FACT BE NEEDED
YOUR MONITORING THAT ASPECT I
ASSUME. CORRECT SO SPECIFICALLY
WITH THE FEDERAL FUNDS THERE IS
A FEDERAL THERE'S A MONITORING
REQUIREMENT. OF EXPENDITURES
FOR THE FEDERAL FUNDS- IN
REGARDS TO THE STATE FUNDS THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING TO PUT OUT- AND
THAT ALLOWABLE EXPENDITURES TO
BE CAUGHT- THROUGH THE AUDIT
PROCESS. PROPELLERS ALLOWABLE
EXPENDITURES THOSE TRACKING THE
DOLLARS SPENT. AYE AYE YOU YOU
EXPLAIN THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS TRACKING THE
DOLLARS THAT IS A STATE TO.
TRACKING THE DOLLARS IT HAS
SPENT FOR BERMAN SPENT RE
OPENING. SO THE FEDERAL DOLLARS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR RE
OPENING- HAVE RECALL HAVE AS
TRACKING REQUIREMENTS ATTACHED
TO THEM THAT THE STATE IS-
ADMINISTERING SO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION HAS BEEN WORKING
ON THE FEDERAL TRACKING
REQUIREMENTS- IN TERMS OF THE
STATE FUNDING THAT'S AVAILABLE-
I WOULD DEFER. FOR THE EIGHTY
SIX BUT THEY WERE DIFFERENT
STP- AND- IN TERMS OF WHAT
KINDS OF TRACKING THEY'RE
DOING. I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE
INCLUDED IN THAT LANGUAGE- A
SPECIFIC MECHANISM AROUND
TRACKING THE EXPENDITURES FOR
THOSE FUNDS BEYOND WHAT WOULD
NORMALLY BE CAPTURED AND- FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE STOCK SYSTEM.
THE KICK IN THE REAR I AM IS
BECAUSE MAYBE. THEY DON'T NEED
THE MONEY AND THE MONEY COULD
BE PUT TO A- SOME OTHER USED TO
CD HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT. I'M
SORRY AT. A SOMEONE CAN YOU
SHARE YOUR QUESTION AGAIN I'M
NOT THESE. I'M SORRY WHAT THE
QUESTION AGAIN. YES PLEASE OKAY
YOUR QUESTIONS ARE YOU TRACKING
THE FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN SENT
TO DISTRICT FOR REOPENING
SCHOOLS THERE'S A FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT THAT WE TRACK THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS BUT EVERY
TRACKING THE STATE DOLLARS THAT
HAVE GONE TO SCHOOLS RE OPENING
AND THE CONTEXT IS ASKING WHY
ARE WE GIVING SCHOOLS MORE
MONEY IF WE'RE NOT SURE IF THEY
EVEN NEEDED NOW THEY VERY WELL
MAY. I'M NOT SAYING THEY DON'T
AS MUCH THEM DO WE HAVE DATA
RELATIVE TO THIS. STILL V.
LEGISLATION AT THE EIGHTY
EIGHTY SIX LEGISLATION. ONLY
REQUIRED A FINAL REPORT WE ARE
NOT CURRENTLY TRACKING. ON HOW
THE SPENT THE HOW DOLLARS ARE
GOING OUT I WILL SAY THAT WE
ARE GETTING THEM OUT BUT- THOSE
ARE JUST NOW STARTING TO GET TO
THE SCHOOLS AND SO IT. WE DON'T
HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF. HOW
THEY'RE USING THEM AND WHAT
THEY'RE USING THEM FORM AND
OTHER THAN THE ALLOW POLICE
THAT'S- RIGHT THANK YOU MAYBE
THAT'S THE CONVERSATION WE HAVE
TO HAVE GOING FORWARD. OUR NEXT
QUESTION IS WITH REGARD
INDEPENDENT STUDIES. RIGHT NOW
INDEPENDENT STUDIES IS YOU KNOW
IT. AS I'VE COME TO UNDERSTAND
IS THE WILD WEST YOU CAN PRETTY
MUCH DO ANYTHING. AND PRETTY
MUCH DO NOTHING THERE'S FOR
EXAMPLE. IF A STUDENT IS
INDEPENDENT STUDY THERE'S NO
REQUIRED STUDENT TEACHER
CONTACT TIME. K. IS A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS THAT CAN HAPPEN
AND AN INDEPENDENT STUDY THEY
DON'T SERVE- THE ACADEMIC NEEDS
OF A CHILD WE REALLY NEED TO
CLEAN THAT UP I KNOW THERE'S
SOME LANGUAGE I BELIEVE IS
COMING OUT TODAY. I HAVEN'T
SEEN IT IT WAS COMING OUT OF
THE GUYS WERE WALKING INTO THE
ROOM MAYBE. SO MAYBE YOU COULD
SPEAK TO THAT A LITTLE BIT WHAT
WHAT DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
INTENDED. TO IT TO PROPOSED
WITH REGARD TO INDEPENDENT
STUDIES AND ESPECIALLY IN THE
AREAS OF CREDENTIALING. DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION AGREE THAT
TEACHERS SHOULD HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE CREDENTIALS. IF YOU
COULD MAYBE SPEAK TO THE
OVERALL- TOPIC OF INDEPENDENT
STUDIES SUGGEST- TOOK- PROPOSED
TRAILER LANGUAGE AND THE- THE
APPROPRIATE- CREDENTIALING AND
MAYBE ANYTHING ELSE YOU'RE
DOING THERE BECAUSE AGAIN. I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO AYE I KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE
STUDENTS ON INDEPENDENT STUDY
THAN WE EVER HAVE NEXT YEAR. WE
CAN LIKE IT OR NOT LIKE IT'S
JUST A FACT THAT'S GOING TO
OCCUR. SO THE FACT IS WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THOSE STUDENTS
THAT DO ON DO DO FALL UNDER THE
INDEPENDENT STUDIES UMBRELLA.
THERE IS- ACADEMIC
ACCOUNTABILITY. ON THE ON THE
THERE'S THAT KIND OF EARLY ON
THE ACADEMIC SIDE AND THE
FISCAL SIDE. SO COULD THE
ADMINISTRATION. SPEAK TO THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE. CERTAINLY
AND JUST GO HOMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO YOU ARE CORRECT AS
A MEMBER OF DONNELL AND THAT
LANGUAGE WAS RELEASED LAST
NIGHT SO MOST PEOPLE THOUGHT
THIS MORNING- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
MAKE SOME CHANGES TO THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY LANGUAGE-
THAT ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING AN OPTION FOR
FAMILIES- IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO SCHOOL YEAR FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING. HOWEVER
WANTED CABBIE OUT ALL OF THAT
AND KIND OF PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT BY SAYING THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING THAT THE DEFAULT IS
IN PERSON FULL TIME IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN THE FALL- ELLIE
GAYS WILL ONLY HAVE THE SAME
TWO OPTIONS FOR BURNING AND
STATE APPORTIONMENT IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND THEY DID PRE
PANDEMIC. AND THAT IS THE MUST
OFFER ALL STUDENTS ACCESS TO A
FULL TIME IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
PROGRAM THEY CAN EARN A PORTION
OF THAT WAY AND THEN THEY CAN
CHOOSE TO OFFER INDEPENDENT
STUDY PROGRAM AND PARENTS CAN
OPT INTO THAT PROGRAM IF THEY
WISH. BUT ALL. THE IS CLEAR ALL
THE- WILL BE OFFERED. ACTS TO A
FULL TIME IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
PROGRAM IN THE FALL. SO THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY PIECE THAT IS
THE OPTIONAL I'M PROGRAM THE
LEDS CAN PROVIDE IN THAT
PARENTS CAN OPT INTO. IS BUILT
ON THE EXISTING INDEPENDENT
STUDY PROGRAM WE HAD SOME
STRONG CONCERNS ABOUT- THE
QUALITY OF SOME OF THE
INDEPENDENT THREE PROGRAMS THAT
WERE BEING. CONDUCTED A
MINISTER PRIOR TO COMMITTING
DURING COVE IT- IN A LOT OF
THEM HAVE TO DO I THINK WITH A
SIMILAR CONCERN. THAT YOU ALL
HAVE AROUND YOU KNOW THE IDEA
THAT UNDER THE OLD LAWS YOU
KNOW AT AT. AN EARLY AGE COULD
SEND A PACKET HOME WITH THE
STUDENTS AND- YOU KNOW THE
STUDENTS ACTUALLY IS TEACHING
THEMSELVES AND THEN COMING BACK
AND SWITCHING OUT PACKETS TWO
WEEKS LATER YOUTHAT THAT. IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE NOT
SUPPORT OF A- SO ARE PER. AND
IS. ON IT OF- IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE EXISTING PROGRAM. THE FIRST
EING THAT- FOR ANY STUDENT
THAT IS PARTICIPATING OPTING
INTO AN INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAM LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY WILL BE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE DEVICE
THAT TECH THAT TECHNOLOGY
ESSENTIALLY DEVICE AND
CONNECTIVITY. ON TO PARTICIPATE
IN ONLINE INSTRUCTION- ANOTHER
KEY PIECE IN TERMS OF THE
STUDENT TEACHER ENGAGEMENT IS
THAT THE- TEACHER WILL BE
REQUIRED TO DO A DAILY CHECK
INS WITH A STUDENT TODAY TO
CHECK IN WITH THEM MAKE SURE
THEY'RE OKAY SEE IF THEY HAVE
ANY NEEDS OR CONCERNS. AND THEN
AT LEAST ONE DAY A WEEK
PROVIDES SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION WITH THAT STUDENT
SO THE IDEA OF BEING HERE THAT
AT LEAST ONCE A WEEK THAT THAT
THE TEACHER HAS TO PROVIDE A
LESSON TO THE INDEPENDENT STUDY
STUDENTS. ON THE LISTING CHRIS
MANNER- IN ADDITION WE HAVE
SOME. AROUND RE ENGAGEMENT
STRATEGIES FOR THIS IS SIMILAR
TO WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE AGREED TO- WE PUT
TOGETHER SB NINETY EIGHT IN SB
TWENTY AROUND TO AGREEING GAUGE
AND STRATEGIES. ON BEING PUT IN
PLACE FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT
ENGAGED ON FOR THREE DAYS AT
LEAST THREE DAYS- OR 60% OF
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME. HERE STILL
ENSURING THAT THOSE KIDS WHO
ARE NOT BEING SERVED WELL AND
IN THE AN INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAM HAVE- SOMEONE REACHING
OUT TO THEM TO ENSURE THAT THEY
CAN RE ENGAGE IN THAT PROCESS.
SO THAT'S SORT OF A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF THE CHANGES THAT WE
ARE PROPOSING- HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS HONOR. GREAT NOW
THANK THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THAT AND AGAIN I DON'T THINK IT
WAS MUCH QUITE FRANKLY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSING IN
THIS TIME. TO REALLY BOLSTER
THAT PROGRAM ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY THERE NEEDS TO
BE GREATER AUDITING. I WOULD IN
A PERFECT WORLD I GRADUATE THE
FUNDING OF A STUDENTS AT SCHOOL
IS NOT IN A SCHOOL SETTING. THE
SCHOOL- THAT THE ALLEGATION NOT
GET FULL FUNDING FOR THAT
STUDENT- UNIVERSITY YOU KNOW
STEVE YOU'RE NOT NEVER THERE
ARE ONLY ONLINE WHITE WHITE WHY
WE SHOULD THEY RECEIVE FULL
EIGHTY AGE MAYBE MAYBE SEVENTY
PERCENT. IS THAT OF BRICKS AND
MORTAR AND ALL THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH BRICKS AND
MORTAR SHOULD BE A GRADUATED
FUNDING- A STREAM. AND AGAIN%
THE AUDITS ARE KEY AND
BOLSTERING THE ACADEMIC SIDE I
REALLY DON'T THINK WE'RE THERE
YET- YEAH I THINK IT IT'S GOING
TO BE PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE MORE
CHILDREN- IT YET ENGAGING AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY- NEXT YEAR
BUT THAT'S- THE TOP. AT THE
PART OF THE ONE OF THE TOP OF
THE HEARING THIS HEARING BUT
NOT THE ONLY TOPIC. BUT AGAIN-
WITH REGARD TO- IT INDEPENDENT
STUDY NOW WE HAVE AS COMPANIES
COMING INTO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IN OFFERING TO HANDLE THEIR
ONLINE LEARNING FOR THEM. AND
THAT- PRESENTS A COUPLE
QUESTIONS AB FIVE ALONE. AB
FIVE VIOLATIONS. SO I HOPE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS WILLING TO
ENGAGE IN CONVERSATIONS. TO
ENSURE THAT- I INDEPENDENT
STUDY IS. IS BOLSTERED AND
APPROPRIATE AND LEGAL- SO WHAT
WE'LL HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
GOING FORWARD- SO LET ME SWITCH
TO A DIFFERENT QUESTION HERE US
PROBABLY AGAIN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH
REGARD TO THE RE BENCHING A
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT IS
THERE IS THERE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE YET ON THE RE BENCHING
OF PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT IS
IT A TREE BENCHING. AND WHAT
WITH THE GUARANTEE BE THAT IT
ACTUALLY IS A REINVENTION AND
THAT THOSE THAT DID REMAINS
FUNDED IN THE OUT YEARS
ESPECIALLY IF WE'RE GOING TO
ADD A GRADE LEVEL THE PEOPLE
LEADER STANDIFER ADDING T. K.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
ADDING A GRADE LEVEL WE DON'T
WANT TO JUST ADD A GRADE LEVEL
TO AN EXISTING BUCKET OF
DOLLARS WE WANT TO GROW THAT.
BUCKET OF DOLLARS AS WE GROW
THE STUDENTS THAT WERE ADDING
INTO THAT POCKET SO AGAIN THE
QUESTION IS WHAT IT WHAT ONE OF
THEMECHANICS REINVENTION
PROPOSITION. NINETY EIGHT IS
THERE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE YET
FOR THAT. OF COURSE. THE OTHER
PERMANENT FINANCE AGAIN I'LL
ANSWER THAT QUESTION ACTUALLY.
I THINK YOU DESCRIBED IT QUITE
TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT.
THE INTENT WITH EVERY BATCH IT
TO BE ABLE TO GROW THE POT OF
FUNDING IN THE CASE UNDER OUT
THE ATTACK WITH THE FEET WITH
THIS INCREASE OF ADA. AND NOT
JUST CROWD OUT FUNDING. FOR
OTHER PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF
INCREASED ABOUT THE ABOUT WITH
HIM. PROBABLY NINETY EIGHT- IF
WE IF WE DIDN'T TAKE THAT
APPROACH SO. AT THE MOMENT.
BECAUSE BE ADDITIONAL ADA NOT
THAT TO. BE ROLE THEN UNTIL
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. LPF
PERCEIVED THE CONTINUOUS OF
CORPORATION. OF THE APPROACH AT
THE MOMENT IS THAT WE WOULD.
OVER APPROPRIATE- THE
GUARANTEED MOST LIKELY BY
WHATEVER. AMOUNT OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WE ESTIMATE. WILL BE
INTRODUCED ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
INCREASE THEN CAN. TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE- AND
THEN ONE. FULL IMPLEMENTATION
IS ACHIEVED AFTER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS FROM THERE- WE
WOULD LOOK AT EXACTLY WHAT
WOULD MAKE THE MOST SENSE
WHETHER IT'S AN ONGOING TEST
ONE PERCENTAGE REBOUNDS OR OR
SOME OTHER MECHANISM ASSUMING
WE- WOULD STILL BE AN ATTACHED
ONE AT THAT TIME- WE WOULD LOOK
AT THAT. DOWN BUT CURRENTLY
UNDER THE- TRAILER BILL AS-
DRAFTED THE MOMENT THERE IS NOT
JUST A BIG LANGUAGE TO THAT
EFFECT. RIGHT- THANK YOU I.
WITH REGARD TO THE EXTENT OF
THE HOW THOSE- DAHLE DIFFERENT
THAN THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION.
WE ALREADY PROVIDED FOR
LEARNING LOS. CARLOS DOLLARS
DIFFERENT WHAT EXTENDED
LEARNING VERSUS LEARNING LOSSES
OF THE SAME THING THAT MORE
MONEY FOR THE SAME PURPOSE.
PROBABLY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. APARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION-
WAS GEARED TOWARDS EXPANDING
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES WHICH
INCLUDED EXTENDING
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME ACCELERATING
PROGRESS TO CLOSE ANY GAPS AND
INTEGRATED SUPPORTS- THERE MAY
BE SOME OVERLAP WITH THE LEVEL
USES RELATED TO TUTORING AND
LEARNING RECOVERY PROGRAMS BUT
A. B. B. SIX WAS OUT A LITTLE
MORE BROAD TO ADDRESS IMMEDIATE
NEEDS ARRANGING RENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS TO COMMUNITY SUPPORT
CLUBS- ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY-
THESE FARMS THE TWO POIT SIX
BILLION WITH SUPPLEMENTAL FOUR
POINT SIX BILLION INVESTMENT
FOR- GEARING TOWARDS INTENSIVE.
EACH MINUTE RESEARCH TESTED
INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS HIGH DOES
TUTORING AND IS INTENDED TO
SUPPORT LONGER TERM NEEDS OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS TO SUPPORT
TARGETED INTERVENTION AND RE
ENGAGEMENT- FOCUSING ON
STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
BACKGROUNDS ENGLISH LEARNERS
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO HAPPEN ON
THIS FORTUNATELY IMPACTED. BY
THE KIND OF. THANK YOU I THINK
WE NEED TO. ECN THAT EVERY
STUDENT HAS BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. AND EVERY STUDENT
HAS HAS NEEDS I MEAN THERE ARE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE
TRADITIONALLY GOTTEN- FOUR
POINT NO THAT ARE NOW TO THREE
POINT TWO. SO WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THOSE
STUDENTS TO IT CAN'T BE JUST AT
THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL CREDIT
RECOVERY IT ALSO NEEDS TO BE
GPA RECOVERY SO I HELP OR
THINKING- BROADLY ON THIS AGAIN
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY STUDENTS
WHO. WOULD HAVE DONE FINE BUT
FOR THE PANDEMIC THAT NOW ARE
NOT DOING SO FINE. AND THEIR
GPAS HAVE DROPPED ARE NOT GOING
TO GET ENOUGH CALLS THAT THEY
POTENTIALLY WOULD HAVE HAD THE
PANDEMIC. NOT HIT BUT WE NEED
TO THINK OF ALL STUDENTS. AND
CERTAINLY THERE ARE SOME THAT
ARE HURTING MORE THAN OTHERS
BUT- BUT BUT BUT MANY ARE
HURTING THAT WE MADE. THAT
MIGHT NT HAVE BEEN HURTING
YEAH- BUT FOR THE PANDEMICS ARE
OVERWORKED FOR THINKING BROADLY
ON IS. JUST ANOTHER A TOPIC A
CT. I MEAN IT'S TRAGIC THAT
THERE'S NO INCREASE IN CD
FUNDING- THERE'S A GREAT DEMAND
FOR THESE DOLLARS- THERE'S MORE
DEMAND THAN DOLLARS AND THIS
IS. ONE YEAR WE CAN TAKE CARE
OF THAT ADDRESS THAT ISSUE- ONE
OTHER ISSUE IS WITH PERSON
STIRS IS THERE AN INVESTMENT IN
PERSON STIRS. IT THE ON THE
MINIMUM IF YOU WILL- WHAT THE
WHAT IS TYPICALLY PUT INTO YOUR
PERSON STIRS AN ANNUAL BASIS.
THAT'S PROBABLY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I HAS
JUST GONE TO PARTNER FINANCE SO
BE- THE EMPLOYER SHARE OF COST
FOR SCHOOLS- PER PERSON SCARES
IS STILL RECEIVING AND THE ONE
TIME BENEFIT PROVIDED ON THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT THAT
PROVIDED RESOURCES TO PAY DOWN
THE RATES IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND
THEN 202-020-2020 ONE AND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- BUT WE
ARE NOT PROPOSING ADDITIONAL
PAYMENTS INTO PERSON SERVICE ON
BEHALF. OF- SCHOOL EMPLOYERS.
OKAY I THINK YOU ARE WE ARE
STATE WHY ARE WE ARE WE PUTTING
MORE MONEY INTO PERSON SIR SO I
PULLED I THOUGHT WE WERE. FOR
UHHUH. I BELIEVE. GOD THIRTY.
I'M SORRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
THE HOW CAN TO FIND WITH THE
GENTLEST OFFICE SO- WE'RE NOT
MAKING ANY ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS
LIKE WE HAVE IN PREVIOUS YEARS
BUT BOTH THE STATE CONTRIBUTION
RATE IN THE DISTRICT
CONTRIBUTION RATE IS GOING UP.
OVER TIME AND HAS BEEN GOING
UP- SO THOSE ARE INCREASES
LIKELY RELATED TO PAYING DOWN
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES WE JUST
THINK THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY WITH THIS- LARGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S
AVAILABLE THIS YEAR TO
ACCELERATE THAT PROCESS AND
GAIN SOME ADDITIONAL SAVINGS.
OVER POTENTIALLY THE NEXT
COUPLE DECADES. THANK YOU TO ME
THE NEW BRAINER THE STATE WOULD
PUT MORE MONEY INTO THE SO. IN
PERSON STIRS. AND JUST ONE LAST
THING IS WITH REGARD TO PULLING
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON
THE ADULTS IN CHARTER SCHOOLS-
A TO ME THAT'S JUST CRIMINAL
MAYBE EVEN LITERALLY- AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT WE'RE NOW
GOING TO OPEN- THIS MONEY THE
THAT THE- ADULTS. INTO THESE
PRO OR INTO INTO BASICALLY PROP
NINETY EIGHT PROGRAMS IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS IS ONLY GONNA
GROW. SO THEY'RE ONLY GOING TO
ADD JOB OUT- MONEY THAT WE USED
TO EDUCATE. PRE K. THROUGH
FOURTEEN STUDENTS AND I JUST
THINK THAT'S RATHER UNFORTUNATE
I GET THE POLITICS OF IT BUT I
THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE WITH
THAT BACK TO YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU. I THINK AS YOU NOTED
THERE'S SOME HIGH LEVEL ISSUES
THAT WE'RE SPENDING A LOT OF
OUR TIME ON BUT- THIS. PROPOSAL
HAS QUITE A FEW NEW THINGS AND-
YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE TO- PASSER
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE BY THE
FIFTEENTH OF JUNE FOR THE
BUDGET BUT- SOME OF THESE
THINGS. YOU KNOW MAY WE MAY NOT
AGREE ON RIGHT AWAY AND FIGURE
OUT AND WE CERTAINLY HAVE THE
REST THIS SUMMER AS WELL SO
JUST. KEEP THAT AS WELL THE FOR
NOT TOTALLY COMFORTABLE YOU CAN
ALWAYS REVISIT SOME OF THESE
PIECES- SOME MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER. YEAH I JUST-
RIGHT I THINK MY COLLEAGUE
BROUGHT UP SEVERAL I THINK WE
GET ISSUES THERE- TO BE
THINKING ABOUT AGAIN I'M GONNA
COME BACK TO. I REALLY THINK WE
NEED TO BE PUTTING OUR FOCUS ON
SHORING UP AND IMPROVING OUR
EXISTING SYSTEM. AND NOT
GETTING TOO CARRIED AWAY WITH A
LOT OF NEW PROGRAMMING- AND
I'LL SAY IT THIS WAY. ARE ALL
OF OUR SCHOOLS COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. HEY LET'S JUST FOCUS
ON ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS INSTEAD
OF NOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
SPECIAL PROGRAM FOR SOME NEW.
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS- IDEA. AND A
COMMUNITY ADMINISTRATION- AND I
THINK IN ORDER TO DO THAT
THERE'S SEVERAL THINGS THAT
THAT THAT SHOULD BE REMEDIED
AND- IN OUR- BUDGET ONE OF THAT
I BROUGHT TO THE COMMITTEE
SEVERAL TIMES I REALLY HOPE WE
WORK ON IS A MINIMUM FUNDING
FOR RURAL SCHOOLS. THAT SAID
THERE IS A THERE'S VERY MUCH A
MISSING MIDDLE AND RURAL
SCHOOLS THEY GET THEY GET
HAMPERED AFFECTED YOU KNOW
DRASTICALLY BY LCF FORMULA WE
TALKED ABOUT DOING IT EARLIER
THIS YEAR AND EARLY ACTION. I
THINK THE SENATE HAD A PROPOSAL
FOR A MINIMUM I'M I REALLY HOPE
HEY WE HAVE THIS ADDITIONAL
MONEY LET'S LET'S TRY AND
REMEDY THAT- SPECIAL EDUCATION
YESTERDAY IN A CALL INCREASE
THAT'S GREAT. BUT JUST LAST
YEAR THE GOVERNOR WAS SAYING HE
HAD A THREE FOR A THREE YEAR
PHASE IN MULTI YEAR PROCESS TO
REALLY INVEST IN OUR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. AND THIS THIS
PROPOSAL AS MAY REVISE DOESN'T
GET US THERE IT'S BETWEEN WHEN
YOU COMPARE WHAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT DOING ITS A VERY
MINIMAL. INVESTMENT CERTAINLY
WE NEED TO GET SPECIAL
EDUCATION RIGHT THAT'S BEEN A
BIG FOCUS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
I THINK WE SHOULD MAKE THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT BASED ON
THIS THREE YEAR PROGRAM THAT WE
WERE ALREADY TALKING ABOUT.
DOING CT GETTING NO CALL
INCREASE STILL IN THIS MERRY
VISES JUST COMPLETELY
RIDICULOUS WE KNOW THAT WE NEED
THESE PROGRAMS WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT. THEY ARE LET'S SHOW
THAT THEY'RE IMPORTANT. NOT BY
GIVING ZERO. AND ANY OF HILL
IT'S EVEN MORE CRAZY ABOUT
THAT. IS THE CASE THROUGH
TWELVE CT IS GETTING NO CALL
INCREASE. BUT THE SORRY THE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS GAINING A
CALL INCREASE Y. IT MAKES NO
SENSE AND WE HAVE TALKED BEFORE
ABOUT MAYBE NEED TO CONSOLIDATE
THESE ANYWAY AS- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LONG BEACH IS TALKED
ABOUT. BUT IF THESE ARE A
PRIORITY THEN LET'S INVEST IN
THEM AND MAKE SURE THAT. WE
HAVE SUSTAINABLE- CONTINUOUS
AND EFFECTIVE FUNDING FOR THE
C. T. PROGRAMS. FOSTER YOUTH A
SIMILAR STORY- WE HAD THE L. A.
O. DO A REPORT. THEY CAME OUT
WITH IT- RECOMMEND IN THE NEAR
TERM GOLD ALLOCATING FUNDS
BASED ON A TWO TIER FOR MODEL.
ONE FOR ALL FOSTER YOUTH IN A
SECOND RATE FOR STUDENTS IN
SHORT TERM- RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS- BUT YET
IN THIS MAY REVISE THAT THE
FUNDING FOR OUT OF HOME CARE
PROGRAM THIS IS STILL CURRENTLY
FROZEN- SO WE NEED TO MAKE
CHANGES THERE AND ENSURE THAT
OUR FOSTER YOUTH. IN IN OUR
EXISTING EDUCATION SYSTEMS- ARE
BEING ADDRESSED SO I MEAN THOSE
WOULD BE THE POINTS THAT I
WOULD REALLY. FOCUS ON I THINK
AS A COMMITTEE WE SHOULD- TRY
REINFORCE IN THIS BUDGET
PROCESS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OKAY THANK YOU FOR. SO
THE NUMBER OF I. S. THANK YOU-
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY KEY POINTS
BROUGHT UP BY MY COLLEAGUES
TODAY- I REALLY WANT TO TOUCH
ON SPECIAL EDUCATION- THIS IS
A- GROUP OF STUDENTS- IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE- BUT- REALLY- K.
THROUGH TWELVE BECAUSE WE DO
SERVE TO KATE NOW- THAT. HAS
HAD A REALLY TOUGH YEAR AND I
KNOW ALL OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE A
TOUGH YEAR- BUT HAS IT HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY STRENUOUS DOWN THE
REGRESSION THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
SO MANY SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS-
IS SOMETHING THAT- WE'RE GONNA
BE. TRYING TO RECOVER FOR THE
NEXT YOU KNOW DECADE PLUS. ON
THE MAY REVISION REFLECTS A TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION INCREASE AND
FEDERAL ID A- FUNDING AND A
FOUR. POINT ZERO FIVE COLA. FOR
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION GENERAL FUND
WHICH IS AN IMPROVEMENT OVER
THE ONE POINT FIVE COLA
PROPOSED IN JANUARY. HOWEVER IT
WAS JUST LAST YEAR THAT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED A THREE PHASE
A MULTI YEAR PROCESS. TO
IMPROVE SPECIAL EDUCATION
FINANCE SERVICES AND STUDENT
OUTCOMES. THIS YEAR'S PROPOSAL
SEEMS LIKE A MINIMAL INVESTMENT
AND DOESN'T MOVE THAT EFFORT
FORWARD. THE MAY REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES MORE THAN A TWENTY
MILLION IN STATE OPERATIONS
SUPPORT. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
PRIMARILY FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- OF FIFTEEN MILLION
DISPUTE RESOLUTION THREE POINT
THREE MILLION AND SIX NEW
POSITIONS WERE COMPLIANT
CASELOAD AND MONITORING NEARLY
A MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT.
THESE PROPOSALS SUGGEST AN
EMPHASIS ON IEP COMPLIANCE AND
MEETING THE LETTER OF THE LAW
RATHER THAN FOCUSING ON
MAXIMISING RESOURCES. TO SERVE
STUDENTS SO MY QUESTION IS
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS WERE
STRUGGLING BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC
AND THE SCHOOL CLOSURES HAVE
HAD A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
ON ASK AT RISK STUDENTS. WHY
DOESN'T THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDE A BIGGER AND TARGETED
INVESTMENT DESERVES SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS AND WHY ARE
WE LOOKING AT EVEN POSSIBLY
INCREASING INCREASING THAT THAT
THE BASED ON FOR SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS. ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTIONS- I REITERATE
THE INVESTMENT THAT YOU PARTY
OUTLINED- THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISION AND WE DO
CONTINUE TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
MAY REVISION- PROVIDES A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE FOR AND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES NOT
ONLY AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
SPECIFIC INVESTMENTS WITH YOU
HIGHLIGHTED. BUT ALSO AND I'M
AND I'M A NUMBER OF OTHER
INVESTMENTS- THAT HAVE BEEN
GOING OUT BOTH STATE BOTH STATE
AND FEDERAL INVESTMENTS- AROUND
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION- AND
TARGETED INTERVENTION GRANTS
WHICH ARE IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- AND ALSO SPECIFICALLY
CALL OUT AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AS ONE OF THE-
GROUPS TO PRIORITIZE FUNDING
FOR. I'M IN IN IN RESPONSE TO
THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE- THAT
MULTI YEAR PLAN THAT WAS LAID
OUT LAST YEAR WE WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT- AS PART OF THAT PLAN
LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR AND THE
GOVERNOR IN THE BUDGET DID IT
DIDN'T BEST AND SEVERAL WORK
pPROCESS AROUND AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING REFORM IN
PROGRAMMATIC REFORM THAT IS
NEEDED AND THOSE WORKERS ARE
CURRENTLY ONGOING SEVERAL OF
THOSE WORKERS HAVE REPORTS THAT
BE. USED TO THE LEGISLATURE
INTO. OCTOBER OF NEXT YEAR AND
WE DO INTEND TO- WORKING TO
REVIEW THOSE FINDINGS IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO COLLABORATE IN
TERMS OF REFORMS THAT ARE
NEEDED GOING FORWARD- WE'RE
VERY MINDFUL AND INTENTIONAL-
AROUND NOT GETTING OUT- IN
FRONT OF THOSE EFFORTS AND
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
OUR PARTNERS ON FUNDING REFORMS
THAT ARE NEEDED- WITH REGARDS
TO THE OUT OF HOME CARE
FUNDING- I BELIEVE THERE. THERE
WAS ATTENTION CALL TO THE FACT
THAT WE ARE AND I'M FREEZING
THAT FUNDING FOR AN ADDITIONAL
WEEK THERE THAT'S ALSO IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
THE ONLY- RECENTLY CONVENED IN
OUT OF HOME CARE FUNDING WORK
GROUP- AND- PRIOR TO THE
RELEASE OF THE MAYOR VISION
THERE WAS NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR
FINANCE AND OF THE LEGISLATURE.
IN THE L. A. O. TO GET TOGETHER
TO CAN TO- DECIDE ON WHAT THE
BEST BEST PATH FOR. WAS COMING
OUT OF THAT WORK FOR. AND AGAIN
WE WANT TO GET OUT IN FRONT OF
THAT. RECOGNIZING THAT THERE
HAS A GREAT DEAL CLASS. AROUND
ACTUALLY OR- ACT THIS POINT.
AND ONE YOU TO. WE WOULD. AN
UPDATE ON THE EUROPE EFFORT.
AGAIN I THINK THE REPORTS FROM
THE WORK THAT ARE COMING OUT IN
OCTOBER OF THIS NEXT YEAR WILL
GUIDE A LOT OF FACT EFFORT- WE
DO ANTICIPATE THAT THE THAT THE
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET AND BECAUSE
WE WILL HAVE THOSE REPORTS AND-
BE FORMED LARGELY BY THOSE
WORKERS CONVERSATION THAT HAVE
BEEN OCCURRING. GREAT YOU. YEAH
YEAH MORE OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MEMBER TEAM. THANK YOU FOR
OUR FIRST LET ME JUST- THANK
ARCHIE FOR ALL HIS. ON THE
LEADERSHIP ON THE T. K. ISSUE I
THINK THIS IS A- GREAT- AND
HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY TO.
FINALLY ARE CORRECT I THINK
WHAT'S BEEN A FAIRLY LARGE AND
JUSTICE 275% OF OUR CHILDREN IN
THE STATE THAT. WE HAVE 25% OF
OUR CHILDREN ARE GETTING AN
EXTRA YEAR OF EDUCATION 75% NOT
GETTING AND I THINK THIS IS A-
HUGE STEP IN REALLY CORRECTING
THAT AND I. JUST WANT TO
COMMEND OUR OUR CHAIR FOR ALL
OF HIS HIS GREAT LEADERSHIP ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AS WELL
AS- I THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
PUTTING IT IN HIS. MAY REVISE I
DID WANT TO GO BACK TO SOME
LIGHT ON COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS-
FROM LONG BEACH- PERHAPS MISS
HOME COULD COME BACK ON. AND WE
COULD TALK ABOUT THE REAL
OPENING DOLLARS I MEAN IF AB
EIGHTY SIX- GOT SCHOOLS- FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TO HELP THEM RE
OPEN AS AN INCENTIVE- TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS INCLUDING-
FEDERAL AID- TO HELP WITH.
LEARNING RECOVERY- IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT ON TOP OF THAT
POTENTIAL SIXTEEN. BILLION
DOLLARS PLUS ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
RESOURCES ARE COMING OUT WHY
THEY WOULD NEED SOME MORE
MONEY- TO BE OPEN ESPECIALLY
WHEN OUR COVERT RATES ARE- AT
AS LOW A RATE AS A WORST MARCH
OF LAST OF LAST YEAR- THE CDC-
HOUSE HAS GONE TO A THREE FOOT
INSTEAD OF A SIX FOOT DISTANCE
AND- I ANTICIPATE BY THE FALL
YOU KNOW KNOCK ON WOOD. THAT WE
WILL BE PRETTY CLOSE TO NORMAL
SO JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT. WHAT YOUR HEARING FROM
DISTRICTS THAT THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY. NEED TO SPEND THIS
MONEY ON. CERTAINLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM AND DISCOMS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO JUST
IN TERMS OF ALL CANCER BOTH
THOSE QUESTIONS- IN TWO PARTS
THE FIRST PART IS REGARDING THE
FUNDING THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED TO
ELEAZAR. WHO HAS BEEN PROVIDED
TO WOULD HAVE BEEN PROVIDED FOR
SO AS YOU AS YOU WELL KNOW AB
EIGHTY SIX- PROVIDED SIX POINT
SIX BILLION OF WHICH TWO
BILLION WAS AVAILABLE FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION GRANTS TO
HELP ADDRESS HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND NEED THE VALLEY IT'S AN
OPENING. OR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN THE CURRENT YEAR
THE FUNDS WERE ALSO AVAILABLE
TO THE EXTENT THAT ANYWHERE
REMAINING ON IN THE BUDGET
YEARS FILED. AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
POINT SIX BILLION WAS ON
PROPOSED FOR EXPANDING AN
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME. AS WELL AS
PROVIDING ACADEMIC
INTERVENTIONS SO IN TERMS OF
THE TWO BILLION. THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IN THIS BUDGET-
THAT'S IT'S A LITTLE MORE CLOSE
ALIGN WITH THE- BILLION CORRECT
THAT WAS BY. THROUGH AB EIGHTY
SIX AS OPPOSED TO THE FOUR
POINT SIX BILLION THAT WAS
PROVIDED FOR EXPANDING LEARNING
TIME. ON ACADEMIC
INTERVENTIONS. SO THAT FUNDING
THE TWO BILLION AB EIGHTY SIX
AGAIN WAS AVAILABLE FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR- AND THEN AGAIN AT
CAN CARRY OVER INTO THE BUDGET
YEAR AS WELL. AND THAT WAS
REALLY INTENDED TO HELP COVER
THE COSTS OF OPENING IN THE
CURRENT YAR- GIVEN THAT THE
YOU KNOW I'VE AS YOU RECALL YOU
KNOW PRIOR TO YOU WHERE WE ARE
NOW. AND THAT THE MUCH MORE
STRICT REQUIREMENTS ON THINGS
LIKE TESTING- AND CLEANING
STANDARDS AND SOCIAL DISTANCING-
THIS TO BUILD. ISRAELI FOLK ON
THE BUDGET YEAR. AND IN TERMS
OF. AND PROVIDING RESOURCES TO
ALL LEDS SO- YOU ALSO REFERRED
TO THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
HAVE GONE OUT ON A FEDERAL
FUNDS AND THOSE ARE REALLY
GOING FOCUSED ON TITLE ONE.
DOESN'T ALLOCATED BASED ON
TITLE ONE ENROLLMENT- SO THAT
THE MAJORITY OF FUNDS HAVE GONE
TO CERTAIN ALLEYS AND NOT
OTHERS- AND THE TWO BILLION
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING WOULD BE
SPREAD OUT MORE. EVENLY ACROSS
THE STATE FOR ALL LEDS-
ADDITION- IN TERMS OF THE NEED
FOR THESE FUNDS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR- WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE GOING TO BE- THEY'RE
GONNA BE REQUIREMENTS RUN
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND SIMPLY
GIVEN THE FACT THAT FOR MANY
CHILDREN. ON THERE'S NOT
CURRENTLY A VACCINE AVAILABLE-
AND WE KNOW THAT THAT THIS WILL
CREATE SOME CONCERN AMONG MANY
PARENTS ON WHETHER OR NOT TO
SEND THEIR CHILDREN BACK FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. WE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT SCHOOLS HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BE
PROVIDING- THE KINDS OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY- PROTOCOLS AND THAT
HELP PARENTS FEEL COMFORTABLE
SENDING THEIR KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL. IN ADDITION- THERE IS A
LIKELIHOOD THAT THERE WILL BE A
VACCINE- FOR YOUNGER CHILDREN
AS WE MOVE THROUGH YOU KNOW HE
COMING YEAR AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT ELEAZAR WANT TO FIND-
TAXATION CLINICS OR AND
CONTINUE TO DO TESTING UP UP UP
UP UNTIL THAT POINT. ON THE
SONS OF THE ALLOWABLE THE BIT
THAT WOULD BE ALLOWABLE USE FOR
THESE FUNDS AS WELL SO THEY'RE
INTENDED TO BUILD UPON THE
FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED THEIR INTENDED TO
COVER THE NEEDS OF THE BUDGET
YEAR AND THEY'RE INTENDED TO BE
PROVIDED TO A BROADER. SWATH.
OF ALLEYS ACROSS THE STATE. DO
YOU HAVE FROM REGARD THE TO
MORE THAT WAS A PER. BUT THEY
BE AT LEAST DO YOU- KNOW HOW.
OF A HAS BEEN. AND ON WHAT. SO
THOSE FUNDS COULD BE USED TO
COVER COSTS THE LEDS INCURRED-
PRIOR TO THIS WE CAN AS LONG AS
HOLDEN I'M NOT ASKING WHAT THE
ALLOWABLE USES FOR NOT NOT FOR
THE TWO BILLION IN YOUR MAYBE
VICE PULLS OF THE TWO BILLION
THAT WE ALREADY APPROPRIATED
THREE B. EIGHTY SIX. YOU KNOW
HOW MUCH OF THAT HAS BEEN.
SPENT AND ON WHAT. SO THE FIRST
ALLOCATION OF THOSE FUNDS WAS-
I BELIEVE IT HAS JUST BEEN MADE
THE FIRST ALLOCATION WITH
INTENDED TO GO OUT IN MAY. OF
THIS YEAR AND THE WITH THE
FOLLOW UP TO GO OUT IN AUGUST
BECAUSE THAT WAS DEPENDENT UPON
SCHOOLS RE OPENING FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. SO WE DON'T
HAVE DATA YET ON WHAT THOSE
EXPENDITURES WERE. HOWEVER WE
DID PROVIDE ELEAZAR WITH THEIR-
TOTAL GRANT AWARD AMOUNT. AND
DID TELL THEM THAT THEY COULD
USE THOSE FUNDS. TO REIMBURSE
THEMSELVES FOR COSTS INCURRED
PRIOR TO THE RECEIPT OF THOSE
PLANS. SO WE WILL KNOW- AFTER
THAT THOSE FUNDS WILL GO OUT
HOW THEY WERE EXPENDED BUT IT
MAY BE THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
IDENTIFIED- INTACT. FOR
EXPENDITURES THAT HAVE ALREADY
HAPPENED. GOT IT WILL ALSO.
HOME WHAT WHAT WE DIDN'T
DISCUSS WITH THE FIVE BILLION
THAT WAS ALREADY APPROPRIATED
PREVIOUSLY. IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
USED FOR RE OPENING- THE
MAJORITY OF IT WAS USED FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING SO THAT.
ELLIE IS HAD THAT CHOICE FOR
THE FIVE BILLION. TO SPEND IT
AND I WAS THE LEGISLATURE THAT
WITHOUR INSTRUCTION THE
GOVERNOR'S DESTRUCTION
LEGISLATURE DESTRUCTION TO.
SPEND IT ON- THE OPENING TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE BUT-
SOMETHING THAT THEY DIDN'T DO
VERY WELL SO I GUESS- FOR ME I
WOULD AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM PALM BEACH OF THE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IS GOING OUT
AND MAY. END IN AUGUST AND WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW. IF THEY HAVE
SPENT IT OR EVEN NEEDED IT
SEEMS- PREMATURE. TO DO ANOTHER
TWO BILLION ON TOP OF THAT.
WHEN IT'S NOT EVEN CLEAR THAT
THEY EVEN NEED THE TWO BILLION
ESPECIALLY. WILL BE GIVEN THE
FIVE BILLION FOR RE OPENING
WHICH WE HAD HOPED WOULD BE
USED FOR MASS AND PLEXIGLASS
AND SPACING- ONLY 10% OF IT WAS
USED FOR THOSE TYPES OF ITEMS
AND SO I THINK. THAT- TO ME THE
TWO BILLION COULD BETTER BETTER
USED ELSEWHERE. I WANTED TO GO
INTO. ON JUST JUST OF WHAT WHAT
ALSO JUST GOING TO INDEPENDENT
STUDY AS WELL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
QUESTION IS THERE A REASON WHY
WE DON'T WANT THE GUY- THE
ADMINISTRATION DID NOT PROPOSE
A CAP ON. THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS USING INDEPENDENT
STUDY. YES SO- WE DIDN'T
PROPOSED A CAP UNDERSTANDING
THAT IN SYDNEY TO THE EXTENT
THE PARENTS FROM WOULD LIKE THE
CHOICE TO HAVE THEIR CHILDREN
BE IN DISTANCE LEARNING AGAIN
NEXT YEAR. THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
THE OPTION NOT BE LIMITED AND
BYE BYE A NUMBER AN ARBITRARY
PERSON AT THE STATELEVEL. SO
IF A SCHOOL WANTED TO ENROLL
90% OF ITS STUDENTS AND
INDEPENDENT SAY THAT WOULD BE
OKAY. W. ALLOWABLE I'M EIGHT I
WANNA- JUST. MAKE SURE I'M
UNDERSTANDING YOUR QUESTION
CLEARLY SO- THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A PARENT
CHOICE AND A SCHOOL I HAVE. A
REFER THAT QUESTION SO IF 90%
OF PARENTS IN A PARTICULAR
SCHOOL WANTED TO ENROLL IN
DISTANCE LEARNING THEIR WOULD
BE ALLOWED TO AN END
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. THAT'S
CORRECT AND BACK END THE
ADMINISTRATION BE OKAY WITHOUT.
YES WE ARE SUPPORTIVE PARENT
CHOICE AND IN TERMS OF THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEAR AND WHETHER OR NOT PARENTS
FEEL COMFORTABLE BRINGING THEIR
KIDS BACK TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION THIS IS A CELL I AM
NOW I WOULD JUST SAY THAT I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE ON-
PRETTY CATASTROPHIC MISTAKE-
THAT. KNOWING HOW MUCH LEARNING
LOSS WE'VE HAD THIS YEAR-
KNOWING THAT AT THIS POINT
THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT. NEEDING
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS. FOR THIS
INDEPENDENT STUDY- WITHOUT
FURTHER TIGHTENING THIS I THINK
IT WOULD BE ON. IT WOULD NOT BE
VERY GOOD POLICY GIVEN WHAT WE
HAVE WITNESSED AYE I KNOW THAT
THIS TIME LAST YEAR WE DEBATED
DISTANCE LEARNING AND I THINK
GIVEN WHAT WE KNEW LAST YEAR TO
GET WILL BE NEW LAST YEAR AS WE
WERE IN. IN A MONTH TO OF THE
PANDEMIC THAT WE ACTUALLY KNOW
VERY LITTLE ABOUT AND WE HAD
HOPED THAT GIVING FROM
DISTRICTS THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DISTANCE LEARN BUT ALSO TO
BRING THE CHILDREN BACK WOULD
WOULD WORK. CLEARLY IT DID NOT
I DISTRICTS- DEMONSTRATED A
VERY- INABILITY TO SHUT DOWN
BUT THEY DID NOT DEMONSTRATE
ANY ALMOST NO ABILITY. TO OVER
80% OF CHILDREN REMAIN NOT
FULLY BACK IN SCHOOL EVEN AT A
TIME WHEN A COVERT RATES AGAIN
R. AS LAW WAS WHEN WE SHUT DOWN
IN MARCH. ALSO IN TERMS OF
INDEPENDENT STUDY I THINK IT'S
VERY CONCERNING THAT THERE IS
NOT DALY AND ASYNCHRONOUS
LEARNING WITH A CREDENTIAL
TEACHER I THINK THAT- NOT
HAVING- ANY PARTICULAR LANGUAGE
ASTO- WHAT WILL HAPPEN-HILL
CAN THAT PARTICULAR SETTING I
THINK- WE DON'T DEFINE THAT IN
GREATER DETAIL I THINK WE WILL
DEFINITELY. LIVE TO REGRET THIS
NEXT YEAR HEN WE'RE HAVING
THIS HEARING GOING INTO NEXT
YEAR'S ME REVISED. I'M JUST IN
ADDITION I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT- WE HAD HOPED-
THAT DISTRICTS WOULD FOLLOW OUR
INSTRUCTION TO HAVE IN PERSON
LEARNING TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE- ALMOST EVERY DISTRICT
DEMONSTRATED AN ABILITY TO DO
THAT I THINK- MY OWN. DISTRICT
HAS BECOME THE POSTER CHILD OF
HOW NOT TO DO THIS. ON AND I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE A TRIGGER ON HOW TO RE
OPEN IF IN FACT WE DO HAVE SOME
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE AN
OUTBREAK. OF BECAUSE IT SEEMS
THAT IF THERE IS AN OUTBREAK
DISTRICTS WILL PROBABLY THE BE
ALLOWED TO SHUT DOWN A WILL
NEED TO SHUT DOWN. BUT I THINK
WE NEED TO. FIGURE OUT WHAT
TYPE O TRIGGER WILL BRING THEM
BACK HI I FEAR THAT ONCE
DISTRICTS ARE SHUT DOWN BECAUSE
OF AN OUTBREAK THAT THEY WILL
NOT COME BACK AND I THINK THAT
IS A VERY. SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS- JUST I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO HEAR A COMMENT. ABOUT
HAVING A TRIP. OR WHAT- WHAT DO
YOU THINK WE CAN DO TO BRING
DISTRICTS BACK SHOULD THERE BE.
AN OUTBREAK OF ONCE THEY OPEN
UP OPEN BACK UP IN THE FALL.
CERTAINLY AND JUST TO PROVIDE
SOME CLARIFYING AND CONTEXT TO
YOUR INITIAL REMARKS- WE ARE
NOT PROPOSING TO OFFER LEAST
THE OPTION. OF EITHER AN IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION OR DISTANCE
LEARNING. WE ARE PROPOSING THAT
IN THE FALL I LIAISE WILL BE
REQUIRED AS A DEFAULT TO
PROVIDE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
FULL TIME TO EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT- WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING
IS SIMPLY THAT WE ALLOW THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY MODEL- THAT
EXISTED BEFORE KOBE TO CONTINUE
TO EXIST. POST CODE ED BUT WITH
IMPROVEMENTS AROUND QUALITY AND
WE ARE NOT SUGGESTING THAT I'M
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS BE ABLE
O TEACH THESE PROGRAMS-
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO HAVE
CREDENTIALS IN ORDER TO TEACH
AN INDEPENDENT STUDY- AND WE
ARE REQUIRING OUR LANGUAGE THAT
JUST WAS RELEASED THIS MORNING
DOES REQUIRE. I'M DAILY
INTERACTION AND AT LEAST ONE
DAY A WEEK OF SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION BETWEEN ON TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS- INDEPENDENT STUDY
SO JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE THAT
CONTACTS. INSURANCE AS THE
QUESTION THAT YOU HAD AROUND
PROVIDING A TRIGGER. FOR VALUES
THAT MAY EXPERIENCE OUTBREAKS
AND HAVING. A PLAN IN PLACE FOR
THEM TO COME BACK WE'RE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF SHOULD
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THAT
CONCEPT. I'M INTO CONSIDERATION
AS WE MOVE. TOWARDS THE CLOSING
OUT THE BUDGET. THANK I BELIEVE
THAT. I THINK THE- ARE COMMENTS
REGARDING RE OPENING IN THE
PAUL HAVE BEEN CRYSTAL CLEAR
AND I REALLY DO COMMEND HIM. ON
HIS ADVOCACY HIS VERY VERY
CLEAR LANGUAGE AND I APPRECIATE
YOU FOR REITERATING THAT SO- I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT I MYSELF
COMPLETELY AGREE- THAT. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND FOR ALL THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LISTENING AND
FOR ALL THE ASSOCIATIONS
LISTING I THINK EVERY DISTRICT
NEEDS TO BE PREPARED TO RETURN
TO NORMAL. IN THE FALL BE BACK
AT SCHOOL FIVE DAYS A WEEK IN
PERSON I THINK WHAT'S VERY
CRITICAL IS I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
AFTER SCHOOL BECAUSE I BECAUSE-
THERE'S BEEN TALK ABOUT
FAMILIES NOT GOING BACK I THINK
A NUMBER OF FAMILIES. ARE GOING
BACK BECAUSE THERE'S NO AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM RIGHT NOW. YOU
CAN'T. IF YOU KNOW IF YOUR
WORKING FAMILY YOU CAN'T PICK
UP YOUR CHILD AT ONE THIRTY
UNLESS YOU HAVE EXTENDED FAMILY
OR SOME OTHER. CARE GIVING
OPTIONS SO HAVING. SCHOOL OPEN
IN THE FALL IS NOT ENOUGH IT'S
HAVING SCHOOL AND- BEFORE AND
AFTER SCHOOL OPEN UP WITH THAT
SO WE GO BACK TO THAT MODEL. IS
ACTUALLY CRITICAL I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT INVESTMENT IN
THAT PROGRAM IN THIS BUDGET I
DO REALLY WANT TO SAY THAT. I'M
LET ME JUST LEAVE IT
INDEPENDENT STUDY I UNDERSTAND.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS HOMES ARE
I WORRY THAT INDEPENDENT STUDY
WILL BE ABUSED THE WAY DISTANCE
LEARNING HAS BEEN ABUSED. AND
IF WE DON'T CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE
WE WILL REGRET. SELL I
UNDERSTAND WE NEED TO PASS A
BUDGET ON JUNE FIFTEENTH WITH
NOT WHICH NOT ONLY ARE REFLECTS
THIS ERA OF WHAT THE GOVERNOR
SAYING. BUT THAT THE LETTER OF
THE LAW REFLECTS BUT THE
GOVERNOR HE SAID. AND IF WE
REALLY WANT CHILDREN TO BE BACK
IN SCHOOL. IN THE FALL THAT
INDEPENDENT STUDY LOOPHOLE
HOUSE TO BE CLOSED. IT HAS TO
BE CLOSED IN A WAY TO MAKE A
LEGITIMATE HAS TO BE CLOSED IN
A WAY THAT WE ARE FULLY
CONFIDENT THAT EVERY STUDENT
WHO IS PURSUING THAT PATH IS
GOING TO GET AS GOOD AN
EDUCATION AS THOSE WHO ARE IN
THE CLASSROOM. SO I THINK THAT
IS WHAT WE SHOULD BE STRIVING
FOR AND I THINK THAT- WE VERY
MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO ACHIEVE- NOT JUST A
GOAL IN SPIRIT. BUT THEIR GOAL
IN LIFE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU. SOME OF OUR BY THAT S. AND
TWO QUICK ONE QUICK COMMENTS
AND THEN- ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION- I WOULD AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT THE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WHAT I'M
HEARING FROM MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AS THEY HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY AND- THEY HAD ONE OF MY
SUPERINTENDENCIA WE ACTUALLY
DON'T NEED MORE MONEY I'M BUT
WHAT THEY NEED IS FLEXIBILITY
IN ORDER TO SPEND AND MOVE
AROUND CURRENT DOLLARS THAT
THEY DO HAVE SO I THINK WE
SHOULD REALLY BE CONSIDERING.
AN OLD EIGHT GIVING THEM NOT
FLEXIBILITY AND IS IT AN AND
JULIE IF WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
THEM AN ADDITIONAL TWO BILLION
DOLLARS MAKE SURE THAT THAT
MONEY CAN BE SPENT FLEXIBILITY
FLEXIBILITY BECAUSE THEY HAVE
P. TO DISTRICT IS DIFFERENT
EACH COMMUNITY HAS ITS OWN
NEEDS THAT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
ALLOW THEM TO DETERMINE WHERE
THESE FUNDS GO THAT ARE GONNA
BE MOST BENEFICIAL TO STUDENTS
ON. SECOND VACATION AMBLE FOR
OF ALL I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT. AND T. K. I KNOW OUR
CHAMPION HERE OUR CHAIRMAN
MCCARTY- HAS BEEN- REALLY AN
ADVOCATE FOR EXPANDING T. K.
FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS AND-
HAPPY TO BE AN AUTHOR ON ON THE
BILL- THAT IS NOW. IN THE
SENATE THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
THROUGH- ON ONE OF MY CONCERNS-
IS WORK WITH THIS DECREASE IN
ENROLLMENT THAT WE'VE SEEN AND
T. K. AND KINDERGARTEN BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC. SO I JUST
WANTED CLARIFICATION. ON WHEN.
BECAUSE WE ARE BECAUSE THE-
DEPARTMENT MINISTRATION. IT THE
IS PROPOSES TO REPURPOSE THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN
JANUARY BUDGET- UTK INCENTIVE
FUNDING TO AN ALLOCATION TO ALL
ELEAZAR BASED ON KINDERGARTEN
ENROLLMENT WHAT YEAR
KINDERGARTEN OPEN ROMAN ARE WE
USING I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT OUR OUR NUMBERS ARE GOING
TO BE OFF- I AM SO UPSET
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE START. ON THIS NEW
PHASE STRONG SO AND IS ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AND TALK
TO THAT. A LITTLE BIT.
CERTAINLY I WE ARE PROPOSING
THAT AN ALLOCATION OF FUNDS.
THAT THE KINDERGARTEN
ENROLLMENT NUMBERS FROM
NINETEEN TWENTY ARGUES-
UNDERSTANDING THAT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE HAD QUITE AND
PRODUCTION AND THE NUMBER OF
KINDERGARTEN STUDENTS. ON
EDUCATE STUDENTS ATTENDING
SCHOOL- AND SO KNOWING THAT
THOSE NUMBERS MAY NOT BE
INDICATIVE OF THAT HAVE BEEN
NORMAL HERE. AND WE ARE
PROPOSING TO USE THE. NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE- EIGHTY EIGHT.
GREAT AND WHAT'S- I AM GETTING
YOU KNOW SOME QUESTIONS FROM
SOME CONCERNED PROVIDERS- THAT
CURRENTLY PROVIDE A PRESCHOOL
FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS- BECAUSE WE
HAVE WE DO HAVE A MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM. THAT RELIES ON PRIVATE
NONPROFIT- WHAT. ONE OF MY
CONCERNS IS THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT LEAVING THEM OUT
AND I UNDERSTAND THIS IS PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING- BUT I
WANT TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT
THIS ROLLOUT GOES AS SMOOTHLY
AS POSSIBLE. AND NOT OUR
PROVIDERS KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT
LEAVING THEM BEHIND BOND THAT
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL SEE
AND- AND EXPANSION AND WE KNOW
WITH A HUNDRED THOUSAND- SLOTS-
PROPOSED ON THAT MORE THREE
YEAR OLDS WILL WILL BE SERVED-
EIGHT. I'M AB I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYONE CAN SPEAK TO THE ON THE
PANEL- COOPER PERFECT FOR MIXED
DELIVERY PROVIDERS. CERTAINLY
SO WE DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS CONCERN IN THE
EARLY EDUCATION COMMUNITY
AROUND THE MOVEMENT THE
POTENTIAL MOVEMENT OF A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER FOUR YEAR
OLDS AND TO THE T. CASE SYSTEM-
WE RECOGNIZE THAT. SYDNEY AND
PARENTS STILL SHOULD HAVE A
CHOICE AND SO WE ARE NOT
PROPOSING TO DISALLOW FOUR YEAR
OLDS FROM PARTICIPATING- IN A
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IF THAT'S
THEIR PARENTS CHOICE- BUT WE
ARE ALSO LOOKING AT WAYS AND WE
ANTICIPATE HAVING A PROPOSAL
THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET ACT TO THIS EFFECT. WE
ANTICIPATE TAKING THE FUNDS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY ALLOCATE
DISTINCT PRESCHOOL AND THINKING
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM AGAIN TO
MAKE IT MORE APPROPRIATE TO
SERVE YOUNGER CHILDREN-
RECOGNIZING THAT WILL NEED TO
DO SOME THINKING AROUND THE
RATES- GIVEN THAT RATIOS CAN
BE- MORE RESTRICTIVE FOR
SERVING INTERNATIONAL TREND.
BUT ALSO UNDERSTAND IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THREE YEAR OLDS
TO ALSO HAVE. ADDITIONAL YEAR
OF. EDUCATION AND PLAY BASED NO
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE AND
ACCESS TO LOOK AT CARE- PRIOR
TO ENTERING TKA AS IT IS FOR
FOUR YEAR OLDS TO HAVE A YEAR
AS OF CARE QUALITY INSTRUCTION
PRIOR TO ENTERING KINDERGARTEN
SO THAT IS THE IDEAS THAT. ARE
MOVING FORWARD WILL WILL
RETHINK THE FUNDING AND THE
PROGRAMS FOR STATE PRESCHOOL TO
HELP THOSE PROVIDERS- SERVE
YOUNGER CHILDREN INTERCEDING ON
REIMBURSEMENT. APPROPRIATE TO
THAT SERVICE. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU AYE AYE I WANNA TALK
ABOUT THEM I KNOW THIS AGENDA
ITEM IS ALL ENCOMPASSING WE
COULD HAVE HAD FIFTY CHEN ITEMS
BUT IT'S THAT'S JUST A PROP
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE SO I DO
HAVE SOME- ISSUES AND QUESTIONS
ON ON SCHOOLS AND T. K. BUT ALL
THE ALL THE START RIGHT WHERE
YOU LEFT OFF ON T. K. THIS IS A
BIG TOPIC WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM THE PUBLIC IN A LITTLE
BIT- CERTAINLY I'M NOT
SURPRISED THAT HE WOULD PUT
HERE THAT I'M ALL IN ON THIS
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS BURKE. FOR MANY YEARS HAS
BEEN- COUNTLESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND SENATORS AND TRIED
TO MAKE UNIVERSAL PRE K.
REALITY IN CALIFORNIA AND I
HAVE A LIST OF THEM SO MAKE
SURE WE RECOGNIZE THEM BECAUSE
SO MANY PEOPLE WORKED ON THIS
OVER THE YEARS- BUT I GUESS THE
BIG PICTURE I WANT TO SAY IS
THAT AND IN ADDITION TO BEING
ALL IN ON THIS A MAKING A
REALITY THAT I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT CHANGE IS HARD. AND THAT
SOMETIMES- AB SAYING THE ORDER
OF THINGS YEAH- CHANGERS A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTY ON THAT ON THE
POSITIVENESS OF THE IT AND FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT FOR THE
CHANGE RIGHT AWAY THERE IS 100%
CERTAINTY THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
DETRIMENTAL AND SO WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN- WE WANTED
TO FOCUS ON MAKING SURE THAT NO
ONE IS LEFT BEHIND NOT ONLY
KIDS AND FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIANS BUT PROVIDERS AND
WE TRULY THINK AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES SAID AT
HALF HOUR AGO THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY. FOR A WIN WIN WIN
WITH OUR EXISTING- MIXED
DELIVERY SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
AND JUST WHAT THE- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST
NOTED THAT NOT PART OF THIS
BUDGET NOT PARDEE EXPANSION%
SLOTS THAT A NO NO NO WE'RE
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
THEIR PROVIDERS OUT THERE
WHETHER THEY'RE CBO'S OR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OR WHAT HAVE YOU
FAMILY FAMILY- CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. THAT CURRENTLY SERVE
FOUR YEAR OLDS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNISTS ARE MORE ZERO
THREE THREE YEAR OLDS- WE
EITHER A MASSIVE. WAITING LISTS
WE HISTORICALLY THERE HAVEN'T
BEEN UP LOTS. FOR INFANTS
TODDLERS AND I HE- SOME
PROVIDERS SAY WELL THE MATH
DOESN'T. WORK DOESN'T PENCIL
OUT WELL I'M HERE TO STATE THAT
WITH MY- INSULTS MY IPAD PENCIL
RIGHT HERE BUT- WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE IT PENCIL OUT WHO WORK
WITH US IN THIS BUDGET. IN AB
TWENTY TWO. IN SB FIFTY CENT
EARLY AMOUNTS BILL AND AS
FINANCE SAID IN THE NEXT YEAR
TO MAKE SURE IT PENCILS OUT
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE
TRANSFORMATIONAL HERE TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL THE PROVIDERS OUT
THERE ARE WHOLE. NO ONE LOSES
THEIR JOB NO ONE LOSES THEIR
BUSINESS FRANKLY WE'RE GONNA
NEED MORE ECG WORKERS. WITH THE
EXPANSION NOT LAST SO I DON'T
SEE THAT HAPPENING. BUT EVEN
MORE MORE A TRANSFORMATIONAL
THE FACT THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
SEE SERVE MARKETS. IF YOU'RE A
LOWER LOW INCOME FAMILY AND-
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA RURAL
CALIFORNIA SOME URBAN AREAS.
ANOMALY BUT HAD A UNIVERSAL FOR
FOUR YEAR OLD ACCESS BUT THREE
YEAR OLD ACCESS YOU JUST THINK
ABOUT. WHAT A DIFFERENCE IT'LL
MAKE FOR KINDERGARTEN READINESS
AS THE GOVERNOR SPOKE LAST WEEK
IN THE MAY REVISE ITS NOT. AN
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IT'S REALLY THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP AND SO IF SO
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES LIVE TWO
YEARS OF HIGH QUALITY YOU SEE
BEFORE THEY ENTER KINDERGARTEN-
THAT WILLIE WILL BE
TRANSFORMATIONAL AND- WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE DO NEED TO
FOCUS ON. THE NEEDS OF FAMILIES
THAT'S WHY WE'RE COMMITTED TO
THE EXTENDING AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS EXTENDING RAP.
PROGRAMS AT TEEKAY SITES- IF
FAMILIES WANTED TO HAVE THE-
THE HALF DAY PROGRAM- IN AND WE
ARE SAYING THAT T. K. AND K. WE
DON'T WANT PART DATE WE WANT
FULL DAY. K. PROGRAM SO WE'RE
GONNA MAKE SURE WE HAVE THAT AS
WELL- WE'RE ALSO GOING TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE APPROPRIATE-
QUALITY ELEMENTS TO MAKE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT. HAVING ONE
ADULTS HAND TWENTY SOMETHING
KIDS THIS IS A DISASTER FOR
EVERYBODY SO- THE GOVERNOR
HASN'T. PLAN EVEN MORE
AGGRESSIVE THE NEST. HAVING ONE
ADULT FOR IT FOR TEN KIDS IN
THE T. K. AND CAN OUR
CLASSROOMS OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS SO. WE REALLY ARE MINDFUL
OF THIS- OF WHAT'S NEEDED TO
MAKE THIS WORK. AS WELL THIS IS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN OVERNIGHT
SO WE HAVE MULTIPLE YEARS TO
PHASES SENT TO WORK ON THE WORK
FORCE WORKING FACILITIES. BUT
ALSO ALLOW OUR PROVIDERS AND
CENTERS OUT THERE. TO WORK WITH
US AND THEN I LAST THE AS I
SAID IN THE LAST PANEL. NONE OF
THIS WORKS UNLESS WE HAVE
ADEQUATE- REIMBURSEMENT RATES
IN A FEE STRUCTURE. TO PAY
THESE PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE
THAT CANCEL OUT SO- WERE 100%
COMMITTED TO THAT- DID JUST
AGAIN YOU KNOW- WE'RE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH OUR
PROVIDERS AND CHILD CARE FIELD
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS CAN CAN BE
A WIN WIN WIN FOR ALL OF US.
AND SO- WITH THAT- I THINK
THAT'S ANOTHER STATE ON ON THAT
ISSUE I WILL SAY ON THE OVERALL
PROBABLY INDIAN SCHOOL AT 100%
CONCUR WITH BUT- OUR EDUCATION
CHAIR MISTER O'DONNELL. TALKED
ABOUT AS WELL AS OUR BUDGET
SHARES RETAIN. OUR SCHOOLS ARE
RETURNING THIS THIS FALL NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT QUIT ASKING
ABOUT IF AND WHAT AND WHEN PER
COMING BACK. UNLESS THERE'S
SOME NEW VARIANTS ARE CRAZY
SOMETHING HAPPENS DIFFERENT AND
THEN WE'LL WE'LL WE'LL ADAPT
ADAPT TO THAT- I DO THINK THAT
WE SHOULD. TIGHTEN UP THESE
INDEPENDENT STUDY IN A VIRTUAL
ACADEMY TYPE THINGS BUT THEY'RE
HAPPENING ANYWAY THESE ARE OF
THIS IS BIG ARTICLE IN OUR
LOCAL NEWSPAPER HERE TWO WEEKS
AGO. BUT THESE ARE HAPPENING
BEFORE. THE PANDEMICS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN DO THESE ANYWAY
SO I DON'T SEE THERE AND THE
NEED. TO DO SOMETHING TOTALLY
DIFFERENT WE HAVE THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE TO DO THIS CURRENTLY.
AND IF WE NEED TO ADJUST THAT.
WE CERTAINLY. CAN AND- I WILL.
I'LL STOP THEIR EXYNOS GETTING
LAID THE CAUCUS TIME WE HAVE
ONE MORE ITEM AND PUBLIC
COMMENT SO- TODAY THAT SAYS
THAT'S ALL FOR THIS ITEM
UNICOM'S MYSTERY OKAY THANK YOU
WILL GO ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE SO FAR IS TRANSFORMING
SCHOOLS AN EDUCATOR PIPELINE
OVERVIEW SOUTH LAST APARTMENT
OF FINANCE IN L. A. L.
ABBOTTABAD TO KEEP THIS BRIEF.
PLEASE PRESENT. WELL AGAIN
TODAY AT APARTMENT RIGHT NOW I
WILL DO MY BEST TO KEEP IT
BRIEF HERE ARE COVERS UP WHAT
THE PHOTOS OF MY COLLEAGUE
AMBER ALEXANDER WILL COVER- ALL
OF OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT. PROPOSALS FIRST I
DID WANT BRIEFLY ABOUT
COMMUNITY SCHOOL THOUGH I KNOW
IT WAS DISCUSSED OF THE
PREVIOUS PANEL THE MAJOR VISION
DUCTING INTRICATELY EXPAND UPON
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM THAT WAS
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BY INCREASING
INVESTMENT TO JUST OVER THREE
BILLION DOLLARS TOTAL
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND
PROVIDED FOR THAT PURPOSE.
GIVEN THE SIZEABLE INCREASE
SEVERAL STRUCTURAL CHANGES ARE
INCLUDED IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO PRIORITIZE FUNDING
FOR NEW COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND
TO BUILD OUT THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE STRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
APPLICANTS AND OTHERS WHO MAY
BE INTERESTED IN APPLYING FOR
FUNDING. ALSO REFERENCE THE
PREVIOUS PANEL WAS THE.
INCREASE TO THE ONE POINT ONE.
ONE POINT. BILLION DOLLAR. A
WITH IT IN THE CARPENTRY GRANT
PERCENTAGE- FOR THE PURPOSE. OF
REDUCING ADULT STUDENT RATIO ON
CAMPUS AFFILIATES- BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
CERTIFICATED AND CLASSIFIED
STAFF PROVIDING DIRECT SERVICES
STUDENT- AS WELL THERE IS
EXPANDED LEARNING TIME DOLLARS
OF ONE BILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED
AT THE MAY REVISION. FOR
EXTENDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
WITH FUNDING TARGETED TOWARDS
EARLY EIGHT WITH A HIGH
CONCENTRATION OF EDUCATED
PEOPLE AND EVENTUALLY FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF THESE THAT
RECEIPT CONCENTRATION GRANT BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
IN NUTRITION THAT MADE REVISED
BILLS FORTY MINISTRATIONS GOAL
OF PROVIDING UNIVERSAL ACCESS
TO SCHOOL MEALS BY INVESTING
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON ONGOING BASIS
INCENTIVIZE EARLY EIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE EXISTING
FEDERAL UNIVERSAL MAIL
PROVISION TO BOTH MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL FUNDS. FOR MAKING
PARTICIPATION MARK FINANCIALLY
VIABLE FOR L. YANG. BY
PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL- TWENTY
FIVE CENT STATE STATE
REIMBURSEMENT. IN ADDITION TO
INVESTMENT A LOT MORE ACT THAT
FORCE STUDENTS TO ME ALL THE
MAJOR VERSION ALSO PROVIDES A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING TO ABOUT THE
STAFF. TRAINING ON FOOD
PREPARATION AND PROMOTING
HEALTHY FOODS AS WELL AS
FUNDING FOR KITCHEN BILL. FOR
KITCHEN EQUIPMENT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT A
BILL ABILITY TO STORE FRESH
FOODS AND EQUIPMENT NECESSARY
FOR PREPARATION OF HEALTHY AND
NUTRITIOUS SCHOOL MEALS.
INCLUDED MENTAL HEALTH THAT MAY
REVISION WITHDRAW THE GENERAL
PROPOSAL FOR A NEW TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS PUBLISHED
NINETEEN MATCHING GRANTS TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH GIVEN THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT. OF
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS THE
THING MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT
SERVICES ACT PARTNERSHIP GRANT.
ACTUALLY MAYBE INCLUDES FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS
FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
WHICH WILL BE DISCUSSED. IN
FURTHER DETAIL IN BUDGETSUB
COMMITTEE ONE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES LIKE I SAID I'LL
NOW TURN OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
AFTER ALEXANDER TO DISCUSS OUR
FUTURE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU- ERIN GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AGAIN I'LL BE PROVIDING A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE INVESTMENTS
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION- TO EXPAND THE STATE'S
EDUCATOR PREPARATION AND
TRAINING INFRASTRUCTURE- PER
YOUR REQUEST ALL A LOT OF MY
PRESENTATIONS I WON'T GO OVER
THE PROGRAMS. AND THAT WERE
INCLUDED IT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BUT WE JUST NOTE THAT THERE ARE
FOR THEIR WORK AND SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAM. THE
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING I AM. THE
EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAM IN THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER AND PRINT PROGRAM
AS OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA-
THERE ARE ALSO SEVERAL
INVESTMENTS IN THE MAY REVISION
THAT ARE NEW FOR MAY REVISION
BUT- BILL THE POINT OF PRE
EXISTING- PROGRAMS. AGAIN I
WILL COVER THESE PROGRAMS AND
MUCH NEED HELP BECAUSE THEY
THEY ARE- EXISTING OR OR HAVE
BEEN EXISTING PROGRAMS IN THE
PAST- THIS INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- ONE TIME PROP
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL PLAN TO
PROVIDE NO. NO GRANT FOR FUTURE
TEACHERS THAT EARN A NATIONAL
BOARD CERTIFICATION AND AGREE
TO TEACH IN A HIGH PRIORITY
SCHOOL. AND THIS ALSO INCLUDES
A TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME PROP NINETY EIGHT-
INVESTMENT TO EXPAND THE
EXISTING TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
SCHOOL LEADERSHIP ACADEMY. AND
FINALLY FIVE MILLION- DOLLARS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND IS
INCLUDED TO- PROVIDE-
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING THREE
EDUCATOR WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
GRANT. SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
COMPUTER SCIENCE- WILL PROVIDE
A LOT MORE DETAIL ON THE-
PROPOSAL FOR ARE AND BRING NEW
FOR ME REDUCTION AND YOU. I
THINK IN THE AGENDA THAT
REVISION INCLUDES FIFTEEN ONE
TIME. NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
AVAILABLE OVER THREE YEARS TO
ESTABLISH THE COMPUTER SCIENCE
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATION
INCENTIVE GRANT. THIS
INVESTMENT WILL SUPPORT SIX
THOUSAND TEACHERS TO COMPLETE
AND COURSE WORK IF NECESSARY TO
EARN THEIR SUPPLEMENTARY
AUTHORIZATION TO BE ABLE TO
TEACH COMPUTER SCIENCE. THE
MAYOR VERSION ALSO PROVIDES
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO WAIVE THE CRAVING FOR
BE FOR INDIVIDUALS ENTERING THE
K. TWELVE EDUCATOR WORK FORCE
IN THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THE MAYOR VERSION
ALSO PROVIDE FORTY FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION ONE CAN GENERAL
FUND TO CREATE A NEW ROAD MAP-
FOR PRE K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATIONAL EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM.
WILL BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AND AIMED AT
REALLY- IMPLEMENTING A LONG
TERM- TARGETED STATEWIDE
RECRUITMENT AND COMMUNICATION
STRATEGY TO- INCENTIVIZE MORE
INDIVIDUALS TO GET INTO THE
FUTURE WORKFORCE AND ALSO.
WE'VE BEEN DOWN THAT PATH SO
THAT THEY KNOW. WHERE TO WHERE
TO GO- FOR FINANCIAL AID- AS
WELL AS THE MULTIPLE PATHWAYS
AND THAT THE KIDS COULD GO DOWN
TO INTO THE TEACHING PROFESSION.
THE ROADMAP PROGRAM ALSO SIXTY
FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND- WHICH WOULD ALSO
BE PROVIDED TO THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING TO
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
OPERATION OF UP TO EIGHT
STATEWIDE REGIONAL EDUCATOR.
RECRUITMENT AND SUPPORT
CENTERS. THESE CENTERS WOULD
AGAIN BE CRUCIAL IN IN TERMS OF
SERVING AS A POINT OF CONTACT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE INTER
INTERESTED IN ENTERING THE
TEACHING PROFESSION. OF THIS
AMOUNT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND IS PROVIDED- TO
DEVELOP AND DISTRIBUTE A
RESOURCE GUIDE FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES- TO USE-
FOR RESOURCES AROUND HIRING AND
PREPARED AND LICENSED QUALIFIED
TEACHERS. FINALLY THE MAY
REVISION- IN THE AREA OF
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING PROPOSES
TEN MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL PLAN FOR THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE. AND PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING- AROUND
STRENGTHENING GRADING
INSTRUCTION FOR ALL STUDENTS
INCLUDING- STUDENTS WITH
DYSLEXIA. IN TOTAL THE PACKAGE
PUT FORWARD BY THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR EDUCATOR
INITIATIVES IS APPROXIMATELY
THREE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS OR PROVIDE ANY
MORE DETAIL ON THESE
INVESTMENTS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT. GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
MICHAEL PEREZ WITH THE ILLEGAL
I WILL PROVIDING OUR BRIEF
COMMENT THE PROPOSAL ARE
GETTING HIGH POVERTY SCHOOLS IN
THE DISTRICT MY COLLEAGUE AMY
WE WILL PROVIDE OUR COMMENTS ON
EDUCATOR TYPE AND PROPOSALS.
ALTHOUGH TO INCREASE THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT TO PRODUCE
LITTLE TO STUDENT RATIOS. THE
PROPOSAL IS REASONABLE AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
BOTH EFFECTIVE. AT PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO DISTRICTS
WITH HIGHER PROPORTIONS LOW
INCOME STUDENTS FOSTER YOUTH IN
ENGLISH LEARNERS. HELPCENTER
DISTRICTS CAN INCREASE OR
IMPROVE SERVICES. THAT SUPPORT
STUDENT LEARNING AND WELL BEING.
THE PROPOSAL ALSO GIVES THE
CREDIBILITY TO DECIDE HOW TO.
ADDRESS VESTED THROUGH NEEDS-
NEXT FOR THE EXPANDED LEARNING
GRANT PROPOSAL WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE COULD SHOULD
CONSIDER THE TRADE OFFS OF
RESTRICTING THE INCREASE
FUNDING FOR EXPANDED LEARNING.
ACCESS TO SUMMER AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS CAN PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ENGAGING
ACTIVITIES OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL DAY AND PROVIDE ADULT
SUPERVISION FOR CHILDREN WITH
PARENTS WORKING TRADITIONAL
HOURS. ALTERNATIVELY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
PROVIDING FUNDING TO ROUGHLY A
FIFTH BUT GIVING DISTRICTS
LOOKS ABILITY TO SPEND FUNDS
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY THINK WILL
BEST INTERESTED STUDENTS AND
YOUTH WHICH COULD INCLUDE
SUMMER AND AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM.
OF THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
TARGET FUNDING TO OTHER
ACTIVITIES THAT WILL BENEFIT
STUDENTS WITH THE GREATEST
NEEDS. SUCH AS A THING OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR PROVIDING INTENSIVE
TUTORING OR OTHERS TO SUPPORT.
OUR LAST WEEK PER THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOL CARE PROPOSAL WE THINK
THE CHANGES MADE TO IMPROVE ON
THE JANUARY PROPOSAL. WE
RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE
MODIFICATIONS THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PARTICULARLY THE
CHANGES IN THE STRUCTURE OF THE
PROGRAM THAT ENSURES FUNDING IS
PRIORITIZE FOR CREATING NEW
PROGRAMS. OF THE LANGUAGE
AROUND- PROVIDING MORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
EVEN SETTING UP A REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER.
AND BE A MUCH MORE OF A CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS THAT ARE SET FOR
THE SUPPORT THAT SCHOOL WHO
RECEIVE- THE MEMBER VISION
PROPOSED THE- INCREASE AND
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER PROVIDING SMALLER
AMOUNT OF FUNDING INITIALLY BY
ADDING FUNDING IN FUTURE YEARS
THAT THE MANDATE HIGH- THAT
CONCLUDES MY PORTION OF OUR
REMARKS FINISHED WITH THREE ON
NOT PASSED ON TO MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE- GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
A NEARLY WHAT THE ALEJO. I WILL
BE COVERING THE EDUCATOR
SUPPORT IN PIPELINE PROPOSALS-
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF BUT
FOR REFERENCE THESE COMMENTS
CAN BE FOUND ON THE LAST PAGE
OF THE ALLEY OVER YOU CAN'T
OUT. SO WE HAVE THREE
OVERARCHING POINTS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. FIRST
WE THINK THAT THE CAPACITY FOR
NEW OR EXPANDED PROGRAMS WILL
LIKELY BE LIMITED IMMEDIATELY
POST PANDEMIC. SO THE ME
REVISED PROPOSES NUMEROUS NEW
AND EXPANDED EDUCATOR WORKFORCE
INITIATIVES WHICH REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY TO
IMPLEMENT. GIVEN THE LIKELIHOOD
OF BURNOUT AND FATIGUE AMONGST
MANY SCHOOL STAFF SCHOOLS MAY
BE UNABLE TO IMPLEMENT OR TAKE
FULL ADVANTAGE OF THESE
INITIATIVES IMMEDIATELY. IN
RESPONSE THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER FOCUSING ON A
FEW IMMEDIATE PRIORITY IS TO
HELP STUDENTS AND STAFF RECOVER
FROM THE IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND EITHER REJECTING
PROPOSALS FOR EXTENDING
SPENDING DEADLINES FOR OTHER
PROGRAMS. SO WE NOT THE EDUCATE
TRAINING. OVERLAP WITH THE USES
FOR FEDERAL FUNDING SCHOOLS
HAVE RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT
POSSIBLE FEDERAL FUNDS- FROM
THE RECENT RELIEF PACKAGES
WHICH CAN BE USED FOR
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. THE
LEGISLATURE ME JUST WANT TO
CONSIDER HOW THE EDUCATOR
TRAINING- PROPOSALS COULD BE
BEST COMPLEMENTING THESE
FEDERAL FUNDS. LASTLY RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE
CONSIDER REQUIRING CLEAR
DELIVERABLES AND EXPECTATIONS
FOR THE EDUCATOR TRAINING
PROPOSALS SEVERAL OF THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS INCLUDE FEW
DETAILS ON THE DELIVERABLES
EXPECTED ACTIVITIES TO BE
FUNDED SOME PROPOSALS DO NOT
INCLUDE SPECIFIC TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES TO BE FUNDED WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. OR LACK
ROUTINE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE WE THINK
IT'S AYE WISHING A CLEAR SET OF
DELIVERABLES AND EXPECTATIONS
FOR THESE PROPOSALS WOULD HELP
ENSURE THAT FUNDS ARE SPENT AS
INTENDED AND ACHIEVE THAT
DESIRED OUTCOMES. WITH THAT
I'LL CONCLUDE MY TESTIMONY BUT
HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS OF THE
PERFECT TIME THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
PRESENTERS. NO NO THAT IS IT SO
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S ME- SO MAYBE SOME
QUESTIONS IN JUST A COMMENT-
APPRECIATE THE- THE ADULT TO
STUDENT RATIOS CONVERSATION-
LISTEN IF THERE'S ONE WHITE
BEST WAY TO RETAIN TEACHERS AND
HELP OUR KIDS. IS TO LOWER
CLASS SIZES CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE STILL HAS A LARGE CLASS
SIZES IN THE NATION- FOR MANY
YEARS I TAUGHT EIGHTH GRADE
WITH THIRTY EIGHT EIGHTH
GRADERS IN THE CLASSROOM AND
THAT JUST IS. THAT'S TOUGH IT'S
TOUGH ON THE KIDS IT'S TOUGH ON
THE TEACHER. AND IT JUST YOU
KNOW WE CAN DO BETTER. I SEE A
LOT OF MONEY IN HERE FOR A LOT
OF THINGS WE CAN EVEN THOUGH
THE ONE THE ONE KEY THING WE DO
AND ALSO EXERCISE IS TO LOWER.
CLASS SIZES- BECAUSE IT'S BOTH-
YOU KNOW PROVEN QUANTITATIVELY
QUANTITATIVELY AND
QUALITATIVELY THAT IT. IMPROVES
A CHILD'S EXPERIENCE AND THEN
ALSO HAVING- TWO CHILDREN ONE
WENT THROUGH CLASS SIZE
REDUCTION IN K. THREE. WHEN
THEY DID NOT I THINK I SAID I
BELIEVE I SEE A DIFFERENCE EVEN
TODAY AND THAT. SO I APPRECIATE
LEASE OF YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF
THAT. AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE
NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
GOING FORWARD ABOUT BECAUSE
THAT THAT IS A REALLY BIG DEAL.
A FOM MY PERSPECTIVE. I JUST
REGARD WITH REGARD TO THE
EDUCATOR AND SUPPORT PIPELINE
THREE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY
THAT'S LIKE TONS OF MONEY LIKE
PROBABLY TOO MUCH MONEY- BUT-
THAT'S JUST MY PERSPECTIVE-
AGAIN I APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
LIST HERE- SEEMS SO YOU KNOW
THAT THEY THINK WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT GOING BACK TO THE
NATIONAL BIRD SAID. THE BOARD
CERTIFIED TEACHER THING. AND
WHAT THAT REALLY DOES- IS THERE
DATA THAT. TELLS US THAT'S A
GREAT IDEA THAT'S A
CONVERSATION WE DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE RIGHT NOW. BUT I KNOW WE-
WE PROMOTED THAT ABOUT WEALTH
PRIDE ABOUT TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
YEARS NOW WHEN THAT FIRST CAME
ON THE SCENE AND- WE JUST NEED
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS WHETHER
OR NOT THAT'S THE BEST PASSED.
THE GO DOWN- WITH THAT I'M
GONNA TURN IT BACK TO THE
CHAIR- CHAIR MCCARTY WILL TAKE
IT BACK. THANK YOU THINK OF
YOUR PRESENTATIONS. OKAY THANK
YOU- I HAVE. A COUPLE QUESTIONS
ON THE ON THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
SO. THE DEPARTMENT OF A FROM
THE FINANCE WITH THE WHO THE
ONCE YOU GET YOUR. AMBER
ALEXANDER'S HERE AND I CAN FEEL
QUESTIONS ON THAT PROPOSAL OKAY
YES THOSE THIS BUILT UPON THE
PRIOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
PROPOSALS WITH THE- ECONOMICS
FOR HOW IT'S GOING TO BE PAID
FOR WITH THE MATCH REQUIREMENT
TO. MAKE SURE HE'S ACTUALLY ARE
FINANCIALLY VIABLE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF SUPPORT AND I
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT COMMITTEE
SCHOOLS JUST WANT TO SEE HOW
THESE WOULD ACTUALLY. THE
COMMONALITY- THE LANGUAGE THAT
ACTUALLY WITH INTERVIEWS- I
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS LARGELY
BUILT UPON THE LANGUAGE AND
THAT WAS DRAFTED LAST YEAR
AROUND THE FORTY FIVE MILLION
THAT WAS PROVIDED FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS SO IN THAT SENSE- YES
IT IS CONSISTENT THAT LANGUAGE
DID NOT HAVE THE MATH
REQUIREMENT THAT IS A NEW
PIECE- THAT OF THE PROGRAM THAT
WE HAVE BUILT OUT FOR THE NAY
REVISION- WE WOULD NOTE THAT
BACK- MATCH REQUIREMENT- IS A
50% MATCH AMOUNT AND IT CAN BE
EITHER CASH OR IN KIND AND
WE'VE ALSO DRAFTED THE LANGUAGE
TO ALLOW FOR. THAT CONTRIBUTION
TO COME FROM PARTNER ENTITIES-
INCLUDING GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
THE PRIVATE SECTOR SO THE
BURDEN IN PROVIDING THAT MATCH
WOULD NOT- FALL SQUARELY ON AND
THE ONLY A WHICH WE THINK WOULD
HELP MITIGATE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS. IN THAT AREA. OKAY
FAIR ENOUGH. M. THEN. GO AHEAD
THANK. ONLY GONNA GONNA IN THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION. NOTE ON
THE 50% OF MATCH AGREE THAT IT
MAY BE AN ISSUE FOR SOME
SCHOOLS I WOULD ALSO IKE TO
JUST FLAG AT THE TIMELINE IS
DEPENDENT UPON THE TOTAL AMOUNT
OF FUNDS AVAILABLE THE CURRENT
TIMELINE ON THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS PROJECT WAS BASED UPON
THE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION PREVIOUSLY BUT IF THE
FUNDING MOVES FROM THAT NUMBER
TO YOU. THE BILLIONS RANGE WE
ARE LOOKING AT AN EXTENSION AN
EXTENSION NEEDED FOR THE GRANT
ADMINISTRATION PROCESS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT STATE OPERATIONS- TO
ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF THIS
PROGRAM BASED UPON INCREASED
FUNDING. GOTCHA OKAY AND THEN
MOVING ON TO THE- TO THE
TEACHER WORKFORCE SAID
CERTAINLY THIS IS CRITICAL OF
THE IT IN AND ALL- IN ALL OF.
TWENTY YEARS AS FAR AS- MAKING
SURE CAN WE CAN RECRUIT RECRUIT
RETAIN- YEAH OUR PARTY TO WORK
FORCE. WHAT THINK WHAT THINGS
DO WE THINK ARE ARE UNIQUE AS
FAR AS- POTENTIAL EXPANSION OF
EARLY EDUCATORS WITH T. K.
SPECIALLY. THAT THERE IS THE
TWO TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM
THE PART PROFESSIONALS WHO
DON'T NECESSARILY NEED A
TEACHER CREDENTIAL AND THEN THE
TO KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS WHICH
ARE ESSENTIALLY HE KNOWS THAT
THE TYPICAL SINGLE SUBJECT
CREDENTIAL FOR A K. TWELVE
TEACHER. DO WE THINK THIS IS-
IS ADEQUATE AND SUFFICIENT TO
DEAL WITH THE DEAL NEEDS OF
JUST OVERALL- NEED TO RECRUIT
MORE TEACHERS FOR A K. TWELVE
SCHOOL SYSTEM AND WITH THE
EXPANSION OF T. K. NUMBER
ALEXANDER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. ALL AND GO HEAD AND
BEGIN SPEAKING ON ON THAT POINT
AND THEN MAYBE PASS IT OFF TO
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING TO ADD MORE
COMMENTS- BUT WE WOULD NOTE
THAT A NUMBER OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT HAVE BEEN- DRAFTED
INCLUDING THAT. A LARGE AYE
ROAD MAP TO- PRE K. EDUCATIONAL
EMPLOYMENT. WERE DROPPED
INTENTIONALLY TO INCLUDE THAT
CREE QUE- WORKFORCE ANTI CASE
SPECIFICALLY- ACT DR CITY I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANYTHING
MORE THAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO
HAPPEN. OF ANY. OTHER SPECIFIC.
AND WE WERE VERY THOUGHTFUL AND-
IN MAKING SURE OUR TEETH
PARTNERS WORK WITH. YES YOU-
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY OF THE
COMMITTEE- I AGREE WITH EMBERS
SAID COMMENTS AND- THE NEW
TAKEN IN MAY REVISE HERE A
MULTI YEAR MULTI FACETED
SYSTEMIC APPROACH TO
RECRUITMENT- AND THAT'S GOING
TO BE NECESSARY IN ORDER IN
ORDER FOR US TO GET THE T. K.
THROUGH TWELVE IN THE PRE K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATORS WE
NEED. OVER THE COMING YEARS SO
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS MIGHT HAVE
ABOUT THAT BUT- YOU KNOW WE
THINK THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF POTENTIAL PATHWAYS THAT CAN
BE A LINE VERY WELL TO THE T.
K. SPACE. AND WE ARE WORKING ON
THAT OVER HERE AT THE
COMMISSION. TIGHTLIPPED SONNY
JUST ASK A DIFFERENT WAY SAID
YOU THINK AS WE X. AS WE EXPAND
T. K. WHICH IN OUR DOING WHICH-
HAS TO BE APPROVED FORCE FIRST
BUT THAT'S PART OF THE BUDGET
FOR EARLIER CHEN ITEM. DO YOU.
THINK ALL THESE. TEACH PIPELINE
IN AND TEACH TRAINING PRO. WILL
ARE SUFFICIENT AS WE LOOK TO.
EXPANDED T. K. WORKFORCE
ESSENTIALLY TRIPLE THE EXISTING
TICKET WORKFORCE FOR DO WE NEED.
BY THE BOX AND FUTURE AS WELL-
WELL CONTINUALLY WE SHOULD BE
THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX- IN
ORDER TO KIND OF ****
CONTINUALLY ASSESS WHERE WE ARE
AND WHERE WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS- AND WE DO BELIEVE
THIS IS ADEQUATE- TO REALLY
PURSUE- THE KINDS OF WORKFORCE.
THAT WE NEED THE PEOPLE WHO.
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES BASED ON
THESE INVESTMENTS FROM THE
GRANT PROGRAMS THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM THE CLASSIFIED GRANT
PROGRAM THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM ALL OF
THESE OPPORTUNITIES WILL BE
THERE FOR THE TEA CARE WORK
FORCE. TO SUPPORT THEIR
ACHIEVEMENT OF THAT THE
APPROPRIATE CREDENTIAL TO WORK
IN THAT SPACE AND ITS
SIGNIFICANCE FUNDING OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS WHICH IS GOING
TO BE NECESSARY. I THINK THE
ONE ISSUE THAT WE THINK IS
GOING TO BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO ATTEMPT TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY. IS THAT OUR
PREPARATION INSTITUTIONS HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO ABSORB AND
DEVELOP AND PREPARE THIS
WORKFORCE WE KNOW THE MAY
REVISE FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
FOR OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS-
BUT WE THINK THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO TARGET IN THAT SPACE AS
WELL. A DOUBLING THE NUMBERS OF
TEACHERS THAT ARE COMING OUT OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION TO ADDRESS CURRENT
AND CHRONIC SHORTAGES AND TO
ADDRESS THE FUTURE NEEDS THAT
T. K. WILL PRESENT. SURE
MCCARTY. YES I LIKE HONOR ON
BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I'D LIKE TO DO AS MY
COLLEAGUES THERE NETTLE MORGAN
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY WITH SO
MANY NEW CHILDREN BEING SERVED
IN TKA IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE
WORK TO ADDRESS ON THE TKA-
TEACHER PIPELINE. AND AS WE
WELCOME ANY GRADE LEVEL TO THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE GET PARTICULAR
ATTENTION TO RECRUITING AND
SUPPORTING ENOUGH TEACHERS. TO
TEACH THE THOUSANDS OF NEW
STUDENTS WE ANTICIPATE WILL BE
ENTERING TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. THAT SAID THE CD
DOES NOT THINK THAT THAT FIFTY
MILLION IS SUFFICIENT TO
ADDRESS THE WORKFORCE NEEDS
ADAMS THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS
OF NEW TEACHERS THAT WILL BE
NEEDED. TO SUPPORT A WHOLE
DIFFERENT LEVEL. OKAY THANK
YOU- NO FURTHER QUESTIONS WITH
THAT WILL ALSO HOLD THIS ISSUE-
OPEN. AND WITH THAT WE WILL NOW
PROCEED WITH THE PUBLIC%
COMMENT. ON ANY OF THE THREE-
ISSUES ON THE AGENDA TODAY.
LATER THAT MAY REVISE. BUDGET
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE ROOM
OPERATOR WHO'S HERE TO TESTIFY
SO WE CAN- PROCEED WITH THE-
MODERATOR WHO'S FOCUSING ON
TELEPHONE PARTICIPATION HELP.
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE THE SPEAKER LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE THIRTY TWO. PEOPLE
LINED UP. DO WE HAVE OUR OP
MODERATOR OPERATOR. HIS THIRD
LUNCH BREAK THEY'RE GONNA. OKAY
WELL HANG TIGHT FOR A SET. FOR
THE OPERATOR DISCONNECTED.
OTHER WORKING ON IT OKAY. SO
WE'LL JUST- SIT TIGHT FOR A FEW
MOMENTS. THE RETURN TO PEOPLE
SORRY ABOUT THIS TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED OR GO TO LINE
NUMBER THIRTY THREE THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. UP THE CREEK
THIRTY THREE MAY HAVE REMOVED
THEMSELVES ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER FIFTY
TWO FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MURDER WITH SEIU WE WERE
EXCITED AND CRESCENTA FEET I
THINK THE MILLION INCLUDED FOR
THE CLASSIFIED FROM EMPLOYEE
PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN SUMMER
BRIDGE WE WOULD LIKE IF YOU
KNOW DOLLARS BE ONGOING WE'VE
HAD THIS PROGRAM FOR YEARS AND
WE KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT THINKING
THAT- WE ALSO- COMMAND-
INCLUSION AND- AUGMENTATION. OF
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS I WANT TO
REITERATE THAT WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THE KEY
PARTNERS FOR THE COUNTY BOARD
TOGETHER OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES OUT OF ALL THE WORKERS
AND SOCIAL WORKERS ARE CRUCIAL
TO MAKING SURE THE KIDS ARE NOT
ONLY SUPPORT IN SCHOOL BUT AT
HOME- AND- IN TERMS OF THE
UNIVERSAL. KINDERGARTEN AND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM WE UNDERSTAND IF MOVING
FORWARD WE WANT TO WORK WITH-
BOTH OFFICE AFTER THAT WE HAVE
BEEN IN THE GOVERNOR WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
STABILIZING THE ORDER THREE
CARE I IN OUR RICHARD.
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS WE HAVE
THAT- IN MORE DETAIL IN WRITING
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT AS WE MOVE FORWARD BUT
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
STABILIZING. THE CONVERSATION
IS OF THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE AND
FINALLY WE WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
EAT. THIRTY AND THEN CREATE A
CONVERSATION AROUND RATIOS. YOU
KNOW THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE
ONLY TO CLIENTS AND ON THE
GREAT RECESSION AND THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK UNTIL THE
ABOUT INCREASING OUR STAFFING
AND HYGIENE IS IMPORTANT. NOT
ONLY TO PROVIDING- PREVENTING
TO INCLUDE THE READERS BUT ALSO
ENSURING THAT TEN AND- IS THAT
WHAT OF ALL BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT IN OUR LOW INCOME OF
COURSE. THEY HAVE THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF STAFFING FOR
CUSTODIANS AND THEY HAVE THE
HIGHEST- WELL I DON'T ONE
HUNDRED WHICH IMPACT THEIR.
OVERALL FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER
HAVE APPROX TWO TO IN AT THIS
WE'LL GET LINE NUMBER TWO FOUR
FOUR YOUR IS OPEN. THE SHERIN
NUMBER SEVERAL YEAR TO HAVE TO.
P. PARTNERS BETWEEN YEAH YOU
YOU NEED A- ALL OF THE THAT THE
CARE ACT. WITH THE CAN TAX FROM
THE FOR TO REACH CON. WOULD
ALSO MINOR COMMENT WITH EACH
WEEK. HIGHLIGHTS THE FOLLOWING.
ALRIGHT WE APPRECIATE THE- AT
THE CORE AT A MINIMUM RATE
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MARKET
SURVEY FOR ALL PROVIDERS 85% OF
THE STATE MEDIAN INCOME TO KEEP
DOORS OPEN AND- WE SUPPORT
WAITING OFF FAMILY B. THIRD
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
ALL PROPOSED PROVIDER GRANT.
LOOKING RECORD PART OF THE
PROVIDER AND FINALLY WE THANK
THE CHAIR FOR ITS SUPPORT
EXPANSION WHAT. I JUST HAPPEN
TO MAYBE BACK TO GET START WE
WILL NEED TO ADDRESS THE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOUR YEAR OLD
AWAITING WITH THE HELP WORKING
FAMILIES. THANK THE MUCH. THANK
YOU CAN EXPECT. YOUR NEXT OVER
ONE FIFTY FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU TERRY
MCCARTY MEMBERS INTERCHANGE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS SPEAKING ON ISSUE
NUMBER THREE THE NEW CHRISTIAN
INVESTMENT WE ARE THRILLED TO
SEE THE GOVERNOR EMBRACE THE
CONCEPT OF UNIVERSAL SCHOOL
MEALS AND APPRECIATE THE STRONG
COMMON IN THE REGION HEARING-
BY THE STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICE.
HE WE WERE ALSO PLEASED TO
SPEED THE HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIME INVESTMENT IN THE WORK
FORCE AND THE OPERATION NEEDS
TO HAVE A SCRATCH COOKING AND
HEALTHY GROWN FOODS SERVED TO
OUR OUR STUDENTS- WE HOPE THAT
THE FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT WILL
FULLY SUPPORT THE ABOUT THE
NECESSARY. FOR SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL STUDENTS- AS WELL AS
PREVENTING ANY GOT FIVE PARENTS
AS WELL AS SCHOOL. DISTRICTS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. Q. ONE EXTRA
LINE NUMBER SIXTY TWO SIX TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO ALLOW AIR
NAPPING WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES
BUT THE RECORD AMOUNT OF STATE
AND FEDERAL FUNDING FLOWING TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE HAVE AN
UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY TO
REDRESS THE PRESIDENT EQUITY
AND HELP COMMUNITIES RECOVER
FROM THE PANDEMIC. THE APART
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
TRANSFORMATIONAL INTEGRATED
INVESTMENT OVER A MULTI YEAR
PERIOD TO PROVIDE RESTORATIVE
AND TARGETED SUPPORT THE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS OF COLOR. WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED THREE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO
ESTABLISH AN EXPAND COMMUNITY
SCHOOL THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP FOR THE FUTURE OF
LEARNING SUBMITTED WRITTEN
COMMENTS THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
STRENGTHEN THE PROGRAM WITH THE
JAPANESE SIDE AT LEAST 5% OF
THE PLANS ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR BUILDING CAPACITY
AT EVERY LEVEL OF THE SYSTEM.
INCLUDING EIGHT MILLION TO
ESTABLISH ADVISORY COUNCIL
FORTY SIX MILLION TO BUILD
STATEWIDE CAPACITY AND NINETY
SIX MILLION TOOK BATTING EIGHT
REGIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTER WE ALSO BELIEVE THE
ADDED WEIGHT SHOULD BE GIVEN TO
THE APPLICANTS POVERTY STATUS
TO ENSURE THE NEEDIEST
COMMUNITIES ARE PRIORITIZED.
LASTLY TEACHER SHORTAGES REMAIN
A CRITICAL PROBLEM WITH APART
THE TOTAL PROPOSED THREE POINT
THREE BILLION FOR VARIOUS
TEACHER PREPARATION NUMBER
TREATMENT PROGRAM TO HELP
EXPAND AND DIVERSIFY THE
TEACHER PIPELINE ESPECIALLY IN
HIGH NEED AREAS OF SUBJECT. WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE FIFTY MILLION
FOR TRAUMA INFORMED EDUCATOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THANK
YOU. WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU. THANK YOU. NECK WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY FOUR
WORSE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TO DECIDE JERRY CALL WITH
NOURISH CALIFORNIA MY COMMENTS
ARE IN REGARDS TO ISSUE THREE
SPECIFICALLY THE MAY REVISED
SCHOOL THE CHRISTIAN PROPOSAL
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE.
FOR CONSIDERING THE PROPOSAL TO
MAKE CRITICAL ONGOING
INVESTMENT IN SCHOOL NUTRITION
AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER TARGETED INVESTMENTS
IN THE COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY
PROVISION OR C. P. AS A
FUNDAMENTAL COMPONENT OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PERMANENT
APPROACH TO UNIVERSALLY FREE
WITH STRATEGIC STATE INVESTMENT
HE COULD WORK IN A FISCALLY
SUSTAINABLE WAY FOR THOUSANDS
MORE SCHOOLS AND AS MANY AS TWO
MILLION MORE SKEWED. ADAM I
THINK HE'D BE AT THE- SCALABLE
AND EFFICIENT AND OF STATE
DOLLARS THEY CAN DRIVE DOWN AND
EIGHT TO ONE FEDERAL MATCH. AND
IF WE ACT THIS YEAR WHEN
CALFRESH AND MEDI CAL CAPE OF
THE ELEVATED WE CAN MAKE THE
MOST OUT OF AVAILABLE FEDERAL
DOLLARS MAKE SURE THE KIDS MOST
IN NEED TO FREE SCHOOL MEALS
ARE WELL NOURISHED. READY TO
LEARN AND ABLE TO THRIVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. EXCELL THE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN SIX SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS LORRAINE AND FOUND THE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER WE THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR RECOGNIZING
THAT CHILD CARE IS ESSENTIAL
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
TO OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WE
ALSO A LINER COMMENTED BEASTIE
COALITION MESSAGE MANY TO
MAINTAIN AND SUPPORT THE DOCTOR
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ARMAR
SURVEY FOR ALL PROVIDERS 80% OF
STATE MEDIAN INCOME TO BETTER
ENSURE. THEY'RE PUTTING AIRLY
AND JUSTLY WE ALSO ASK THE
ASSEMBLY TO SUPPORT AT LEAST
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILD CARE
SPACES WITH FAMILY FEES BEING
WAIVED FOR ALL FAMILIES UNTIL
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. LASTLY CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FIND
CHILDCARE PROVIDER
STABILIZATION. GRANTS PURSUANT
TO. THANK AND THEN MERRICK
RESCUE PLAN. THESE GRANTS ARE
TO ENSURE. THE THAT INCREASED
TO THE PANDEMIC AND ARE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED TO ENSURE
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS CAN RE
OPEN AND STAY OPEN THIS MONEY
MUST BE USED FOR A SPECIFIC
PURPOSE THE FUNDS MEANT THREE
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
IMMEDIATELY AND EFFICIENTLY WE
WILL BE SUBMITTING A LETTER
LAYING OUT OUR BUDGET
PRIORITIES BASED ON FEEDBACK
FROM PARENTS AND PROVIDERS
STATEWIDE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER INTERCONNECTS OVER
ONE SIXTY EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THAT WAY WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
DOPPIO RECOMMENDATION BY DOWN
1100% ABOUT CREATING K. TWELVE
THE PHONE. EIGHTEEN TWO POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS ACROSS YOUR
PHONE TO THE CONTINENT ALL THE
GENERAL FUND REVENUE DOES NOT
PRETTY GOOD FOR THE LONG TERM.
FIND DOWN THE DEFERRALS NOW
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN FUTURE
BUT IT WILL BE NEEDED. TWO
POINT SIX BILLION FOR. WEEKS
NOW BUT NO BIG DEAL BUT ON A
CASH BASIS THAT WILL COST.
ABOUT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
PAY IT OFF IN CUMULATIVELY
BILLION DOLLARS MORE. IN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR IF IT DOESN'T
PERTAIN OFTEN RETIRED AND-
HIGHLY IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. WE OPPOSED BILLION THINK
IN THE FUTURE TO COST AND HOW
DO MEAN FOR NOW. THE
LEGISLATURE KNOWS SCHOOL DEBATE
ANY PRETTY COSTS OF PENSIONS
AND OTHER PROJECTED COST
PRESSURES AROUND THE CORNER
WHEN ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDS GO
AWAY. NO LONGER THE BALLOT
COUNTY CONTINUES THE MORE RISK
FUTURE CUTS WILL. BE FACED BY
TEACHERS AND KIDS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOUR NEXT ORDER LINE
NUMBER SIXTY NINE SIX NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU'RE CARE
COURTNEY JENSEN ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL THAT CALIFORNIA. OVER
FORTY ORGANIZATIONS OR
OFFENDING BURKE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES WE APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN A REVISED
AREN'T BACK. YET WE ARE
REQUESTING AT LEAST THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION TO
SUPPORT HOME BASED AND CENTER
BASED CHILD CARE FACILITY WE
ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE
ADMINISTRATION L. A. O. TO
DISCUSS THESE THAT FEDERAL.
BURKE BUT THE LEAGUE ACTION WE
MUST INVEST IN FACILITIES TO
ENSURE WE HAVE THE PHYSICAL
SPACE THAT VARY FROM THE NEW
BASES THE FACT. THAT DAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY THREE SEVEN
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS CARLA
CALIFORNIANS REJECTED- OUR
ORGANIZATION ALONG WITH MANY
OTHER THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHO
WORK WITH STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
OF COLOR- ORGANIZED ADVOCATED
FOR FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS WE WANT TO REAFFIRM OUR
SUPPORT FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. BY NAME
SCHOOL TRANSFORMATION ABOUT THE
RACIAL JUSTICE ISSUE NOT OUGHT
TO OUR COMMUNITY BECAUSE THEY
NEVER BEEN UP FUNDING FOR IT-
BUT THAT'S WE WANT TO GET TO
WE'RE NOT THERE YET. BUT YOU
FOR MANY BLACK AND BROWN
STUDENTS- I THINK LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE ERIN SURE EARLIER ARE
HOPE TO. CREATE A COMMUNITY
VALUE. TO WORK WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. THE KIND OF REALLY
WALK INTO A DEMONSTRATION
PLANNED- THAT THAT THAT'LL BE
FIVE PERCENT. BA AND ALSO GIVE
ADDITIONAL WEIGHT. THE HOBBIT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ON OVER
THE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOWNLOAD WITH
THE AT THE FIRST ONE IS
KNOWLEDGE THAT HUGE POSITIVE IN
THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDING QUALITY
EDUCATION FOR ALL FOUR YEAR
OLDS. K. THE 5% TO QUALIFY FOR
THE LTFS EFFECT. BUT WE THINK
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND ALL THE
K. TWELVE CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS
LIKE FOOD SERVICE AND
TRANSPORTATION SHOULD RECEIVE
THE CALL AS WELL. WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THE APPROPRIATION FOR
THE CLASSIFIED SUMMER DISTANCE
PROGRAM RECOGNIZED AS ON THE
PHONE WITH HER FRIEND HAS BEEN
APPROPRIATED FOR FOUR YEARS
NOW. RECOGNIZING THE PROGRAM AT
UNBELIEVABLE MAKE DISTRICTS AND
THAT BILL MORE SECURE IN THEIR
PARTICIPATION. WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION PERSONAL
E-MAIL REIMBURSEMENT FALL SHORT
OF THE COST OF THE TRUE
UNIVERSAL NO PROGRAM WHICH IS
CLOSER TO FIVE HUNDRED MILLION.
FINALLY A PORTION OF THAT
BACKING PLATE SHOULD BE
DEDICATED FOR CUSTODIAL STAFF
TO THE NECESSARY. THINGS STAND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELL GO
TO LINE SO NINE SEVEN ONE NINE
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
KYLE I'LL AND I'LL BE HAPPY
EDUCATION MENDED THE COST THAT
WORK WHICH IS TO BELIEVE IN
OBTAINING WRITTEN. UNFUNDED
STATE MANDATES WE ARE PRETTY
GOOD THAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
TO PROVIDE A ONE POINT SEVEN
COLLECTED AT A BLOCK GRANT AND
INCLUDE THE FEMININE HYGIENE
PRODUCT MANDATE INTO THE
MEDICAL GRANT BEGINNING WITH
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR. HOWEVER WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
FUND THE FEMININE HYGIENE AND
IT FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS MUCH LESS THE TWO POINT
ONE MILLION BUT THE ONLY A
RECOMMENDED IT MARCH REPORT.
ALL OUR ELEAZAR SUPPORT OF A
POLICY STIPULATED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AB TEND TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS AN
ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF AND HYGIENE
PRODUCTS PROVIDED AT SCHOOL BUT
SERVING STUDENTS IN GRADES SIX
THROUGH TWELVE. WE NEED SUPPORT
IN THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
EARLY EIGHT ABOUT IT WITH MONEY
TO CARRY OT THIS REQUIREMENT
WITHOUT HAVING TO DEPEND UPON
THAT ARE MEANT TO EDUCATE OUR
STUDENTS TO COMPENSATE OUR
TEACHERS AND STAFF. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO FUND THE
FEMININE HYGIENE PRODUCT
MANDATE AT THE ELLIOTTS
RECOMMENDATION. OF TWO POINT
ONE MILLION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL NOW GET A LINE OF.
FORTY FOUR SIX OUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS
SYNDICATE WATCHMEN AND
REPRESENTING THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
FIRST OFF WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO
COMMEND THE GOVERNOR AND THANK
HIM FOR INCLUDING UNIVERSAL T.
PAY OUT THE PART OF THE
NEIGHBOR YOU BUY THEM WE LOOK.
AT THE FINAL PACKAGE OF TOP-
SUCH A PROPOSAL THE BEST WAY TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP IS TO
PREVENT IT BEFORE IT EVEN OPENS
UP AND WE SEE UNIVERSAL PK. AT
THE PATHWAY TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT. OUR SECOND ON INDEPENDENT
STUDY I'LL JUST NOTE THAT THE
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS PROVIDED HIGH
QUALITY INDEPENDENT STUDY
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. AND WE
PLAN TO CONTINUE OFFERING THAT
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER AND. INTO
NEXT SCHOOL YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. EXPLORE THE NEXT
OVER THE LINE NUMBER FORTY FOUR
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU LEILANI I CANNOT ON BEHALF
OF THE FEE CAN BE TAKING A
COLLECTION BE TRONG WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE EIGHTY
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION FOR A
FEW KEY GPAS. TO HELP WITH
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH A
PANDEMIC WELL BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS HAVE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND CHARTER SCHOOL
JTA'S HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
THE FUNDS BECAUSE THE STATE
DOES NOT RECOGNIZE OUR GPAS OF
A LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY. IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE ENTIRE
BUDGET OF EIGHTY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION AS A MINIMAL AMOUNT BUT
IT'S SORELY NEEDED PARTS
EIGHTEEN COULD PROVIDE ON THE
RESEARCH TO FIND A SIGNIFICANT
AND MANY EXPENSES TO GET THEIR
PROGRAM THROUGH THE PANDEMIC.
THE FUNDING IS COMPLETELY
SEPARATE FROM THE TAKEN TAKE
OFF FROM WORK WORKS PROGRAM
FUNDS WHICH ARE PROGRAMMATIC
FINDS THAT WE ALSO RELY ON TO
MAINTAIN AND DEVELOP HIGH
QUALITY. ATHLETES FOR OUR
STUDENTS THE THINKING TAKE OFF
FROM WORK WORKS PROGRAM FUNDS
ARE GREATLY NEEDED AND ARE
GREATLY IN NEED OF ADDITIONAL
STATE INVESTMENT IN THE AFTER
THOSE PROGRAMS TO AT A MINIMUM
RECEIVE A COLLAPSE. THANK
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL CLIENTS THAT
THE PRODUCT BY EFFORTS. THANK
YOU. NEXT WERE LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JOSE VARGAS WITH UNITED
WAY THE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
HAPPY THE HEALTHY START
COALITION MY COMMENT PERTAINS
TO EXECUTE COMMITTEE PEOPLE'S
IT'S GREAT TO SEE SUCH A NEXT
INVESTMENT IN WHAT VERY NOW
WOULD BE THE- RANCH. OF OUR
SCHOOLS SINCE THE HOUSE START
IN THE NINETY NINETIES I LIKE
TO THINK THAT APARTMENT BUDGET
AND STATE BOARD ABOUT FOR THE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AS
WELL AS BUDGET STAFF AND
LEADERS WILL BE HARD. TO
INCORPORATE MARK ABOUT THIS.
THERE'S A MARKET THAT SHOULD BE
CAN IF COMMUTER SCHOOL MODEL TO
TRULY BE THE START POINT OUT
FIRST THE ROLE OF COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING MUST BE NEXT. CBO
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO IT APPLE
FOR SOME OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
START AND WE SCHOOL PROGRAMS
FACT BASED ORGANIZATION. THE
RIGHT YOU CENTER IN RICHMOND
EXAMPLE RECEIVE HELP STARTS YOU
AND SO OPERATE TODAY SIMILAR
THE TRUCK IT'S CURRENTLY I
ABOUT OF TWO COMO IN THE
ANGELES AREA SIR OVER THOUSAND
CHILDREN IF. AND YET AT THIS.
WOULD QUALIFY FOR OTHER CURRENT
PRO TRUCTURE SECONDLY
COMMITTEE PROGRAMMING WE SHOULD
DECREASE REMOVE ALL THE METRIC
CARE INSTANTLY. WHICH ARE
PRETENDING APPALLED CONTRACT
SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO WAIT.
THEY WERE FOR SCHOOL AFTER TO
BE. BROKEN BEARDED MAN I'M
GOING TO HAVE THIS WILL BE ABLE
OF RESOURCES AS URBAN EXAMPLE
CAL. THESE COMMUNITIES SHE NOT
BE PUT WITH THEY HAVE A GREATER
NEED IF YOU WERE RESOURCE
ASSETS WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH BUDGETS FROM FURTHER UP
WHICH WE THE SCHOOLS. AT IT'S
POSSIBLE THANK YOU. EACH YEAR.
THE MAYOR VISION OF AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TOWARDS
UNIVERSAL BLACKMAIL. BY
PROVIDING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION AND I'M GOING FUNDING
TO ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE. IN ONE OF THE
FEDERAL UNIVERSAL MAIL
PROVISION. HOWEVER 50% OF THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE TWO POINT NINE MILLION
STUDENTS AT THE SCHOOL WOULD
STILL NOT BE L. TO RECEIVE. THE
MANY BENEFITS IT'S CALL MILK
FOR ALL. MORE IS NEEDED TO MAKE.
MEALS OF REALITY. EVERY HELLO.
STUDENT THERE'S ALSO A HUNDRED
MILLION THE MAYOR. DIVIDE
KITCHEN INVESTOR UP ENTRY CRISP
NUTRITION. EITHER CRITICAL AND-
GINGER HAD THE HIGHER QUALITY
MEALS ARE SERVED TO OUR KIDS.
TODAY HOWEVER BECAUSE TO THAT
CAN. TO STRUGGLE. BECAUSE OF
LOWER PART OF THE RATES DURING
CO WHICH- THAT ALREADY AND- AT
THAT TIME ALITY COSTS. THE
STAFF MAY NOT FIVE FIFTY
MILLION JUST THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY ONE YEAR. YOU MUST
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE PANDEMIC WILL
BE FUNDING FOR THIS WOMAN
PROGRAM THAT CONTINUE TO
CHILDREN TO THE CAR AND DIVIDE
LAUGH BECAUSE- WORKERS. THAT
HAVE BEEN ON THE LINE IS THE
BEGINNING OF. NINETY SEVENTY
FIVE SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CANYON MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
INCLUDING A REQUEST FOR THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE CREATION OF AN
LGBTQ PLUS TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF WHICH
IS MENTIONED IN ISSUE YOU. WILL
BE AN EQUITABLE AND EFFECTIVE
TOOL THAT CAN BE SCALED ACROSS
THE STATE AND IS THE PRODUCT
AND EIGHT YEARS OF ADVOCACY LED
BY EQUALITY CALIFORNIA A
TECHNICAL PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LGBTQ CAUCUS AND WE STRONGLY
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO ADVANCE
THE FUNDING AS WELL- EQUIPPING
TEACHERS TO SUPPORT LGBTQ PLUS.
IS A CRITICAL PILLAR IN
CALIFORNIA BIG PICTURE AFTER
YOU STOP THE HARMFUL CYCLE THAT
YOU BECOME TRAPPED IN WHEN THEY
DON'T FEEL SAFE AT SCHOOL WHICH
HAS IMPACTED INTO ADULTHOOD-
AND FINALLY TEACHERS ACROSS THE
STATE INCLUDING THE EXTENT.
HAVE LONG SUPPORTED THIS
TRAINING WE KNOW THAT TEACHERS
WANT TO SUPPORT THEIR STUDENTS
THEY WANT TO PROVIDE A SAFE
HAVEN ND THE FUNDING WILL
EQUIP THEM WITH THE TOOLS TO DO
SO AGAIN WE URGE THE RETENTION
OF THE THREE MILLION DOLLARS AS
AN INVESTMENT IN OUR FUTURE AND
OUR. COMMUNITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WELL NOW THAT NUMBERS. ONE
SIX ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CARE MCCARTY TRICKY
BALANCE HERE TO UNION OTHER
EDUCATORS AND QUALIFIED
PROFESSIONALS WE'D LIKE TO.
EXPRESS OUR THANKS FOR THE
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM THAT IS
BEING UNVEILED THE COURTS YOU
KNOW WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT
SUCCESS. AS WELL THE CARD FIGHT
SUMMER SCHOOL OR SUMMER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IN ITS
FUNDING WITHOUT THE P. THAT
BECOME ONGOING RATHER THAN
FILLING UP THE COP EVERY SO
OFTEN. SOMETHING THAT WE ALSO
AGREE WITH THAT THAT'S BEEN
SAID TODAY THE LACK OF STURGEON
PERS CONTRIBUTIONS FOR
EMPLOYERS- IT IS HEARTENING WE
HOPE THAT THAT WILL CONTINUE.
INTO THE FUTURE KNOWING THAT WE
ARE ON THE LAST OF THE LAST-
PROVIDED CONTRIBUTION THE IRAQI
ISSUE ALSO MUST BE ADDRESSED AS
IT HAS BEEN ONGOING IMPACT ON
PROP NINETY EIGHT. I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE INCREASED CUSTODIAL
RATIOS TO STUDENTS SO THAT THEY
CAN- INSURANCE SAFE. PLACE TO
LEARN- IN A POST PANDEMIC
WORLD- BUT MOST OF ALL THE
DISCUSSION AROUND DISTANCE
LEARNING WE UNDERSTAND THAT
INDEPENDENT STUDY MAY BE THE
SQUARE PEG GOT THESE ROUND
HOLES WILL BE TRYING TO FIT
THROUGH HOWEVER WE'RE NOTICING
IN OTHER STATES SUCH AS NEW
YORK. THAT GIVEN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BEING BUILT UP
IN BROADBAND CONNECTION WITH
STUDENTS EDUCATION NOW- SNOW
DAYS MAY NO LONGER BE A THING
AND I FEEL SORRY FOR THOSE
CHILDREN IN NEW YORK BUT IT
JUST GOES TO SHOW HOW WE CAN
PICK A QUICKLY- WHEN WE NEED TO
HAVE TO. LEARNING ADHOC AND WE
BELIEVE THAT DANNIELYNN PORTENT
ELEMENT THE. TRIPLET THANK YOU.
AN EXTERNAL NUMBER TWENTY TWO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS A- CREOLIZED
WITH THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER
COMMITTEES WORK WHEN CHILDREN
ARE CARED FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN PROGRAM EIGHT
WHITE ARE URGING FOR POTS ON
THE UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PLAN IN ORDER TO
BRING STAKEHOLDERS MEDIA
PROVIDERS COMMUNITY BASED CHILD
CARE PARENTS ADVOCATE SCHOOLS
AND OTHERS. TO THE TABLE BESIDE
A BOTTLE TRULY UNIVERSAL MAKES
DELIVERY DELIVERY PROGRAM THAT
MAXIMIZES PARENT CHOICE MEANING
PARENTS CAN CHOOSE A FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOME COMMUNITY BASED
CENTER FAMILY FRIEND OR
NEIGHBOR OR ELLIE AID SPACE
PROGRAM OF THEIR CHOICE AND UP
WITH THE NEEDS OF. BLACK AND
BROWN FAMILY AND FAMILIES OF
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES WE
HAVE NOT YET BEEN A PROPOSAL
FROM THE ASSEMBLY OR THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT ENSURES
THAT MODEL AND TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE BRISTOL PLAN WHICH
IS ECONOMIC EQUITY AND
ADVERSITY ASSUMING THAT NON LED
PROGRAMS WILL JUST BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF MORE YOUNGER
CHILDREN MISSES THE POINT THAT
MANY FOR YOU ALSO ALL. RIGHT
THE NEED PROGRAMS AND SHOULDN'T
BE FORCED INTO AN ALLEY A
SETTING THAT THEY MAY NOT BE
READY FOR STATE THERE ARE MODEL
TO OTHER STATES YOU CAN LOOK TO
LEARN WHAT HAS WORKED AND WHAT
DOES THA YES WE AGREE THAT
CHANGE CAN BE HARD AND MORE
THAN EVER IN THE PAST YEAR
PROVIDING PARENTS HAVE PROVEN
AGAIN AND AGAIN. HOW ADOPTABLE
THEY ARGUE CHANGE WE SHOULDN'T
ASK THEM TO ACCEPT SUCH A
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE. THAT HAS
BEEN THOUGHT OUT. ALTHOUGH NEED
HI WE URGE YOU GET TO TAKE THE
TIME NEEDED TO A MORE.
SUPPORTIVE BUT- IN THE BEGIN
APPLY. TO PRESCHOOL AND BEYOND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELL NOW
GO NUMBER SEVEN THAT SEVEN
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MICHELLE TOLD BERMAN THE CITY
WITH KIDDING GO WITHOUT CARE
AND PRESCHOOL PROVIDER- WE
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN ALL FOUR YEAR OLD.
AS A STEP TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO A YEAR
OF HIGH QUALITY PRE K. AND
ALLOW ME TO DO BASS PROVIDED
THE THIRD OF THOSE CHILDREN YOU
NEED IT MOST WHEN THEY'RE
YOUNGER. AND THEN WE WOULD URGE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO OPEN
UP THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
THAT SERVES CHILDREN TERRIFIED
AND INCLUDE FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDER- WE'RE GLAD TO SEE THE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
CHILD CARE SLOTS THE THIRD MORE
FAMILIES. WE KNOW CHILD CARE
THE FINANCIAL AND CHILDREN AND
FAMILY THINGS THAT THAT HIGH
QUALITY CHILD CARE- WE WOULD
ALSO ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
EASY COALITION CALLING FOR
ADDITIONAL CHILD CARE WHAT. AND
ESPECIALLY INCREASING THE TUB
CARE REMARKS RIGHT AND THIS IS
CRITICAL PERVASIVELY DISEMBARK
CHILD CARE TEACHERS AND
PROVIDERS OF BEEN HEROES ON
BOTH OF THE LAST YEAR AND THE
PREVIOUS. DECADE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHEN I GONNA LINE UP
EIGHTY FOR THAT EIGHT FOUR YOUR
LINE OPEN. HEY GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT KATHY
BAN OFTEN RIGHT REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA-
FIRST- WE'D LIKE TO JUST. THANK
THE FAMILY MEMBER RAMPS UP FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON WAITING
FAMILY FEES- WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A FAMILY TO USE EXTENDED
NOW THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR-
YOU THINK THAT THAT AS- THE
BEST WAY TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
RELIEF TO MANY. FAMILIES WHO
HAVE STRUGGLED THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC- WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME WE CAN BE- WE SHAPE BUT
THOSE FAMILY KIDS LOOK LIKE IN
THE FUTURE. ALSO AGAIN WANT TO
THANK THE TERROR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN- WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
SEE- AS UNIVERSAL- TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- WE DO ENCOURAGE OUR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
WORK TOGETHER JUST TO MAKE
SURE- THAT CONCERNED- ARE
DROPPED. UP FROM THOSE OF YOU
WHO MAY BE CONCERNED ABOUT
IMPACT ON IMPACT ON LOW INCOME
FAMILIES- OR TAKING DOLLARS
FROM EARLY CHILD CARE. WE KNOW
THAT YOU WILL WORK TO FIND THAT
BALANCE- SO THAT- WE- ARE
CHILDREN WHO ARE ZERO TO THREE-
ARE NOT IMPACTED- SO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP-
GREATLY APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL ADELINE
NUMBER EIGHTY SIX EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS A- BOXTEL ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. WE ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT NAY
REVISION BECAUSE ON THE ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
CHILD CARE SLOTS AND THE FILING
DONE ALONG OVER YOUR NEED FOR
RATE REFORM AND PAYING
PROVIDERS A LIVING WAGE. TO
EFFECTIVELY INVEST IN CHILD
CARE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ECO OFFICIALS REQUEST TO
IMMEDIATELY RELEASE THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION IN FEDERAL CHILD
CARE PANDEMIC REALLY FUNDING.
UPDATED INCREASE PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENT RATES CREATE A
MINIMUM OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
NEW SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE
THOUGHT. BUILD NEW AND WE'RE
RENOVATING EXISTING FACILITIES
AND EXTEND FAMILY SHE'S AND
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISIONS MOVING
FORWARD WITH RESPECT TO SCHOOLS
RELY THE GOVERNOR'S AMBITIOUS%
SET OF PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
THAT LEAD WITH EQUITY AND
FOCUSED ON THE COMPREHENSIVE
NEEDS OF CHILDREN. AS A PART OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS WE WOULD
URGE THE LEGISLATURE ENTRY TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S CLEAR
CUTTING ON ALLEY EIGHT TO
ALLOCATE ON STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT AND PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
THESE NEW PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
TRANSPARENCY AND EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION. FINALLY AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE FISCAL CLIFF THIS
CREATES AN OUT YEARS AND WOOD
COURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAINTAIN THE COMMITMENT TO
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT TO
ENCOURAGE ELEAZAR TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL STAFF. TO PROVIDE A
STURDY FOUNDATION. FOR SCHOOLS
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK SPEAKER PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR THAT SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBER TO SHELVE THE K. UNDER
WHAT ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION WITH THREE
QUICK POINTS. FOR WORKING WITH
THE NEW SEMESTER CREATION
OPPOSE THE COMPOUNDED COLA FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION. HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE THAT THE FACILITIES ARE
DESERVING OF THE SAME. IT
SHOULD CLASSES. BUDGET THIRTY
ONE OF THOSE VALUES AND WE
BELIEVE THAT YOU BUDGET ITEM
SHOULD BE VALUED EQUALLY BY
PROVIDING THE MEDICAL UP FIVE
POINT 007% TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING AS WELL. SECOND WE
CONTINUE TO CALL FOR ON GOING
FUNDING FOR PRESCHOOLERS WITH
DISABILITIES. UNFORTUNATELY THE
PROPOSED EARLY EDUCATION
BACKGROUND CAN BE USED FOR BOTH
NON SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES
AND FOR NOT THREE FOUR HOURS.
FOR THAT REASON WE SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RECOMMENDATION TO ALLOCATE THE
FUNDING FOR PRESCHOOLERS WITH
DISABILITIES. THROUGH THE
EXISTING FORMULA. BY WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LEARNING
INTERVENTIONS. BE TARGETED
TOWARD STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES PROPHETICALLY BY
FUNDING ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SIXTY SEVEN- WE BELIEVE THAT
THE COURT APPOINT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN LITIGATION AND
POTENTIAL SCHOOL DISTRICT
BANKRUPTCY. BY PROVIDING
FUNDING TO RECALL THE NINETEEN
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL EDUCATION
FOR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
AT THE PROVIDE WAYS FOR PARENTS
AND FAMILIES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT- TO GET THROUGH. THAT
LEARNING MEDICATION. TOGETHER
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I'M NOT
GONNA LIE NUMBER SEVEN EIGHT
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DERELICT WITH
PEACH PLUS A WE WANTED TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S- INCREDIBLE FOCUS ON
EQUITY AND IT'S AN INVESTMENT
IN OUR K. TWELVE SYSTEM- BUT
LIKE THAT LET'S JUST LIKE THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S MENTIONED WE
ARE ALSO CONCERNED THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
INVESTMENT REALLY. HAS THE
IMPACT BEEN INTENDED AND WOULD
ENCOURAGE GREATER OVERSIGHT
TRANSPARENCY AND HOW THOSE
DOLLARS WOULD BE SPENT
INCLUDING- CONTINUING TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THE LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATURES PROPOSAL OF THE L.
CATS PORTAL- FROM LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET TO ENSURE THAT WE
ACTUALLY DO SEE WHERE THESE
RESOURCES ARE GOING ON THAT
THEY'RE HAVING THE IMPACT THAT
THEY WERE INTENDED HAHA WE ALSO
HIGHLY SUPPORTIVE. OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN- BUILDING A WALK
SUPPORTED AND DIVERSE EACHER
PIPELINE- WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS WORK BUT WE ALSO
ENCOURAGE A GREATER FOCUS ON-
EXPLICIT EXPECTATIONS BOTH IN
TERMS OF PROCESS FOR LOCAL
LEADERS ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
WORKING WITH THEIR TEACHERS ON
THE GROUND TO ENSURE THAT THIS
IS MEETING THE GREATEST NEEDS
BOTH THE TEACHERS AND STUDENTS.
AND THAT THERE ARE SOME CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS FOR HOW THIS THIS-
THE FUNDS ARE. GOING TO BE
EXPANDED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WILL NOT ALIGN NUMBER THIRTY
THREE THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KAREN MCCARTY IN NUMBERS
MY NAME IS GETTING COLD DURING
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION OUR COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS SUPPORT ESSENTIAL AND
ARE LOWER INCOME FAMILIES THE
FACT THAT THE CHILD CARE AND
OTHER FAMILY SUPPORT. MY INPUT
IS BEEN REGARD ISSUES ONE AND
TWO IN RESPONSE TO THE PROPOSED
A REVISED FAILURE TO INCREASE
RATES WILL COLLAPSE THE CHILD
CARE FIELD. ARE THERE ANY
THOUGHT PROVIDED ARE
ANTICIPATED TO ONLY BE ACCEPTED
BY LICENSE EXEMPT PROVIDERS AND
WILL FURTHER DISCONNECT OUR
LOWEST INCOME MAINLY BLACK AND
BROWN WOMEN. WHO ARE ALSO IN
HEAD OF HOUSEHOLDS FROM HIGHER
QUALITY OF LIFE FAMILY CHILD
CARE HOMES AND CENTRES. NOT
INCREASING RATE WILL KEEP
PROVIDERS AND POPPERS MAKING
HOURLY RATES OF BETWEEN. THREE
TWENTY TEN NINE FIFTY AN HOUR.
START WITH THE WEATHER THERE
BEEN A ONE HUNDRED TO HUNDRED
THOUSAND SPOT. WITHOUT A RATE
INCREASE MANY HIGHER QUALITY
PROVIDERS WILL NOT ACCEPT
BELCHER STERN THAT'S RIGHT
ASSEMBLY. CREATING A GREATER
RACIAL INEQUITY DIVIDE. IT THE
INCREASE IN WHAT IS SECURED
WITH A RATE INCREASE. THERE
MUST BE CONSIDERATION OF ONE
TIME GRANT MONIES FOR AGENCIES
TO BEGIN IMMEDIATELY RAMPING UP
FOR FAMILY INVOLVEMENT. WE
BELIEVE THAT IF YOU INCREASE
THE RATE AND PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR CONTRACTORS TO RAMP UP.
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO ENROLL
ANY NUMBER. OF BLOCKS THAT YOU
MAKE AVAILABLE. OUR AT THE PEAK
THE PROPOSAL I THINK ASK THAT
THERE BE PURSUED TO PROTECT OF
PARENTAL CHOICE FOR FAMILIES.
WHAT DID YOU QUE PROGRAM DOES
NOT MEET THE NEED OF A FAMILY
THAT THERE BE VALUED A TRUE
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
COMING TOGETHER TO SUPPORT
CHILD AND FAMILY NEEDS. FINALLY
I ASKED THAT THERE BE
CONSIDERATION TO PROTECT
CHOICES THE FAMILY BY ALLOWING
FREE IN PERSON AT. A SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE DURING SCHOOL HOURS.
WE ALIGN OUR- FURTHER AFTER THE
ECB COALITION AND GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR HEARING. TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELL NOT
A LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIX THREE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON DIANA DOMINGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER. MEMBERS SPENT RATE
REFORM IS OUR TOP PRIORITY AND
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY BREAK
BEGAN RATES EARLIER. CALIFORNIA
MUST DO THE RIGHT THING FOR OUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS BY
INCREASING RATES AND
IMPLEMENTING REIMBURSEMENT RATE
REFORM TO CREATE A MORE
EQUITABLE RATE STRUCTURE.
PUBLIC CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WERE ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE
PANDEMIC SERVING THE CHILDREN
OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE AT
RISK TO THEIR OWN HEALTH YEAH
HE CONTINUED TO PAY THEM
EMBARRASSINGLY LOW WAGES.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT FULLY
STABILIZED AND RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC WITHOUT A ROBUST CHILD
CARE SYSTEM TO ENABLE PEOPLE TO
GO BACK TO WORK GO BACK TO
SCHOOL AND. TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU. YOU WILL
HAVE A LINE NUMBER SEVENTY TWO
SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THAT AFTERNOON I'LL HELP WITH
WIDENING GROUP OF THE SAME NEXT
GEN CALIFORNIA SPEAKING OUT
GOING TO TRANSITION AT THE END
OF THE SECURITY HAS NOT LEAVE
BEHIND DURING THE PANDEMIC THIS
LACK OF RELIABLE ACTION SHIFTED
A PARTICULARLY SEVERE FOR BLACK
IN LENEXA HOUSEHOLDS ESPECIALLY
THOSE WITH CHILDREN. WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THE PROPOSED ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AN
ONGOING FUNDING TO ENCOURAGE
SCHOOLS TO PARTICIPATE IN
FEDERAL UNIVERSAL MEAL PROGRAM
AS WELL AS THE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME INVESTMENT IN
SCHOOL KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES AND TRAINING FOR
STAFF. IF THEY'RE BORN FIRST
STEP THAT WILL HELP EXPAND ACT
THAT THAT I WILL MAIL AND HELP
OUR STATE TRANSITION TO
UNIVERSAL WILL. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THAT FUNDING FOR
UNIVERSAL BREAKFAST LUNCH AND
OUT OF WHAT TIME YOU OPEN PLAY%
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
TWENTY TWO BUDGET TO ENSURE WE
ARE HEALTH. FRESHLY FOR MEAL
SOFT AT SOME THERE AND LEVEL
THANK YOU. FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
AND PARTNERSHIP ON EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE PROGRAMS OVER
THE YEARS. WE ALSO- WANT TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT. WACO
PROVIDES HEAD START PROGRAMS TO
ELEVEN THOUSAND CHILDREN
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
CANADIAN STAFF. TO ADVOCATE FOR
CURRENT CHOICE. PROVIDING FOR
HOLD CHILD STAR DOES. WE
APPRECIATE THE FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL PRO. AS WE HAVE
BLENDED PER. WITH HEAD START.
WE ALSO. THE GOVERNOR'S. ON
THAT- PROGRAM IS WELL LOOK FOR
TO AND- THINGS THAT COVER MAYBE.
AND WORKING WITH THE CAN BE. TO
CONTINUE. BANISH ISSUE. IN A-
TO A CO. AS YOU KNOW. COURT
SCHOOL. OF STUDENTS WHO ARE IN
OUR JUVENILE WHO CAN. ALTER OUR-
SCHOOLS. RECENTLY WE HAVE X.
AND AVERAGE A DAY ATTENDS CUT
ABOUT HALF- AND WE- DO NOT HAVE
TIME TO CALL AND WILL. AT
SCHOOL THIS HAS FOR THIS AND TO
AT NINE MILLION DOLLARS. IN
FUNDING- SITUATION IN BY IN
LIKE HE TO. WHO ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN PRO. WE HAVE A.
AND WITH IT FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS-YOU MAY HAVE ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FAIR TENSION TO THESE REQUESTS
THANK YOU. ADELINE NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- ROMANTICA
BONTA ELLIOT CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM- BUT WE ARE A
COALITION OF NONPROFIT I'M
SORRY NONPROFIT COALITION OF
PROVIDERS THIRTEEN OUT OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY CHILD
CARE CENTERS PRE PANDEMIC AND-
OVER FORTY THOUSAND CHILDREN AS
WELL PRETEND THAT MAKE ONE I
THINK- THE CHAIR FOR HIS TIME
AND LEADERSHIP THEY ON THE
ISSUE- I HAD TO BE COGNIZANT OF
TIME I JUST WHEN I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR RECOGNIZING
THE NEED TO FOR. ALL PROVIDERS
WITH THE FIGHT STIPEND- HOWEVER
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE LA-
EARLIER TODAY THERE IS-
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE MONEY
AVAILABLE TWO POINT THREE
BILLION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- BUT STILL WE WOULD-
ALIGN OUR CAR WITH THE EAST
COALITION. OUR THE STATE AND TO
GO TO ALL PROVIDE. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY WILL ALIGN OUR ARE
TRANSITION CAN ARE WITH THE
CARE. ON THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT
MAKE THE LIBERATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. BORDERLINE NUMBER NINE
ZERO LINE IS A- THANK YOU
AFTERNOON PATTY ON BEHALF OF AS
FORMULA EARLY AT TO SEAT
MINISTRY PULL ADVANCED OF THE
TRANSITION CAN'T. WE THINK THAT
THIS PURPOSE WILL HELP IN
FINALLY COULDN'T THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP BY PER IT
BEFORE IT STARTS THANK YOU
BRING EVERY FORTY OLD. TO A
HIGH PRE PUBLIC. IN ALIGNMENT
WITH EASY COALITION- EARLY AT
EDGE APELA ANNIKA. TO MAKE IT
BY INVEST ACROSS OUR- STEP BY
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE CHILD SLOTS
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S START OF
THE HUNDRED PER NEW. AS WELL AS
BY INCREASING REIMBURSE RATES
TO THE PROVIDE JUST CLICK THE
WERE FORCE THE THING ON THE
LINE OF THIS CAR ANTIQUE CREEK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIG
PLEASE. DIVINA SIX TWO THREE
THREE YOUR LINE OPEN. AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER BOB HOFFMAN
COLOR IN ON THE OF COUNCIL PER
THREE AMERICA REPLICA FIGHT
INVEST KIDS. READY NATION AND
READY. WE ARE PLEASED TO HIM
BACK INCOME SCHOOL AFTER SCHOOL
PER. AND THE AT THIS. HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDCARE SPOT
PROPOSED. MEDICAL WE ARE THE
EASY. COMPARING BUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND BOB AREN'T ADEQUATE
MEET THE DIRE NEED FOR ZERO TO
THREE KAREN CALIFORNIA. AND THE
ATHLETE AND THE- HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOUGHT BE FUNDED. WE
ARE EXT KIND ABOUT A PROVIDER
PROVIDER WE AND RATES INCREASE
BY THE INCLUDED IN AND URGE
THAT WE THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ARMAR BASED ALL ABOUT. AT FIVE
FOR ABOUT MY WE ALSO THAT FEED
WAIVED WHEN THROUGH SEPTEMBER
TWENTY. WHAT ARE TO TRY OKAY.
WE DO IT AS A TOOL AND A THREE
NEXT CRISP AND WANT TWENTY THAT
ARE YOU STUDENTS EIGHT ZERO ARE
NOT LEFT THE- FAMILY CHOI MUST
BE AT THE CENTER OF SYSTEM WE
MAY. AND THAT CHAU CARE. OF
CAPITAL AND REMAIN IN EFFECT
PART OF OUR- AS THEY ARE THE
BACKBONE TO OUR SUCCESS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONCERN. THANK YOU.
THANKS BAKER PLEASE. SENTIMENT
EXPRESSED BY SEVERAL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TODAY. BUT MORE IS
NEEDED FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. WITHOUT THE
ADMINISTRATORS LINE BUT THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE.
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. TO REQUEST ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE COVER
NINETEEN SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUND. THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER. SIX
HUNDRED PER FIGURE SERVER FOR
YOUR BUT THAT'S- EQUITABLE
OUTREACH TO FAMILIES AND
ALTERNATIVE RESOLUTION PRACTICE
THAT. THE PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THE NEED OF STUDENTS
MEDICARE THE POTENTIAL
ASTRONOMIC COSTS OF THE STATE
ELLIE. NEED TO INCLUDE THE
NINETY SPECIAL EDUCATION FUND
AND ASSEMBLY ADVOCATES PACKAGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. NUMBER LINE NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT NINE EIGHT ZERO IS
OPEN. THIS I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
MY IS NEED FIFTY NEED THAT KIND
OF- DIRECTOR AT CHILD POLICY
AND THANK YOU FOR THE- COULD TO
YOU. WE ARE IN UNIT TO MAKE
CRITICAL NEEDED TO ENABLE
SOMETHING CHILD AND STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO BETTER
CHILLED AND TO BUILD A STRONGER
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE SYSTEM
I WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS TODAY WITH THE- COLD
WHEN WE ALL ADMITTED BRITAIN
CALM TO THAT. ADDITIONALLY WE
LOOK AT THE TWO ONE TWO BUDGET
THE FEDERAL FUNDS AND THERE IS
MUCH CAN BE DONE TO STAY AND
BUILD UP THAT CARE SO. WE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE AND-
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO MADE DID
NOT IN PROTECTIONS FOR KERN
EDUCATION PROVIDERS WE INCREASE
AND STAND INCREASE THE PROFOUND
ACCESS STRICTER CON PER. AND
FAMILY CARE IN. SPECIFICALLY WE
WANT A HIGH THAT WE ARE VERY OF
THE HOLD FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO YEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PUTTING THAT IN THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL I'M ALSO WE ARE VERY
SUPPORT OF A GREAT REFORM FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION ABOUT RACE
THAT YOU ALL HAD TODAY- AS WE
KNOW WE HAVE A REPRESSED RATE
SYSTEM AND THIS REALLY NEEDS TO
BE A- ADDRESSED. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ESTABLISH A
SINGLE REGION LINE'S
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA- THAT WILL BE A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO RIGHT
SIZE OUR REIMBURSEMENT RATE
STRUCTURE STRUCTURE TO
INCENTIVIZE PROGRAMS FOR
INCREASED QUALITY WHILE
RECOGNIZING REGIONAL AND AGE OF
THE CHILD COSTS DIFFERENT SAID.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
RECOMMEND EXPANSION TO CHILD
CARE SPACES INCLUDING TITLE
FIVE PROGRAMS DIRECT
CONTRACTING AND ABOUT YOUR
PROVIDERS UTILIZING ONE POINT
SEVEN FIVE BILLION IN FEDERAL
AND GENERAL FUND DOLLARS THERE
ARE STILL VERY LONG WAITING
LISTS AND ARE ELIGIBLE CHILDREN
WHO ARE NOT RECEIVING CARE WE
ALSO KNOW OUR DIRECT
CONTRACTING GENERAL CHILD CARE
PROGRAM FIFTEEN MINIMALISM'S
AGENT AN INCREASE OF OVER PAST
YEAR. IN FACT THERE ARE SOME
COUNTIES IN THE STATE THAT HAVE
NO GENERAL CHAKA. ALTHOUGH THEY
HAD A LITTLE CHILDREN AGES.
THAT THAT SHOULDER AND- THE
PROGRAMS ARE. AND READY TO GO
AND JUST NEED TO FIND TO
PROVIDE THE CARE. LASTLY I LIKE
TO KNOW THAT WE ARE TO. OF THE
PARENTAL CHOICE FOR YOUR- IN
FOR G. K. L. CHILDREN. WE
RECOMMEND ALLOWING. TO IN THEIR-
HEALTHCARE. FOR THE- YEAR
BEFORE TO. SHOULD THEIR PARENTS
GUARDIAN REQUEST. WE WOULD ALSO
BE OPEN CHECK TRAILER LANGUAGE
TO OPEN UP THIS PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM TO SERVE CHILDREN YOUR
FIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME SHARE APPRECIATE THE
COMP. THANK YOU. ON OUR ALLY
NUMBER NINE TWO NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBER MISTER CHAIR THANK
MEMBERS UNDER PERRY ON BEHALF
NO HUNGRY. I'M SPECIFICALLY
CALLING ISSUE NO THREE THIS AND
WILL MAIL PROGRAMME INCLUDING A
HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING FUNDING
AND A HUNDRED MILLION BY TIME
FOR TO THE SCHOOL KITCHEN AND
FOR STAR UPGRADE HEY AND
TRAINING FOR OKAY. STAFF WE
APPLAUD GOVERNOR NEW FOR IN
INCREDIBLY AND WORK AND
PROVIDING SICK ONGOING FUNDING
TO IN THAT EVERY IN THIS HAD
BACK TO. THEY NEED TO LEARN AND
THRIVE. THIS IS A GREAT PERSON
TOWARD ACHIEVING MALES FOR ALL
OF FOR ALL CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PLEASED TO CAL RIGHT THE
CRITICAL FOR ME PLAIN CHILLED
HEALTH AND AS- OUTCOMES. WILL
MELT YOU CAN AND NEEDS PER IN
EVERY OF THE HAVE DONE WORK
THROUGHOUT THE CHIU ENSURES
THEY BANK WEATHER THE LEARNING
FOR HOME OR IN THE CLOUD.
BEFORE THE FEDERAL LABOR TO WE
URGE THE LIVE ANY MINUTE TO
PLAN ON HOW TO LOCAL HOW TO
SUSTAIN SCHOOL NOW ACT FOR.
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN AS WE LOOK
PROVIDE HIGH CHILD SUPPORT TO
BOTH HER VULNERABLE Y. TOOL AND
VERY DARK ROBOT INCLUDE CHILD
MAIL WE MUST. IMMEDIATE
RELIEVED- FOR SCHOOL NEXT
PROGRAMS INCLUDING TO BE
CHILLED GOING TO CRY AND AVOID.
LET HAVE BANNED A CRITICAL TOOL
TOOL TO ADDRESS HUNGER IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TO ENSURE
THAT UNIVERSAL BREAKFAST LUNCH
AND OUT OF SCHOOL MALES ARE
INCLUDED IN THE 202-120-2018
BUDGET WITH SUFFICIENT FUNDING
TO MAKE THIS A REALITY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME HAVE A
WONDERFUL DAY. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT I
WANTED TO CHECK ON ME. OKAY AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
NINETY THREE NINE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN LINE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN- THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY GOD
THAT THE LATINO COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA. LOOK PRETTY
FIFTY THE GOVERNOR'S SUPPORT
FOR MEDICAL EDUCATION IN THE
FORM OF FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
TOWARDS MEDICAL GRADUATE
PROGRAM. ARE NOW MORE THAN EVER
INVESTMENT IN MEDICAL EDUCATION
ARE SORELY NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE DIVISION WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
IN OUR STATE ESPECIALLY DURING
THE FALL WILL HELP PANDEMIC
HOWEVER THIS ALLOCATION WILL
NOT COVER THE PHENOMENAL UCLA
INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL GRADUATE
PROGRAM. WE ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT A ONE TIME
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS BUDGET REQUESTS THAT
WILL SUPPORT YOU DALY BEIJING
NATIONAL MEDICAL GRADUATE
PROGRAM. YOU JUST KNOWS THAT
THE SPEAKER SAID THIS IS THE
THIS IS NOT THE HEARING FOR
THAT I'M NOT. CERTAIN WHAT
HEARING. I BUT CAN THAT IS BUT%
NOT TODAY'S. HERE SO. URGE YOU
TO GO ITEM OF DATA. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLACK. YES IT'S WELL
THIS IS SUBJECT ARAMBULA STEP
ONE STEP TWO FOR YOU SEE IS
TOMORROW BUT I THINK THAT'S
REGARDLESS IS NOT TODAY SO. ARE
YOU TO GO BACK AND FIGURE THAT
OUT THANK THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. YOUR LITTLE LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIVE THAT'S ONE
ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
KATIE HARTMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND WE SUPPORT MANY OF THE
AUGMENTATION. REVISION AND
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR TO
GLOBAL TO REVENGE PROP NINETY
EIGHT YOUR COMEDY- NEED TO SHOP
KAPITI K. WE ALSO URGE
BLUDGEON. LEGISLATURE TO
INCLUDE A STATUTORY FIX FOR-
THE ACT THAT THE RAP
CALCULATION IN THE BUDGET
WITHOUT THE BANK AND THAT.
NINETY HEARING SHE WILL BE
REDUCED BY APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED BILLION ANNUALLY AND
GROWING EACH. YEAR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. EVERLIGHT NUMBER
FORTY TWO THAT'S FOR TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I DONIFER AT NINE
FIFTEEN OF A WOMAN IN
CALIFORNIA I AM OPTIMISTIC AND
MAGICAL IN A CAR THAT I
PREPARED. IT IS IN THE-
ARCHITECT YEAH A DISABILITY A
LOT THE FACT THAT THE PANDEMIC
HAS BEEN FOR MY FIRST YEAR
THIRTY AND HAVE BEEN CUTTING
THEIR ACCESS TO SUPPORT AND- DO
NOT SUPPORT SERVICES. WHEN NOT
I WOULD LIKE TO STATE MY
SUPPORT OF THE COMMON NINETEEN
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDS I
RECOMMENDED INCLUSION TO
SUPPORTERS OF THE NIGHT I. WHAT
DO YOU WANT ME ANY GROUP. CALL
US THAT'S RESPOND SPECIAL
EDUCATION IN THE MAY REVISE. I
WOULD LIKE TO RESPECT. INITIAL
FIRST LEN THAT GUY THE
EXTRACURRICULAR. THREE ARE
THINGS BATES THAT THEY WANT.
SUPPORTERS ARE THAT THE NUMBERS
DURING CLOSURE ARE PERSPECTIVE
THAT CRANE SB NATION STANDARDS
RIGHT AD STUDY THE CENTERS
ALSO ENSURE ACCESS TO THE
ACCOMMODATIONS THAT BRINGS ME
TO PARTICIPATING IN INDEPENDENT
STUDY PROGRAM RIGHT I LIKE TO
RECOMMEND THE INCLUSION OF A
CONDITION FOR FUNDING FOR SOME
PROGRAMS THE PARTY BECAUSE THIS
IS A GREAT PROGRAM BERNIE MAC
BUSINESS STUDENTS PROGRESS THE
NINETEENTH THANK. YOU THANK YOU
THANKS BAKER PLEASE. WELL I
NUMBER ONE HOW AND THAT'S ZERO
SEVEN LINE IS A- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEN COME OF THE- FOR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH AND THE CALIFORNIA
AFTER SCHOOL AT THE FELINE. AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORTING AND GROWING EXPANDED
LEARNING AND ENRICHMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. THROUGH
AFTERSCHOOL AND SUMMER PROGRAM-
AND ADDS EXPANDED LEARNING
PROVIDERS AND ADVOCATES WE WANT
TO BE SURE. THAT THESE PROPOSED
INVESTMENT SUPPORT THE STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES THAT NEED IT MOST
AND FOR YEARS TO COME. AND FOR
THIS TO WORK WE ASK STATE
LEADERS TO ENSURE THREE KEY
PIECES- IN THIS PROPOSAL WINE
IS ADEQUATE PER PUPIL FUNDING
DAILY RATE FOR ALL STATE AND
FEDERALLY FUNDED AFTER SCHOOL
AND SUMMER PROGRAMS. THEY CAN
MEET INCREASED DEMAND AND
HIGHER COSTS TO OPERATE AND TO
PAY LIVING WAGE TO THE WORK
FORCE THAT IS AN ESSENTIAL ON
HER RELICS THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. NUMBER Q. A DATA AND
STAKEHOLDER INFORM PLANNING
PROCESS I TO MAXIMIZE THESE
INVESTMENTS AND ALIGN VARIOUS
PROGRAMS INCLUDING REFORM
EFFORTS OUTLINED IN CURRENT
LEGISLATION- AND THEN THREE
SETS OF. PROVIDES SUPPORT FOR
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES AND
WILL BE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
SERVE MORE STUDENTS GIVEN THE
CURRENT SCHOOL STAFFING
CHALLENGES. BUT WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH A LETTER AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL IN THE
DETAILS OF THE PROPOSAL THANK.
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
CONVERSATION TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANKS PLEASE. WHAT A LINE
NUMBER TWENTY NINE TO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO I AM NANCY
BY IT PUBLIC POLICY CHAIR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILD
CARE NETWORK. WE ARE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CHILDCARE LAWCENTER. WE WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT MANY FAMILY
CHILD CARE LICENSEES ARE
EDUCATED AND MANY CHOOSE TO
MEET HIGH QUALITY STANDARDS. WE
AGREED THAT RATES NEED TO
INCREASE FOR ALL. AS WE LISTEN
TODAY WERE WONDERING IF THE
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR
INFANT CARE IS BEING COMPARED
TO THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE HER
FAMILY CHILD CARE INFANT CARE
AND THE HIGH COST OF REGION.
THANK YOU. WAIT A MINUTE I
FORGOT ONE WE ARE WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT A SHIFT TO FREE
HE K. WILL RESULT IN THE
CLOSURES OF NOT ONLY HIGH
QUALITY CENTERS BUT ALSO HIGH
QUALITY FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES
THAT OFFER PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
INFANT TODDLER CARE AND CARE
DURING NONTRADITIONAL HOURS.
NOW THAT. THANK YOU CAN EXPECT
YOUR PLEASE. WHAT A LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHT ONE ZERO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS ENTER INTO WE ARE
YOUR EMPLOYEES REVEREND LAYING.
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S NEWLY
REVISED PROPOSAL I FOR ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OLLARS
ARE FOR SCHOOL MEALS. WE THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT DOWN PAYMENT.
BUNDLE PAYMENT ON UNIVERSAL
SCHOOL MEALS I WOULD LIKE TO
CONTACT REJECT GAP OF 50% OF
SCHOOLS. AND THE DIVIDENDS THAT
WILL PAY OFF FOR EDUCATIONAL
BENEFITS AND ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS. ARE YOU ARE HARD TO
EVEN PUT INTO WORDS. WE SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BUT A LINE
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS%
IS ROBIN LAYTON AND EDUCATION
RICHMOND SYSTEMS AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
POLICY COUNCIL. WE ARE A
NONPROFIT IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AND WE HAVE TWENTY TWO CENTER
BASEBALL DAY YEAR ROUND AND
PART DAY PART YEAR EARLY
EDUCATION CENTER. AND WE STAYED
OPEN FOR IN PERSON IN DISTANCE
LEARNING CAR SENT TO WORKERS WE
EMPLOY A HUNDRED NINETY
EMPLOYEES THAT LEFT THEIR HOME
EVERY DAY TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
POTENTIAL WORKERS TO PUT THEIR
LIFE ON THE LINE DURING COLD
THE TO DO THE RIGHT THING. THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION MUST
RECOGNIZE THEM THANK THEM AND
SUPPORT THEM WITH THE
PROFESSIONAL WAY I AM VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION MAY REVISED DID
NOT INCLUDE PROTECTIONS FOR
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROVIDERS RATE INCREASE THE-
POTENTIAL INCREASE THAT. WE
MUST CONTINUE THE HOLD HARMLESS
I CAN ADDRESS THIS FURTHER IN
DETAIL BUT WE DO HAVE STUDENTS
ENROLLED AND WHEN THEY HAVE A
WHEN WE HAVE A TEST POSITIVE
CASE THE CHILDREN STAY HOME. TO
DISTANCE LEARNING FOR FOURTEEN
DAYS SO THAT IS NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR NEW ENROLLMENT
THIS WON'T CONTINUE UNTIL
CHILDREN GET THE VACCINES.
GREAT REFORM MUST BE A PRIORITY
BEFORE EXPANSION FIFTY K. FOUR
YEAR OLDS THIRDS THREE TO SIX
HOURS PER DAY WITH THE FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT
WHY CAN WE NOT ALSO FUNDS. S.
P. P. AT FIFTY EIGHT RIGHT AT
THE SAME RATE THE STATE HAS THE
MONEY. THE STATE MUST ALLOW
CHILDREN TO REMAIN IN THE S. P.
P. BOTH FULL DAY YEAR ROUND.
BEFORE THE FIRST YEAR CAN MEET
OF THE PROBE THAT SUPPORT
PARENTS. AND WORK. STAYED OPEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC COULD YOU
OF. IF WE HAD THIS AS A
PROPOSAL AS PROPOSED DURING THE
LAST YEAR FOUR YEAR OLDS JUST
LIKE KINDERGARTEN CHILDREN
WOULD HAVE BEEN STUCK AT HOME
INSTEAD OF IN OUR POGRAM.
LET'S BE CLEAR G. K. IS NOT
CREE QUE. AND REALLY AT THE
STATE HAD THE FUNDS TO FOUR
YEAR OLD WHY HAVE WE BEEN TOLD
FOR YEARS THAT WE DON'T. WHY
THE INEQUITIES DISRESPECTFUL
PROPOSAL THAT. FOUR YEAR OLD
THE BETTER OFF IN G. K. I THE-
HAVE BEEN EDUCATING FORTY OLDS
FOR ALL. SIXTY YEARS. JUST
INCREASE THE RATE SO WE CAN PAY
THE FEE SB TEACHES THE SAME AS
A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER WHY TAKE
FOUR YEAR OLD THE WAY. GREAT
REFORM IN THE CURRENT NEXT
DELIVERY SYSTEM ACCOMPLISH OUR
GOALS AND DO THE RIGHT THING
PRESIDENTIAL WORKERS. AND THE
TEACHERS THAT CARE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN BIRTH THROUGH FIVE IF
YOU CAN HEAR. I AM SAD
FRUSTRATED AND DISAPPOINTED FOR
THIRTY SEVEN YEARS I HAVE
SERVED THE COMMUNITY. H. CREEK.
AND I HAVE ADVOCATED FOR HIGHER
WAGES FOR THE TEACHERS ONLY TO
WITNESS THE PROPOSAL TO TAKE
THEM AWAY. HOW EXPENSIVE TO
HEAR THAT SHE K. CAN TAKE CARE
OF ALL THE MEMORIES THAT.
TWENTIETH BP. HAS BEEN DOING
THIS. FOR OVER SIXTY YEARS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. EXTRALITE
ONE AND NINE THAT'S ONE EIGHT
ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD ACTORS DANIELLE MAILLET
WITH A CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
JOBS FAMILY SERVICES I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE MINISTRATION AND
THE LEGISLATURE WITH A FOCUS ON
STUDENTS IN FOSTER CARE AND
WHAT VEHICLE HEALTH NEEDS. WE
SUPPORT THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
COMMUNITY THE PROPOSAL IN THE
BUDGET AND THE ICLUSION A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE EXPERTS AT THE RIVER
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THE KIDS.
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND IN OUR
HOME THANK YOU. YOU WILL GET A
LINE NUMBER NINETY NINE THAT'S
NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- MARKET GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
EARLY EDUCATION ISSUES SO PROUD
THAT YOUR- ARE. MA'AM MY
REPRESENTATIVE HERE WEST
SACRAMENTO WHERE I LIVE- JUST A
ONE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH-
THE ECT COALITION AND- SEEKING-
FOR THE RATE INCREASES AND ALL
THE OTHER COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN REFERENCED- BY. PREVIOUS
ADVOCATES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR HARD WORK IN THIS EFFORT.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
WHAT A LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND TWELVE THAT'S ONE ONE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I THANK YOU-
AND- GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY-
MY NAME IS ALI KING AND WHAT
AND THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
MANAGER PARTY AGAINST THE
PROJECT CALIFORNIA. AND A
COUPLE THINGS- FIRST BOX WE
WANT OUR HOPE THAT ENCOURAGE
THE MEMBERS TO ALIGN WITH THE
EASY COALITION. REQUIRED AND
THEN ARE ALSO AGAIN- WE WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR TREMENDOUS
GRATITUDE TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY FORD LEADERSHIP HI NEED
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO PRESCHOOL
AND PK- AT THE MOBILE REPORT AP
HOPE SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT
HAPPENS AND IT DOES SO IN A WAY
WHERE MOST NEEDIEST CHILDREN
HAVE. HAD ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM
FIRST. I AT ALSO A FOR
COMMUNITY'S BUT- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE EARLIER- TOLD. FROM
AGES ZERO TO FIVE. AND PROGRAMS
SERVING SUCH FAMILIES HAVE
ACTED TO THE FUNDING AS WELL-
WE CONTINUED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION TO AND
BUT AND AFFABLE BUT YET. AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR
OPPORTUNITY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LAW. THE YOU.
WILL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THAT'S ONE ONE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
MICHAEL HOLE SIZE AROUND BE
AFTER THE KERN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS-
MEMBERS MISTER CHAIR IT JUST
GENERALLY WE WANT TO COMMEND
THE GOVERNOR FOR AN OUTSTANDING
MAY REVISION. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION TKA PROPOSAL AND WE
AGREE WITH THE L. A- THAT THE
PROPOSAL IS SUBSTANTIALLY
IMPROVED. SPECIFICALLY BY
INCLUDING IN GUARANTEEING
ONGOING FUNDING THROUGH THE
REBATE CHECK A PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
A FIVE. POINT OH SEVEN- PERCENT
COLA- COMMITTEE ON YOURSELF BUT
WE ASK THAT THAT CALL WITH THAT
SAME PERCENTAGE BE EXTENDED TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S FOSTER YOUTH
INTERVENTION AND SUPPORT
PROPOSALS THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS- STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMUNITY SCHOOL
EXPANSION- WE AGREE WITH CITY-
CHIEF CONSULTANT OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHO SEES THIS AS-
SIMILAR TO THE HEALTHY START.
PROGRAM IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES AND WE WOULD AGREE
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION THAT
PERHAPS. THOSE GRANTS B. BE
CONFORMED ARE ALIGNED WITH THE
PLANNING A LUNCHEON ON GOING
COORDINATION GRANTS OF HEALTHY
START- GREAT IDEA AND THEN
LASTLY. WE WANT TO ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF ED. AND ASK THIS COMMITTEE
TO TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT THE-
TREMENDOUS DECLINE IN ALL TED-
AT A- GLANCE BY THE PANDEMIC
AND- CONSIDER AN EIGHTY EIGHT
HOLD HARMLESS EXTENSION FOR ONE
YEAR ON THE. PROGRAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. WE'RE LINE NUMBER ONE AND
FIFTEEN THAT'S ONE ONE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MONICA AND I'M CALLING
IN SANDY HAVE EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATE AND THE CHARM
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK.
AND ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE THOSE KIND OF TWO
DOLLARS. MILLION AND I'M GOING
FUNDING TO ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE IN ONE OF THE
FEDERAL UNIVERSAL MAIL
PROVISION AND ALSO A HUNDRED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE LOCATION INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES. WE BELIEVE THE FALLS
SHORT AND MAKING SCHOOL MEALS
FOR ALL PERMANENT CALIFORNIA
HERE'S THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION TO BEGIN
PLANNING NOW WITH THE SAME
PHONE APP. WITH FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU- WE
WILL ADJOURN MOMENTARILY BUT
JUST WANNA SAY TO ALL ALL THE
PRESENTERS- WE HEAR YOU THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT TOPIC FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND OUR FUTURE AND-
WE KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU UP PUT
YOUR PASSION IN THIS IN THIS-
FIELD INDUSTRY FOR DECADES AND
SO CUT KEEPING GAUGING WITH US
AND- THAT 100% SINCERITY THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THIS YEAR
AND THAT WE CAN. FOCUS ON
TRANSFORMATIONAL INVESTMENTS IN
EASY AND HAVING HAVING IT BEEN
WIN WIN WINS FOR EVERYBODY
INVOLVED SO. WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.